this machine learning course starts at
the beginning and goes all the way to an
advanced level teaching you both the
theory and applications of machine
learning concepts ayush who teaches this
course is a data scientist and machine
learning engineer hi everyone and
welcome to this course of machine
learning this course will teach you
machine learning from very basics to an
advanced level in machine learning in
this course this and this course will be
having both theoretical plus practical
understanding of machine learning
algorithms and building real world ai
projects after this course you will be
you will be able to build your own
machine learning applications and
real-world applications and many domains
okay but wait first who am i my name is
ayush and i'm a data scientist at
artifact i'm in standard nine from india
i've worked on various applications of
artificial intelligence like machine
learning deep learning i've worked on
various domains from deep learning which
is another computer vision generative
adversarial networks and nash language
processing i've also contributed to the
large ai projects and routine by andana
okay so this is this is my basic uh
skills and also i run a small youtube
channel which is not as near now not a
small a big youtube channel which is
around we have a 500 members where we
when i where i make a content on machine
learning deep learning and various ai
things and i put end-to-end courses
there currently deep learning course is
being launched so you can start watching
after this completing that start this
course that deep learning course okay so
that's that's that is from my side and
you can connect me on linkedin if you
want to know over more about me and i've
also cleared some microsoft exams so you
can get to know more about there about
me okay i'm also a founder of android
and ai tech platform and also product
based platform okay so that's it from my
side and i hope that you will get a lot
more from this course now let's discuss
the syllabus of this course
we will start with the very basics of
machine learning covering the
fundamentals of machine learning in the
section number one and then it will go
further into understanding some
algorithms like linear regression a
logistic regression support victim
machine principal common analysis
learning theory and some in symbol
learning methods like bagging boosting
stacking cascading and then we'll talk
about unsupervised learning and you may
think yeah you sure you would you wanted
to teach this much no absolutely no in
this this is a 10 plus hours of course
so absolutely there is a lot more
content so this this course is divided
into sections and each sections have a
different sub sections so you and i have
made a full syllabus talks what topics
i'm going to cover in each and every
topic or something a section divided in
a sub section and you can assess the
syllabus by visiting the course website
the course website i premade with um are
made with my friends friends of andrew
so you can definitely go there and
assess all the syllabus all the problem
sets of this
of this course and each and every
section you will be you you'll be having
one problem set and all of these is in
the description down box below okay all
of
where the time stamps as well as the
course world notes okay so are all
available on the course website so you
can go there see what's assignments are
there complete that and join our discord
server to just to discuss your
assignments and you can also submit it
through forum okay
so this is the basic syllabus that we
are going to follow and i really hope
that it worked a lot in preparing the
materials for this course teaching you
all in the blackboard and understanding
you're helping understand each and every
topics of machine learning in a very
very very easy way and this course has
extensive syllabus a very good syllabus
uh to um which i have which i haven't
seen on youtube youtube okay so please
be sure to see the syllabus what we are
going to cover just have told you in in
just shot the reason is i i want to just
start with this uh video so i've given a
shot you can see the syllabus by
visiting our course website for
absolutely free everything for
absolutely free you can go to the course
website which is the link in the
description that box below so let's
start with the section number one
fundamentals of machine learning okay so
now we'll start with machine learning in
this section you will get an
introduction to machine learning and
we'll talk about introduction to machine
learning types of machine learning and
there are types and we'll see some cool
applications and then we will see some
problem of overfitting and under fitting
and then we'll wrap up this section okay
so let's start okay so now we'll answer
a question
what is machine learning and you may ask
here you sure this is very uh can you
tell what actually machine learning is
yeah you will get to know more and more
about what actually the big picture of
machine learning means you in depth when
when we will go through this course but
in simple terms
machine learning is like this computer
programs that uses algorithms to analyze
the data and make intelligent
predictions based on the data without
being explicitly programmed and you
might think hey are you sure
what is kind of this um it i'm getting a
little bit confused no worries so let's
um let's get into this and let me
explain you what i'm saying over here in
this blackboard so you are given a data
you are given a data okay and then you
give to the algorithm
the algorithm the algorithm analyzes the
data analyzes the data
analyzes
the data and
whatever he has analyzed or learned from
the data it makes predictions based onto
that it makes
predictions under that
okay so specifically what we were the
what what we are doing we want to make a
function x that maps out input variable
x to the output variable y and you may
think here you're sure confusing me what
is x what is y no worries
x is the input feature x is the input
feature means uh let's take a problem
statement of predicting the house prices
predicting the house prices okay so you
want to do this so uh here on the basis
of the size of the house so
on the basis of size of the house
you want to predict the price
of the
house okay so you give an input variable
x and you get outward variable y okay so
on the basis of the size of the house
you want uh the price of the house okay
so you wanted to make a function so you
wanted to make a function
f
that takes input x and maps that to y
and that's the definition of machine
learning that's the beauty of machine
learning so what we were doing we are we
want to have we want to map our input
variable x maybe it can be maybe the
size of the house maybe the
number of fans of the house maybe the
number of our bedrooms in the house so
i'm denoting with a subscript one
subscript to subscript three and we want
to make a function that maps these input
variables to the output variable which
which we did denote with y which is the
price of the house and that's what and
that we are doing
and we will learn how to make this
functions okay so that's the beauty of
machine learning which you can see over
here so let's see some of the more
formal definitions which you will see
you more over the internet then the
machine learning is the field of study
that gives computer the ability to learn
without being explicitly programmed
saved by author samuel but one
definition that i said to use totally
means if you if you if someone asks you
hey hey whatever your name uh what is
machine learning you just ask hey i i
know a better way to define a machine
learning you just make a fun geo just to
make a function that maps your input
variables to the output variable okay
and that's the beauty or that that's
called the machine learning and i hope
that's you that you that you got it what
i'm what i'm trying to say you hear and
access are the input features that you
that you wanted to on the basis of that
these are the input input features and
the basis of that you want to predict
the price
okay the another definition of machine
learning is the computer program is say
to the learn from the experience e with
respect to the sum class of a task t and
some performance measure by p if its
performance on t as measure by p
improves with experience e and this mean
seems a little bit intimidating but let
me clear this definition is very uh
my my favorite definition although this
this is my favorite definition that i've
shown to you but let me tell you what
the definition tells you the definition
is so before that let me take one
example which is let's take an example
of checkers okay playing checkers
playing
checkers i hope that's you no no no
let's let's take another because many
other people do not play checkers over
here okay so let's take a spammed email
spam detection system email spam
detection detection
system which you will make in this
course
yeah you will make this course you will
make this into the course okay so this
is a problem statement and what's what's
the let's fit that definition onto this
problem here t
is the detecting the emails means
detecting whether the email is a spam or
not so let's let's denote zero as uh
detecting a spam or one as uh
okay so let's say let's say ham
and e is the experience of his
prediction is the experience here e is
the experience of detection and p is the
performance how much performance
increases upon to the experience so in
this way higher the experience is best
the system is but i think this is more
formally fit to something called a
reinforcement learning which will not
see the advanced learning but
again the definition which you have to
take is you wanted to make a function of
function f that maps your input
variables to the output variable and
that's machine learning and or you can
say that's the beauty of machine
learning
okay so some of the applications of
machine learning there is um i just
listed on a few but there are a lot more
self-driving cars real estate stock
price prediction and medical we have or
corbin 19 detection maybe
using chest radiographs and then uh
disease prediction cancer detection etc
and then it's just a boom and i highly
encourage people to get into this field
and try to contribute to the world in a
unique way okay so you can see over here
some some of the applications of machine
learning so how it works
so what you do uh let me get to get back
to my boat and how it actually works all
this how it works
it's kind of a very easy
how it works uh first you study a
problem so again let's let's take a
problem let's take a problem of again a
spam detection
spam detection detection
system okay i i think the c okay so to
make a span detection system so first
you study problem you have a look at the
data how actually the data is
okay so first you do this the second
thing is the basic workflow the second
thing you train the algorithm and
algorithm is just a function it's just a
function okay f of x which you will uh
how it is defined which you'll see later
on but you just
have a function which is algorithm this
is this is the algorithm
algorithm and you train with this
algorithm and then you go further into
evaluation evaluation you evaluate it
into uh you give a new train new emails
and check which is correcting for
correct or not and then if it is good
then you launch the system then you
launch the system
launch the system otherwise
otherwise you
analyze some error you do error analysis
you do error analysis and then you go
further into tuning or improving your
algorithm or evaluating your uh and then
you evaluate then again do that do like
this so that's what machine learning is
called ml is very
very iterative process iterative
process which you will see in more and
more loops why this term that but but if
beginner don't worry about it okay but
if you want to get it after this course
you can get to my gans course or maybe
the deep learning course
or uh
maybe another course which is dsa which
which i'll talk about that is very
important and then you can head over to
the ml oops videos okay so this is the
basic you can you can head over to that
and learn something new from there
okay so uh what are the types of machine
learning systems since there are uh i
think the three types of main main
machine learning systems are three types
supervised unsupervised reinforcement
learning and although there is few more
which is batch learning transfer
learning active learning passive
learning and etc which you which you can
learn obviously when you go further no
when you go further means into more into
machine learning then you will see that
uh how you are learning these all and
you learn to grasp each and every
content a few
minutes okay so what are supervised
learning supervised learning uh let's
let's let's go get back to my boat again
and let's take an example of another
example which is my favorite uh no not
not my favorite but yeah it's a house
price prediction so i'm just providing
about house
price prediction
prediction
problem registry system okay so this is
a house price prediction so you have a
feature uh let's let's let's denote that
on the basis of the size of the house
size of the house
i'm just taking example because in the
real world the size of the house thus
the fan number of fans in the house
number of bedrooms in the house on the
base of the butt just for now uh for
predicting this from the size of the
house you want to predict the price of
the house
you want to predict the price of the
house which is which we denote as a y
and whatever we give whatever we take as
a feature we denote this as a x okay so
there is uh we denote there is only one
one feature which is x1 and only we are
getting a one output which is y
okay so uh we have we provide x1 means
the size of the house and we are getting
the price of the house as an output okay
so uh
you can see over here that we have uh
size and we have a label
means we have given the price and the
model can learn from this house the
trend is how the trend is on
it can recognize patterns okay so you
can see over here that our data is
labeled as a y means we know what our
output so it learned from their label
and input that's called the supervised
learning how you can identify the
problem is supervised
because you see the target variable
which is called the target this is
called a target variable
and this is called the features
features or variables okay
and the one we want to predict is called
the target variable so we this is the
features or variable so you see that
there is a relationship between your
input value x and the output value y
input value x and output value y well
i'm saying it has some relationship
because you can see over that we are
given the size of the house and going to
predict the price of house so you can
see over the entirety is that they have
some kind of relationship and we know
what our output should look like in this
case we know what our
our output should look like in reduction
it's kind of a continuous output our
output will be in continuous value so we
know what our output should look like
and that's called supervised learning
okay so i think you i i think it's going
good means you're understanding what i'm
saying so in simple terms you can see
the definition of a hill we feed the
data and this the data are labeled means
that the output variable which we denote
as a y are labeled and which we give
which has some relationship between our
input value x and the output value y
okay so in the unsupervised learning uh
which which i'm not going to go to dig
dive just now and further i will i will
be digging dive into this
so we the data are not labeled and we
can say that we don't know what our
output should look like and there is not
kind of any relationship between what
are what will be our input variable and
what will be the our output variable and
we have to recognize our patterns based
on the data for doing so we have
different algorithm which we'll study
later okay so i'm just not digging
digging type but in simple terms
but in simple terms what i what i'm
saying that
let me let me tell you what i'm what i'm
saying
okay so uh
let's say you this these are the t-shirt
sizing you want to you have a different
different t-shirts and we're denoting
this as t-shirt so we have a different
different t-shirt and what else
and this is our data this is our data
and you have to
then you have to simply classify or
cluster it out so whatever what your
model will do it simply make this as a l
it simply makes this as xl and simply
mix as an m okay so it's just uh make
clusters it makes cluster
xl and l and for now i don't recommend
to brainstorming these things because we
will first we have to understand fully
supervised learning then it will most
much clear uh unsupervised learning so i
don't want to dig dive into unsupervised
learning for now but you can see what
the definitions are cut to cut okay so
let's start let's keep deep diving a
little supervised learning so what are
supervised learning so in supervised
learning um we know our output variable
and input variable etc that i would just
explain your house price prediction so
in supervised learning we have two types
of problems the problems of supervised
learning can be classified into two
types so let me write it a supervised
learning problem supervised learning
problem can be classified into
regression problem
regression problem and it can be
classified into classification problem
classification
problem okay so let's keep talking about
what is regression what is
classification so i'm gonna take take
one example which is a house price
prediction which is a house price
prediction means house price prediction
and we can see over here that our output
will be in continuous value because
super supervised learning and we know
what our output is so you can see over
that output will be in continuous value
continuous
value
okay so your output is in continuous
value and classification and in
classification uh let's say
given a picture x means the often uh you
want to classify an image of a picture
as a cat
or a non-cat
or a non-cat
okay so um you're gonna picture x um you
wanted to uh identify this as a cat or
non-cat okay so you can see here but
that is a binary it has only two it is
it is a it is called a degree value it
is called the degree value means we can
now classify that in regression if our
output of the problem is in continuous
value that's called that that's that's
that is a regression problem if our
output of the particular problem is in
degree value we can classify that as a
classification problem and you can see
over here the definition is the same
okay
okay so
why we need to divide our data so let's
let let me talk about because i'm
talking too much about data but what is
data it's this question arrives a very
good question that i want to ask by
myself
is data are the they how does data looks
like in data let's say let's take an
example of an application a system that
is a price of the house
house price predictor okay so
the data will look like this
so i'm just just making a data frame so
you have a size of the house then you
have a number of fans then you have a
number of bedrooms then then is the
target variable which is the price so
these are your x these are your x and
this is your y okay and what you do uh
let's let's take nine square feet two to
twenty two i'm just taking as a thousand
et cetera just a thousand dollars i'm
just taking as an example don't think
that is a nine it's a nine square feet
size of the house don't don't think like
that
okay so uh this this is kind of thing
uh so this this is kind of thing and we
have a size and we have a number of fans
we have a number of bedrooms okay so uh
what you do uh here you can see over
here that we have a data we have your
data
and what you do you divide your data
into training
into training and testing set
into test training and testing sets so
let's say you have a hundred percent of
data if you take 80 percent of your data
for training or model and 20 of your
data for testing the reason why you take
this to evaluate your model because you
from where you will get all those uh for
testing so you just keep 20 20 for
evaluating so check how how best your
model is okay
so this is the evaluation of the data
which we'll see more later on okay so
there are two problem that i want to
highlight is uh
overfitting and under fitting okay so
what is overfilling so let's take an
example again i just i just i just
believe in examples
okay so here is your x and y plane i
hope that everyone remembers in in in
their school days oops what is happens i
hope that i drawn correctly okay so you
have this uh these features let me draw
it very
quickly
this is your data points and what you do
uh you simply draw a straight line you
simply draw a straight line to make
predictions okay so let's this is your
input which is x so it's a 2200 square
feet so it will go over here and check
what is the price so it will give here
okay so like that it will make
prediction which we'll see later on so
you can see over here that
in under fitting in underfitting and
under fitting what happens
if your model if your model has not
performed well onto the training data as
well as when testing data means in under
fitting your model does not perform well
under the training and the testing data
means uh your model is performs bad
under training and the testing data it
means because you don't have a large
number of in a large number for data you
can you can simply add more data okay
but what happens in under fitting can
then you will tell me what happens in
under fitting so let me highlight this
little bit
let me
so in under fitting if your model has
learned too much this is because when
you have too much of features so let's
say your uh it
will try to touch each and every point
it will try to touch each and every
point
and this is called and you can see if
you if you have a if your model learned
too much and it is generalizing very
very well
very very well onto the training data on
the training data but it fails to
generalize well
fails to generalize well
on testing data
testing data then you can say that your
model is overfitting okay so you can see
over here that the diagram is over here
and you can see with that under fitting
which your does not feed a straight line
a very good way and good fit is a good
good good model you can just fit a
straight line and in a bad fit over fit
it okay so
the solutions of this which you'll see
later on but before that we'll touch
some algorithms and again some notations
which i've already taught you x means
the input features x1 x2 all the way
down to xn y means the output features m
means the number of training examples
and here let's say 600 training example
which you will get to know
more further which when when we will go
more further into this course
okay so now we are done with this uh
introduction of machine learning and i
really hope that you enjoyed this
tutorial and in the next section we'll
be talking about one of the algorithm
which is linear regression and i hope
that you will really enjoy that so let's
meet at the next section
okay so now we will briefly talk about
supervised and unsupervised learning
with adaptation and some cases studies
and data sets so to fully understand
what happens in supervised and
unsupervised learning okay so let's
start
so
uh what happens in supervised learning
and supervised learning as the name
suggests someone is supervising over
here i will take an example of a data
set to help you understand better okay
so in supervised learning uh what i have
told you in the in the previous session
is about in machine learning that you uh
in
in supervised learning we make a
function f of x that maps your input
variable
to the output variable okay so here in
supervised learning we have the input
data
input data as well as the output data
okay
means here as an example that we have
this data set
we have this data set just assume that
we have this data set
and here we have this outlook feature
temperature feature means x1
x2
then we have a humidity as x3
windy as x4 okay and here this the red
one play tennis so here is our problem
statement is given on these features
outlook temperature and humidity and
windy we have to predict whether the
whether that boy will play tennis or not
okay so this is your target variable
this is your target variable or or the
variable that you want to predict okay
this is the target variable or the
variable
that we wanted to predict
that we want to predict so it is given
in this case so it is given in this case
so here uh we have our x variable as
well as y variable as well as the y okay
as well as the y variable okay so we're
going to make a function f of x using
this data that maps our input value all
these features x1 all the way onto x4
uh
do a y variable okay so we'll give input
whether there is sunny or whether you're
hot or high or false and given on this
feature the function will give you
output whether it will play no or yes
okay so here and this is a supervised
learning problem because we have our so
we have our labels which you can see
over here okay so and you can also see
that we have a some kind of relationship
between our input value and our output
value why as you can see that
and these are there is there is some
kind of relationship like a male
stylistic example of house price
prediction so given an input feature
size you want to predict the price of
the house of the house of the house so
it is on a shame name so there is some
kind of relationship between our input
feature x and the output feature why
okay another another property of
supervised learning is that these
features which are input features are
our independent features our independent
features
are independent
independent
features what do i mean by independent
features they do not have to depend on
any and any feature they don't have to
depend on any feature but this target
variable y is a dependent feature
because the target of y is depending on
these features it's depending on these
features to be mapped and is depending
on these features so that's why
x1
x1
x1 all the way down to the x i i equals
to 1 all around to the k means x 1 x 2 x
3 x 4
is a independent feature which you call
usually as an indian independent
variable or feature and y is your a
dependent variable or feature okay so
that's the that's that's called the
features um the supervised learning so
let's um so let's let me write a basic
definition or a good definition of
supervised learning what what is
supervised learning a good definition
okay
so the good definition of supervised
learning is here in supervised learning
we have we have our input features x we
have our input we have our input
features
x we have our input feature x large x
and just assume that x large x this
contains all features in a vector all
the way under the x i okay okay so we
have input we have our input feature x
and also we have our output feature y we
have our output feature y
output feature y y and there is
some kind of there is
some kind of relationship some kind of
relationship
between the input value x and the output
value y
and
and
x is called independent feature
x x feature circle independent feature
and y is the dependent feature because
it is dependent on to the input features
okay so we have seen here so show you an
example that there is a y there is a y
that is used to train uh using x okay
this is that using x and y okay so we'll
be able to uh predict our mod so we will
see in the next section how we make a
predictive model okay as a part of
linear regression so let's see some of
the so um but before that i want to i
wanted to uh just to show you that there
are two parts of supervised learning
first one is a regression second one is
classification classification so what do
i mean by regression you know what your
output will look like because here we
know that what our output because we
have already seen our data so you can
see the output is in decreased value
what do you mean by degrade value your
output is in finite means either it will
be yes or no so here if it is integrate
value if you know that your output is in
degree value then you then you then you
consider that as a classification
problem how you identify that is a
classification problem when your output
is in degree value and when your output
is in continuous value means um
it's not finite maybe the age of the
person maybe the stock prices that is a
that is continuous okay so that's why if
your output is in continuous then it's a
regression if your output is degree then
it's a classification okay so let's see
some of the applications of supervised
learning to help you understand more
better to get the feel of supervised
learning so in supervised learning we
have our favorite uh in supervised
learning we have maybe the stock price
prediction stock price prediction we are
you are given closing price high closing
high then etc maybe some volume and
predict what is the
stock price and on the maybe the you
want to predict this you can consider c
close as a target variable you want to
predict what what with the closing price
basis on high and volume okay so high in
volume are your independent feature and
c equals c will be your independent
feature which will be the y
next is maybe the house price prediction
maybe you want to basis on the size like
that you want to predict what will be
the output why
and maybe uh let's do example of a
classification problem given you want to
identify whether the person has a
diabetes or not basis on maybe the age
gender bmi etc
okay so we have this output variable y
okay so these are some of the
applications of unsuper sorry supervised
learning okay so now let's see so
unsupervised learning as i'm not going
to go deep dive into this uh
unsupervised learning there is a next
section that there is a particular
section after supervised learning we
will cover the in depth about
unsupervised learning but the core idea
behind unsupervised learning that in
this case in supervised learning we are
given x i as well as y i for uh for each
uh for every i equals to 1
all the way down to the m and m here is
the number of training examples means uh
okay so that's m here is means we have
for we are given i okay so here yeah in
super supervised learning in supervised
learning we have this in unsupervised
learning the unsupervised learning we
have only x i's we have only x i's we
don't have y eyes
you have only x i we have x1
x2 x3 all the way down to the xm
okay we don't have the label y i there
is no supervisor that will guide you
okay and what you have to do let's take
an example um you have
you have this
uh so uh here is your data set so here
you have a channel reason fresh milk
grocery frozen detergent and delicious
so let's take an example that uh
unfortunately is used in markets market
segmentation segmenting your customers
so you have these features and you don't
have the whether the person with you
what you do you just cluster the person
which has similar nature you have you
just clustered the person let's take an
example that these person use used to
eat milk these person used to that so
you cluster this out you cluster this
out okay then you can hand code it okay
these person used to eat milk and then
you can send promotion to these people
or big deal another thing to these
people so you can identify your business
needs etc from these clusters either i'm
not going to give deep dive into the
application etc but i will go deep dive
into the application everything but as
of now i hope that you understood
supervised learning in that okay so
that's it for this uh
just a small uh video on supervised
learning and unsupervised learning and
the next section we'll be starting with
actually the math and then we'll leave
dive into the machine learning the
beauty of you will see the beauty of
machine learning okay so let's meet at
the next section till then do the
problem sets
so now we have seen an introduction to
machine learning and i hope that you
have really enjoyed that section now
it's time for getting enhance your dirty
into the maths now we will see some
learning algorithms which is linear
regression and then we will do one
project which is boston hot springs
prediction so i uh so i'm very excited
to
have your first learning algorithm in a
toolkit so head over to the next section
okay so now we will see one algorithm
which is a linear regression which is a
learning algorithm um as in the in our
previous section we have seen a machine
learning and an introduction to machine
learning now we will see how to make
that function f of x that maps that maps
your input variable x to the output
variable of i okay so before that i want
to recall something which is in
supervised learning in super advised
learning we are we were having two types
of problems
first one is a regression problem
the second one is classification problem
as you might think okay so
linear regression as you know as you can
see from the term regression it's a
regression algorithm so it's a
regression algorithm that we'll study
today okay in this section
okay so let's recall what is regression
it's it's a type it's it's a type of
supervised learning and supervised
learning algorithm and here we know our
output will be in continuous value our
output will be in continuous value means
let's say let's let's take an example
that you want to predict the price of
the house let's say you want to predict
the price
of the house okay so you can see over
here the output of this particular
problem will be in continuous value we
don't have any kind of decreased value
so we can identify that this problem is
based on to the
uh
regression problem okay so let's let's
let's start see let's ski let's see how
this algorithm works in much more detail
so that you could get more intuition
about and you can ace an interview on
linear regression and also i'll be
putting some entropy questions over you
of what someone can ask you and what
someone not okay
so let's assume that we have a scattered
data so let me make one x and y plane i
hope that this is good pretty good
and let me make that one okay so i'm
just going to make the scatter data that
looks like this
okay so this is your data and let's take
as a problem statement as like this
let's take a problem statement which is
predicting the price of the house based
on the size of the house so let me write
that predicting
the price of the house predicting the
price
of the house
and this is the end in rupees so
price of the house based on the size of
the house okay so you will give x which
which will be the size of the house and
you will get the y which will the price
of the house okay
okay
so we have the scattered data and in x
axis we have our size
which is our input variable
and in y-axis we have our price
okay so what we do we fit a straight
line we fit a straight in linear
regression we fit a straight line like
this we fit a straight line which is
called the hypothesis which is called a
hypothesis and uh regression term this
is called the hypothesis which we'll see
how we can compute the straight line so
we make this straight line and you can
see over here that after making the
straight line we can make predictions so
let's say that this is this is the size
and based on this we are making the
prediction like this onto the y-axis
okay so and again let's say the prime
let's say the size of the house is 2200
square feet then the price will be like
this uh 2 22 000 etc so like like like
this we are making predictions okay and
you can see over here this line is
little bit far away from the actual data
point so that's the issue that that
we'll see later on but you just
construct a straight line that touches
each that that closely touches each
point or definitely that is closely uh
uh passes through this tray uh
scatter data points okay so let's see
how we can compute the straight line
because linear regression as you know
linear means it constructs a linear line
that separates the data okay
okay so let's see how it works
so in
for making a straight line as i've
already told you this is called the
hypothesis so how we construct
hypothesis so this is called the
hypothesis function we compute
hypothesis function like this we have
weight of every features so let's say
theta 0 times x 0 plus theta 1 theta 0
time times x 0 plus theta 1 times x 1
plus theta 2
times x 2 all the way down to the theta
and times x n okay so
you're summing it all up so what what i
what what you can see over here
that
what you can see over here that
we have the status and we have these
features this is th this is the let's
say the size of the house let's say this
is the maybe the number of fans in the
house i'm just taking the problem
statement predicting the price of the
house so so that's why number of a fans
in the house and and etc okay so these
are the features x1 x2 and x0 is the
biased term is the biased term or the
y-intercept or the y-intercept maybe if
you know about inter-intercept of y
means if x0 equals to 0 then your line
will be crossing from the origin if x 0
equals to 1 then it will be from 1 if x
0 equals to 2 then it will be from 2.
okay so it determines the y intercept
from where he wants to make a straight
line okay so we have this theta zero
times x zero theta one times x one theta
two times x two all the way on to theta
x times x x n and let's take a
particular problem statement and let's
understand that but before that you may
think hey use what is theta here what is
theta here
we only have to learn machine only have
to learn this theta machine only have to
get the best theta now we are able to
make prediction now let's say we we take
theta zero let's take we take theta zero
to be
uh uh two okay and theta one to be
let's say three theta two to be four
okay so just i'm taking only uh two
features and one bias term which is the
this this is the bias term and these are
the two features and x zero is obvious
is always equals to one x zero is always
equals to one so that's why we never
write x zero okay so that's why we never
write we just write uh theta zero plus
uh theta one times x one we did not
write but i just just have showed you so
for a clear ratio of those things okay
so you can see over here that uh let's
let's take an example that this we have
two features like the size of the house
and the number of fans on the basis of
that you have to predict the price so
for each feature we learned the weight
these these are called the feature
weights these are called the feature
weights so we learned this and if we get
the best feature weight we will getting
the best prediction if we get the bad
feature weight we'll be
getting bad prediction okay so let's say
uh let's let's construct the problem so
let's say your theta 0 to be 2 times x 0
which is x where x 0 equals to 1 so it's
obviously true plus theta 1 which is
like let's say theta 1 is 3 as of the
end times the size of the house plus the
theta two before times the number of
fans in the house okay so now this now
using this you can make the prediction
you can just plug in the size and you
can plug in the number of fans and you
will be getting your desired output why
okay so
just now you may think hey machine
learning is not we are not it we are
only using it as a computational power
and you can see over here that how it
how it learns theta will which we'll see
because machine learning is totally
based upon learning parameters okay so
you will see how the theta is learned so
let me tell you uh thetas
we have to only learn theta we have to
only
learn which will see the techniques
where we have to only learn
theta
we have to only learn theta and if the
theta is bad then then you then your
hypothesis when the function is bad so
this is your function this this
constructs your function like this
theta one times x one plus theta two
times x cubed all the way down to the
theta n times x n and and here they
denotes the number of features and
features are the columns okay and the
data okay so uh this is a function and
you can use this function to map your
input variable to your output variable y
okay so that's it that's that's kind of
our we have our kind of a
function that maps our input variable to
our output variable okay
okay so now i think the twos that said
that we've got how we construct that a
straight line and using this function we
can construct that a straight line and
we have to only learn these these this
this is called
these are called the feature weights
these are called the feature weights and
these are called the feature weights and
this is the bias term or the y intercept
uh from where the
the the line should originate as i've
showed you earlier okay
so uh now i hope that you got a
intuition about hypothesis function
okay so now let's keep talking about uh
the vectorized form of this means the
vectorized form
is
maybe vector vectorization means how
here we are separately computing for
each values we are computing theta zero
then times x zero theta one times x 1
means separately for each value so in
vectorization we do at once we do at
once so what we do we put over all the
thetas so we put our so i'm just writing
vectorized form
vectorized forum so we put our all theta
we put our all theta
it will be in joint vector theta and uh
let me do this theta zero theta one
theta two all the way down to theta and
and theta these theta this is the
feature vector this is the feature
vector which can which is all the
weights you will further see that yeah
we have to only learn this then you will
believe me that yeah we have only have
to learn this whether it's a neural
network but it's a machine learning okay
so you have this base theta into joint
vector theta and you take a giant vector
x and you store all your x's over there
x 0
x 1 x 2
x 3 all the way down to the xn okay so
you take this and then you take out the
dot product okay so then you take out
the dot product and theta
times dot product okay so now your
hypothesis f of x will be like this okay
so you just give this function and
thetas what what it will do it will uh
theta zero times x one theta one times x
one it will sum sum it all up theta one
theta two like like this broadcast it
okay and it is computing at once okay so
you can draw and then some sum it all up
okay so so you can write in summation
format
i equals to 1 all the way down to the n
or i equals 0 all the way around to the
n theta theta i times x uh let's say i
okay so so you are doing it's a
vectorized form of that and you can see
over here
and python is very easy just one line of
code uh like like this you just do like
this np
dot dot
theta
and x
done okay so it's very easy in python so
don't worry how how we can code this all
it's quite easy
okay so now we have seen the hypothesis
and and we have seen the vectorized form
of this linear regression okay
so
you may think hey i use how i can get
this theta but before that how we can
evaluate your theta is best means your
thetas are good your theta are good so
for evaluating our model we have
something called cost function we have
something called cost
function okay so why we evaluate a model
to check
how are p if our theta is good or not
okay so we check because
using that theta we are making
prediction we are multiplying with the
features and we will get feature these
the size we will get from the user we
will this game fan number of fans get
the user we multiply with the weights
and then sum it all up and then we give
the result okay so this is the cost
function and here uh what why why we use
cost function to evaluate our model okay
so
you you will get to know how what what
we do so let's say uh
we have a scatter plot so let me plot on
a scatter plot like this again the same
i'll be doing the same
but this time little bit more crunchy
yeah i think so
okay so this is this is my plot and what
we do
we simply draw a straight line uh this
this is your hypothesis this is your
hypothesis which is f of x and what this
cost function will do this is your this
is your actual data point these are your
actual data point and these these are
your actual data point it will what it
will simply do it will simply take out
the distance between predicted this this
is the predictor that i'm highlighting
and this is the actual okay so this is
the predicted this is the sorry this is
the predicted and this is the actual
this is the predicted this is actual
okay so it takes out the difference
between or the the it takes a distance
between like like this predicted
minus the actual value predicted minus
the actual value like this
uh yeah like this and
and then sum it all up means higher the
this uh cost function will be better or
more or less higher the cost function
will be better your moral will be and
less the cost function will be
good your moral will be the reason why
if your if your points are on this line
and your cost function will be zero
because the predicted will be zero sorry
let's say predicted will be all the same
and actually will be also the same so it
will be resulting in zero so just what
what we do we this these are called the
residuals in terms of uh
cost function so we just take out the
distance between predicted and actual
value for all data points okay so this
is the cost function
okay so uh let's rest forward to
formulate this in a formula
let's formulate this is the foreign
formula like this
uh let me show you how we can formulate
that yeah so you just take out of j of
theta i'm just denoting j of theta will
be like the uh
short form of cost function because we
are checking how our theta is good or
bad or not okay because it only
determines whether your model is good or
bad
1 over m 1 over m and m here is the
number of data points
plus
i equals to 1 all the way down to the m
and you just model predicted value less
let's denote the model predicted value
by y hat and how how we have we got y
hat yeah we have got y hat like this y
hat equals to uh f of x
equals to theta times x means dot
product of theta and x which is
equivalently equals to the hypothesis
okay so we let's let's note as a y hat
minus y
okay and in other words we can write
this out like this
in other words we can write
write this out like this theta transpose
x i
minus y i and this this is just a
hypothesis h of x okay and transpose
like this
are you you
your uh
x will be like this so you make this uh
theta will to be like this
okay so it will be easier like this okay
so this so that's what this transpose is
doing but
if you can do or not just just we are
doing the this uh let me write that
theta
times x okay the dot product between
theta and x minus y i
okay minus y i for each and every day at
a point we are taking out the difference
between predicted and actual value and
then we're squaring we had a squaring
here because it helped us to and further
call something called the gradient
descent okay for easily derivation of
this cost function you will see why i'm
taking derivation term over here okay so
in other words it's this this this this
is called the loss function which is
known as mean square error m s e
okay which is called the mean square
error if you square root this if you
make this
let me show you what i'm telling
if you square root over 1 over m
plus
i equals to 1 all the way down to the m
theta x i
minus y i
squared if you square root this like
this
okay this this is called the root mean
square error
root mean
root
mean squared error okay and higher this
and better your model less okay
okay that's just just we are taking the
square root
okay but we'll stick with this um mmc
but in real world a million kaggle
competition they have given what they're
going to use mainly i have seen rmse to
be used very much okay so uh after we
got our cost function it tells okay your
model is that good or that bad now if
your modeling that how you can optimize
or how how you can get optimal theta
means best theta how you can get the
optimal theta this is the great question
to ask
okay so how are you how you're going to
get this optimal theta for getting that
we have something called gradient decent
something called a gradient decent
algorithm
gradient decent algorithm which is known
as the optimization algorithm which is
known as the optimization algorithm
which will help us to get the best theta
okay optimization algorithm okay so uh
let's let's stick dive into this uh
algorithm and let's understand how we go
get this kind of thing so let's say our
the visualization of the cost function
will be like this okay just just for the
sake of an example i'm visualizing like
this okay so this is this is your cost
function i'm just writing as a z of
theta this is your cost function and now
your cos
cos here use is your theta where the
cost function is very high okay so here
is your theta okay so what gradient
descent does it tweaks the theta means
let's see your theta is zero then simply
let's say it's mismakes theta little bit
to 0.2 okay it tweaks the theta it
changes theta a little bit and if the
cost function decreases then updates the
theta to be not like this to be like
this if the theta go down means the cost
function little bit
decreases then it changes again 0.3
if the cost function decreases then it's
do not make this then it's
uh update this theta okay then again it
simply tweaks checks if the j of theta
going down if yes update the theta okay
until and unless your cost function is
until unless your cost function is
approximately equal to zero
okay so that is simply the gradient
decent it's very very simple that i've
just shown to you so let's let's further
formulate this mathematically because
it's very very simple when we formulate
this as a mathematics so how we simply
what what we do for tweaking these
things for tweaking the theta we take
out the partial derivative we take out
the partial derivative of your cost
function j of theta
now you will think hey i use you have
why why you have taken the calculus name
i'm not a calculus student i'm not kind
of that don't worry at all at all it's
kind of it's i just want to give you one
definition of a partial derivative
partial what if what it does it simply
tweaks your theta it simply tweaks your
theta and checks if the cost function
decreasing okay and it's just like the
slope it's just like the slope but you
don't need calculus you don't even need
calculus yeah if you want to go on a
research level then you obviously need
but for now for a machine learning you
don't need calculus for deep learning
even you don't need calculus just um
just you can just what what this
equation is doing it is just it is just
uh
tweaking your theta tweaking your theta
a little bit so it gives us like this
two over m so it gives us two over m
plus
i equals to one all the way down to the
m and this is a y hat minus y squared
okay so this the after after deriving
this partial we we get like this okay so
now after this we do uh we do we take
out the partial derivative for every
theta means theta zero theta one theta
two theta t all around the theta and we
do for all theta we take out the partial
derivative of all theta and then we up
and then we update our theta so here is
a full gradient decent algorithm so what
what what we do
we simply write theta z
this is the
update kind of assignments theta is a
minus the learning rate alpha and the
kind of a partial derivative of your
okay partial derivative of your cost
function okay so what we are doing this
is how this this is uh this this is this
will be our new theta that i've just
shown to you we update the theta so this
this is your old theta means the bad
theta this is your learning rate and
what rate your uh uh this is the hyper
parameter which i will talk about in
just one second in detail but what we
are doing over here we are this this
this the alpha determines the rate means
if the alpha is too large if the alpha
is too large it will go like this it
will never converge it will be like
diverging like like this if your theta
is very small then i think that it will
never converge at local minimum it will
be like this it will never converge at
local minimum so the optimal theta that
i've used till now it's a 0.1 for larger
data data set 0.01 for okay for a little
bit to smaller medium data set 0.001
a little bit more smaller and
0.0001 okay so these these are the
optimal uh for me i have seen so far is
these alpha but you can tune it you can
tune it using um grids or cv or
randomized search cv which we will see
later on okay
okay so i i just say to you why by this
theta it just determines the weight of
your uh tweaking the parameter okay just
going down and this this this gives this
is the simply the partial derivative of
your cost function and we are updating
this this this will be our new theta and
this is whole
algorithm of gradient descent okay
okay this this just just equations tells
us the whole algorithm for gradient
descent okay so now again i'm going to
talk about uh vectorized bottom how we
can vectorize this okay because i i
totally believe in vectorization so
let's tell
what what what we can do uh here we are
in the pre previously we are taking out
the partial derivative of theta zero and
then we are taking the partial
derivative of theta 1 separately what we
can do what we can do
and we can simply put that into uh
like like this partial derivative into a
joint vector theta
into a j of theta with respect to zero
kind of this
and like this
all the way down to the n okay so you
just put into the giant vector and you
just take out the partial derivative of
whatever you want to take out and then
and then you just uh write the
vectorized form theta z
theta z minus
the learning rate alpha and that gives
us like like this 2 over m
times the x transpose
x theta x theta
minus y and this is your new um derived
equation which is a vectorized form okay
and yeah yeah you can definitely use any
any kind of this this is totally okay
but for vectorization you can follow or
not it's your opponent but for
computational powers just just have told
to you okay so we have seen so far and
now we are done with this we have
developed our linear regression model we
first have developed the model from
making predictions and then then we have
moved further to check how our theta is
good then we have seen how to how to get
optimal theta okay but you may think ask
here you see i have to do these kind of
things yeah you have to do these these
kind of things for getting your and
and if i did if i say truth uh the truth
is in scikit learn you can implement
this in three lines of code you can
implement this whole algorithm into
three lines of code in some library but
in programming assignments you have to
implement from scratch this algorithm so
that you can ace any kind of interview
okay okay so um
you may ask there is something called
the normal equation there is something
called normal
equation that that i want to highlight
little but normal equation gives you a
better theta in just one way means
normally patient gives you a theta
optimal theta in just one equation like
this so equation is x transpose
x
inverse of that x transpose y and for by
you by using this and x here is the data
points it means the features so you can
simply use this uh formula for getting
the for for getting your optimal theta
okay this is just the same as doing this
but
not in every algorithm it will work it
will only for linear regression the
normal equation is only for linear
regression and i hope but
having a good intuition of all those
because in interview they usually ask
this they don't they usually talk about
normal equation
okay they don't all talk about normal
equation the usual talk about this
gradient descent etc although there are
too many optimization algorithm some as
like gradient descent in gradient
descent we have this and then we have a
stochastic gradient descent we have a
stochastic which is called hdd we have a
atom optimization algorithm we have rms
prop
rms prop and then gradient with momentum
which we which you will see advanced
level in
uh i will talk about hdd pattern atom rm
rms prop and some more optimization
algorithm or convex optimization
advanced as um which you will ever see
in deep learning okay okay or you can
head over to the newer of it and do deep
learning courses currently learning and
you can learn from there okay okay so
now we are done with this and let's
little bit let's literally spend some
time on to some assumptions of a linear
regression okay because in an interview
they usually ask why you wanted to
choose this algorithm instead of this
algorithm or what is the assumptions of
this algorithm etc so the sum of
assumptions um of a linear regression if
the issue it should have a lean linear
relationship linear relationship the
data should be linear the data should be
linear and
no or little multi-collinearity
the code the correlation between uh
variables would be uh no nothing okay
no
or little
multicollinearity
multicollinearity okay you can see ac
internet for more
okay so now we have seen some
assumptions but i want to just i want to
give you the things what is independent
and dependent feature independent means
the size of the house
the pro the number of fans and number of
let's say the bedroom so these are the
independent features because they are
not independent
to any feature for the kind of any value
but the target variable y is dependent
on all these features so that's why the
target variable is called the
independent sorry dependent and these
are called
independent okay so this is just a
casual information to know because
everyone talks about this
okay so now i think that we have talked
very very much in small amount of time
and i hope that you really really enjoy
this tutorial
and i'm putting all my effort then you
can go on to my youtube channel new era
new era and you can subscribe that
youtube channel if you want okay okay so
um now we have talked that and in the
next section i'm going to go over uh in
theory pattern i'm going to go over
polynomial regression but let's spend
some more amount of if i have time let's
spend two more minutes onto polynomial
regression okay so there is something
called a polynomial regression as we
have seen the assumption that data
should be linear but let's say our data
is not linear then what we do okay then
what we do so let's say your data will
be like let's say your data is like this
your data is like this
your data is like this so you if you
feel fit like this then it is obviously
overfitting so what you do you just
simply transform your data you simply
transform your data to be like this into
the quadratic form you enter the
quadratic forum to be uh you just simply
transform this one one degree to the two
degrees so it will confirm
like this
okay so you two will be transformed as
let's say
four and six uh threes maybe transform
that's a nine and whatever what whatever
it was just so i'm taking an example
okay so you transform your data to be
fitting over the linear so you transform
your data to be fitting over linear now
your uh algorithm will be fitting like
this okay so now i hope that you have
gone everything about polynomial etc now
we will talk about it we'll do some past
and house class prediction and then
we'll move on to the irregularized
linear models okay so let's head over to
the uh boston hospital prediction and
then we'll move on to the regularized
linear models okay so now we have seen
linear regression and we have done one
project now it's time for getting your
hands dirty in the programming
assignment you will be able to find the
programming assignment description box
below in the sign-in page okay so now
we'll start with logistic regression
after doing assignment come at the com
come again and follow up with this
course so now we'll talk about logistic
regression and i hope that you will
really enjoy this okay so now we have
seen linear regression which is one of
the regression algorithm now we will see
one classification algorithm with this
logistic regression don't worry uh don't
think that this legislative question is
a regression algorithm no it's a
classification algorithm so because the
name is logistic regression because the
underlying working of this algorithm is
same as
is
something similar to linear regression
okay so
you will get to know about this how it
differs from linear regression okay so
before that let's uh let's be clear
about we are on the same page about
close classification what is
classification okay so this is a great
question to ask to yourself what is
classification
so let's take an example
given in range x you want to classify
this image as a cat if it is cat then we
will name it as zero if it is non cat
then we will name it as a one okay so
this is a tweet value our output is
indicated value and the classification
is a supervised learning approach so
this algorithm is a supervised learning
algorithm so
here we know what our output should look
like so here our output is in degree
value so we can classify this as a
classification task okay so that's the
specification and something called the
binary classification and we have a
multi-class classification also called a
multi-class classification means uh
maybe the person has a cancer person has
a pneumonia etc this means integrated
value your output is in finite value
value okay so we have this
classification and uh this tool so now
it's time to study about legit
regression in detail and
so what we do in legitimation we
classify the data we classify the data
so uh let's start with hypothesis in
linear regression we have our hypothesis
which is uh
hfx let's stay known as h of x
equals to the in legitimation we also do
the same theta zero times x zero plus
theta one times x one plus theta two
times x two
all the way down to the theta and times
x n okay so in linear regression we are
doing the same for drawing a straight
line and here we are also doing the same
for a function and this is and this this
this will be uh for linear regression
and the same for a legislation and this
is the step this is the fourth step for
hypothesis and the second step of
hypothesis means the more predicted
value equals to the sigmoid of h of x so
let's denote this as a short form of z
okay so this h of x is g and g here is
simply h of x and h of x is here theta
zero all over theta so we're gonna name
it as a theta transverse x
okay so you just here you just
do the sigmoid of your head h of x which
is which is your
prediction function so you just
do do the sigmoid of this z and you get
your output and you get your output so
let's say what the sigma does you get
your output from legit logistic
regression and this output makes the out
this uh the this whatever the output
came let's say 22
22 to between zero to one the sigmoid
the if if you apply sigmoid to this you
apply sigmoid
to this then it then it makes your
output between the range of zero and one
and you then you set the threshold if
and you set the threshold if you're the
model particular y hat is greater than
uh y hat is greater than 0.5 then yeah
this picture is a cat okay otherwise if
it's smaller than 0.5 then it is a non
cat okay and this is what it is this is
what we are doing in linear regression
we are just this is this this was our
hypothesis but in addition we add a
sigmoid to our edge of x and the reason
why we add sigmoid uh it's it's totally
because
uh that we want our output between zero
and one in the range of zero and one so
that we can make prediction like this so
uh just you apply sigma and the formula
for sigmoid is 1 over 1 plus e to the
power minus z and z here is h of x okay
so this this this will be your whole
hypothesis this is your prediction
function okay now you just put the z and
theta you have to one learn theta you
have to learn these thetas which is
called the parameter it's again the same
as a linear regression okay so what we
are doing we are just uh
doing the same as uh
first the first step we are doing same
as a linear regression and then we are
applying a sigma at that h of x and then
um we are getting the output which is
the which is in the range of zero and
one and uh we set a threshold 0.5 is a
threshold and if the particular the
model predicted y hat from this output
between the range is greater than 0.5
then it is a cat otherwise with smaller
than uh of 0.5 then it is a non-cat if
you want to be more uh
strict then you can make 0.7 the
probability is greater than 0 70 okay so
let's say you're more output like this
0.
80 okay so it is equal to the eighty
percent your model is saying that a
particular uh this image is a eighty
percent accurate that this is a cat okay
so you just make it as a one round of
two one means it is a cat otherwise if
it is a 0.4 t then it's 40 that is so
you make it as a non-count
okay so this is the basic thing that you
should understand is a prediction
function that we have made and again we
have to only learn these thetas um it
means we have to get these tt three and
these thetas together to get our good
output okay so this this was a legit
regression and then i and the hypothesis
for legit regression okay
okay so now in linear question we have
seen something called the cost function
something called as cost function and
cost function simply what this does it
simply
gives you the accuracy of the model
means if the cost function is very very
high then then your model is very bad if
your cost function is
low then your uh
then then then your model is good okay
so it helps it help us to evaluate your
model okay is the the loss function it
should be all the cost budget for a good
uh for a good
model your j of theta means the cost
function should be approximately equals
to zero
okay okay so uh in lecture expression we
have defined little bit different this
cost function like this uh let's do for
one training example like this j of
theta j of theta equals to minus 1 times
y i
the log
of h of x i
h of x sine plus
1 minus y i minus 1 minus y i
log
of 1 minus h of x i
okay so this this is your cost function
for for one training example
and you can see over here that
we have a cosplay one minus one times
the y i times the log of h of x i and
one minus y i uh times the log of one
minus h of x time so what we are
actually doing so let's break down this
equation and let's understand step by
step
okay so what we are doing here we are
doing why i
is the grand route is the ground root
ground with truth
and h of x i h of x sign is your model
predicted value which is the model
predicted value
and it's just taking the log of that
your model and multiplying with the y i
okay so let's say your y is equals to
zero your y is equals to zero and your
model predictor y hat is also equals to
zero then your cost function will be
approximately equal to zero because uh
they both are same so your boss
mentioned will be zero okay will be low
if let's say your
ground through this one and your model
predicted is equals to the zero then
this this is a mismatch your model done
very bad so your cost function will be
very very high okay so this is what the
basic integration behind is cost
function and this is your basic formula
and
again uh you can see over here that we
do this uh kind of for
oops what is okay so uh let let me write
the equation for m training example we
have done for one training example so
let's do for m training example so let
me write the equation for that
so you have a j of theta you have a j of
theta and
1 over m 1 over m
i equals to 1 all the way down to the m
y i
log
of h of x i
plus 1 minus phi i
the log
of 1 minus h of x i
okay so this is the log loss this is
this some sometimes called as log
loss in terms of machine learning so you
just uh this this is your calls function
that is used to uh use as a loss
function that we have seen so far and
i've given an example when the both the
output is correct me on ground truth and
your moderator is equals then your cost
function will be zero otherwise is if it
is different then your cost will be very
very high okay so this is the cause
function for your legitimacy model so
let's recapitulate the two things the
hypothesis and your
fault cost function so the hypothesis is
that
h of x equals to the
uh sigmoid of z and z here is theta
transpose times x okay the dot product
between transpose times x and you just
uh take the it's the equation which is
uh similarly equals to 1 over 1 plus e
to the power minus c and z here is just
a theta transpose x data transpose
okay so uh the theta contains the
parameter rates uh theta contains the
parameter base and x contains the x one
x x zero x one all the way to multiply
okay and in y convention we are using x
zero equals to one you can rewatch that
uh linear regression section once more
if you are getting a little bit confused
because i have expect i've gone a little
bit slow there okay okay so
and the gradient isn't for getting the
good for reducing this j of theta or for
getting the good optimal parameter we
use gradient decent algorithm and
gradient reason why it does the same
here is your theta we have the cost
function very very high this is your
cost function diagram so your cost
function will be very very high when
your theta is here when you change theta
your a little bit decreases over here
again you change again you change means
you're taking out the gradient of your
cost function and checking if it is
going down if it is then you just update
your parameter let's say theta 0 was
here to be
there i want to be here too then you
update it out one to be little bit 2.1
then your costs and decreases then you
do the same for getting into the
global optimum over here okay
like this okay so here's an equation for
the same so
how's the equation
uh you just uh
i'm doing it here theta is a for t is
just means of taking out a partial
derivative
j of theta
equals the one over m this this equation
after deriving from cos function the
decision equation forms i equals to 1
all around to the m x i minus y i
okay
and then you just add up some some kind
of um x j times x j
okay so this this is your calls function
that's it this this is the taking of the
partial deliberative although it might
change a little bit because everyone has
a different kind of uh but it's but it's
similar to many of them okay and then
you just take out the partial derivative
of your cos function j of theta and then
you uh update the theta by the by taking
out the gradient then you update the
data like this theta is a theta z minus
the learning rate alpha and this is your
uh this is your pre-previous theta and
this is a new theta is updated theta and
you are taking another partial
derivative of cos punch it and it's just
the same you just tweaks your parameter
and checks if your cost function is
decreasing or not okay
okay so we are done with the legislative
question and i really hope that you
enjoyed so let's recap recap and then a
little bit go further into vectorization
of this code
okay so what we have seen we have seen
hypothesis and hypothesis is given by
the
this sigma of z and is the simple 1 over
1 plus e to the power minus e and z here
theta transpose to x okay and then what
you do you have a cost function for
getting the
accuracy different model uh this j of
theta which is equal to the minus one
times y i
the log of this is this is that using
phi and
and for m training example you have that
and the gradient descent you just update
the this
where you just updated theta and theta
say minus the learning rate alpha and is
take out the partial derivative of your
cost bunch of j of theta okay and the
alpha here is simple the datum is the
rate of learning that we have seen
linear regression okay
okay so we have seen so far and now it's
time for getting into more detail about
vectorization uh what's the
vectorization means so factorization
means is
uh you just you hear you are taking some
amount of time but if you want to do at
once if you want to do all the
calculation at once so here is a
vectorized code for
uh
gram cost function okay so i'm right
writing for cos function which is a
vectorized code so here it is minus 1
over m times y transpose times the
taking of the dot product between y
transpose dot h
plus 1 minus y t
and transpose
dot
log
of 1 minus h okay and h here is your
model predicted and y here is a ground
throughout okay and as we had just
vectorized the code little bit
to get your
job done okay and a good way okay so the
gradient descent also a little bit
vectorized so here is a gradient descent
theta
this theta minus the learning uh this is
a partial derivative uh learning rate
alpha
m times
x transpose dot
h minus y
okay so this is then this is what you
get after deriving your partial
dedicative
okay so this is the basic thing that's
you should uh keep in mind about uh when
performing legit regression and i really
hope that you have enjoyed till now and
now if you if you can see but let's
summarize a little bit so that you can
get a more better feel what we have seen
so far
okay so legislation is a classification
algorithm that will classify our example
um that will give the probability after
you just apply the sigmoid to the z then
you get the probability means in between
zero and one you just get between zero
and one and then what you do you simply
uh take a threshold means if it is zero
if it is the if your output is greater
than 0.5 then you make it as a one
otherwise you make it a zero okay as a
convention we take one as a positive
indication means that the the image as a
as a cat is a positive indication and
zero at the images are not cat then it's
a negative indication okay you can take
anything but for convention you do this
kind of thing
okay pretty much easy what i'm trying to
say over here okay
so we have the hypothesis and we have a
cost function for a checking accuracy
for modern we have a gradient reason for
getting your best optimal theta and
again we are only learning theta over
here using the gradient descent
algorithm okay so now i think we are
done by the legislative regression and
in the next section we will go over to
uh
project which is breast cancer detection
system and then we'll go a little bit
further into understanding the support
vector machine okay and i really hope
that you will enjoy that section also so
let's meet at the next section okay so
here i am on my jupyter notebook and you
can download a jupiter notebook by
searching online how to download the
juba jupiter notebook and you can follow
the tutorials to download a jupiter
notebook okay so uh
what we will do we will first start with
uh
important libraries then we will load
the data we will understand what data we
are working on and then we will follow
the feature engineering then we will see
how to select features we will do
exploratory data analysis like data
visualization and data analysis and will
perform feature engineering and then
before and then we'll see how to select
the features on from the correlation of
the features and you know you don't need
to have any kind of experience with
pandas or although
you can have a look if you want to in
detail but you don't have to be expert
in all of these if you are just this is
just a beginner project you can also
modify it and put it on your resume and
make make some changes and what you can
do you can save this model and simply
deploy it over a website okay okay so i
will talk about deployment later on
but before that uh let's let's walk
through let let me make you walk through
this project so first of all we are
importing the libraries first we are
importing the numpy snp and we are
importing np as allies uh pandas as pd
pde is also alive to short form a name
plotly is another great visualization
library but i really use it i don't want
to use it for now but in future you can
use it plotly just just wanted to show
you i uh seaborn which i'm going to use
here and mathplotlab is also a
visualization library that i'm going to
use over here and this macbook live in
line tells you to use a matplotlib in
the back end okay uh it's kind of a tell
smart plot clip to choose the to plot
the images in the backend use use the
jupyter notebook as a backend okay so uh
first of all uh this is the learning
thing so we will load the data from the
scikit-learn library scikit-learn
library is a famous library for machine
learning so we'll load the data sets
from loadbuster which is a boston house
price prediction will make boston house
price prediction so you so we want a
data set of that okay then we
instantiate our
load boston and then we take our x which
is the data i will tell you what is x
and y over here and y which is a load
boston.target in our previous tutorials
in the introduction to machine learning
we have a talk about x and y variables x
variables is the independent features
which we which which we use to predict
the model and this is the y which is the
target variable because it's
unsupervised so we know what our output
is that we know what our output label y
is okay so um we will be given this and
x and y is the target variable which
will be in case in this case is the
sales price and this is the features
okay and then i call pd.data frame and
it con
constructs a data frame and we give x
which is the features and we give the
name of the columns dot feature names
there is a dot attribute feature names
to get the names of the columns
automatically okay and then we make one
column here we are making one column
which is a sale price we are making a
sale price and then we are making it y
over here okay ma why why means lord
boston.target either you can make this
also like this
either you can make this also it's just
the same okay y is just a target
variable and if you just run this now
you can see this is the data frame um
here you have a crime rate per capita
that let's see the column distribution
so i just first see let me show you what
we have done these are the x variable
till s l stat these are the x variable
and this this is the y variable that you
use to predict and you may think yeah
use 24.0
means 24.0 is the dollars is just the
price of the house no the price of the
house is given 20.0
thousand dollars okay so you can so just
just just we will see the whole thing
just a second okay so this is the data
frame that we constructed okay so now
let's take a look at what data we are
working on so there are 506 rows and
there are 30 numeric and categorical
columns and with the median value
attribute 14 which is our target
variable here i'm giving given is a sale
price name but you can give it a median
value it's usually the target variable
okay so here is the column name is the
crime is the per capita rate then the
proportion of the
residential land proportion of a
non-retail business which knocks age
what's the proportion of average number
of rooms per dwelling in stratfor you
can wait over here and the last which is
the
favorite the target variable which is
the median value of the which is the
sales price in this case in a thousand
dollars so 24 thousand dollars now you
know your dream has gone out i think so
okay so you're going to read it over
here just just you can use dot d c e d e
s e r because it is available in the
cycle learn so you have this kind of
thing to see the information about that
data set but in real world we will work
on real world data sets so you will see
how uv download how we process etc okay
so let's understand a little bit more
about the data we look at the shape of
the data which is 506 rows and 14
columns means rows and then columns then
your dot input tells us the information
of your data which is non-null values
means what are the data types and is
there any null values into that null
means missing values into that column
okay and all the data sides are float
what is the memory usage etc okay and
let's uh dot describe will tell you the
mean of that particular column the
standard deviation the minimum 25
percent of that 70 percent max count etc
okay so we had seen how what data we are
working on these are the features which
is the x variable and this is the
target which is why which is a
supervised learning problem as we can
see over here okay
okay so let's just take a look at the no
you can use data dot is no dot sum and
you can see over here that we have the 0
0 0 all the way and then we can plot a
pair plot sns dot pair plot which will
plot all the things which with respect
to every feature so you can see over
here that we are just plotting the pair
plot uh you can see but if you we we do
not get a lot of information from this
pair plot because it's very kind of
small and we cannot see what data is it
is it pointing on etc okay so we have to
definitely take care of that to do to
check more uh visual visualization that
i made okay just wait for a few seconds
then it will
show up
okay so it's plots and we are unable to
see this kind of thing and we are unable
to see so it's very hard to see this so
what what we do let's let's take out and
let's just take all the inferences from
the sales price this is which is the
target variable let's do some analysis
so we plot a distribution plot and you
can see over here this is a little bit
skewed we want it is we are we are
seeing over here this positive skew but
here we can add some transformation so
what's the seek skewness and word sum
could notice so here we have one point
one zero eight zero nine eight and one
point four nine five one nine seven
which are which this this will help us
to find out liars and outliers are those
who are far away let's say that you are
working on uh
age okay so uh age is 20 uh 20 years old
50 years old but let's say 150 years
this is the outliers okay these are the
outliers
okay those who are exceptional those
were exceptions of the data frame okay
so we have to take care of this but
before that let's see some relationship
with each and every column one you have
taken two columns you can try different
different columns
so
where there is
a little bit crime there is the sale
price is very high and there is a lot
more crime there is sale prices very
very low okay and what's the age you can
also see and you can see over your
100 years old has been sold uh in a
smaller rate and uh 20 years old has a
little little bit higher ray and you can
see see the data visualization over here
okay and you can see over here that i've
imported sci pi which is again that like
numpy i'm just taking out the norm and
the skewness so you just plot a
distribution plot for seeing this kind
of thing means uh for a normal
distribution if you know what normal
distribution you are just plotting the
normal distribution and we and this is
your actual this black line and you have
this blue line so you have to transform
it a little bit so your
new which is uh two trend
mean is 22.53 and sigma is 9.19 okay so
these are some if you know what python
you should know about these kind of for
formatting etc okay and this is the qq
plot which will help us to see the
coordinate quantiles which is uh order
values you can search more on the
internet or go on wikipedia to learn
more about this but to our main main
focus will be this uh sales price means
distribution plot okay so let's run this
let's try let's add let's add a
log let's let's uh transform our sale
price to a little bit more accurate so
now you can see over here that is his
skewness is over now we have just
applied a transformation over here log
one p and it's now good okay to avoid
outliers
okay
and this quadrant trial is also uh
removed okay so data correlation what a
correlation first of all correlation is
the is a relation between features okay
so if the if it is one then it is uh
positive correlated then it's minus one
very negatively correlated you can
search more internet about it because
it's not a statistics class so you see
if the diagonal is one all the features
are perfectly correlated okay so how do
we select the features which are highly
correlated okay the features how we
select if we have taken the absolute
value of the sale price and we are
taking the highly correlated feature
from this uh
statement and there is 12 feature that
we get that is highly highly correlated
you can choose this but i'm not going to
choose you can either
delete the rest of the columns except
these two all okay and let's just start
with model building so you just employ
important split and train test please
simply from divide your data into
training and testing means um
let's say you have 80 of the data so
sorry hundred percent it will take
eighty percent for training and twenty
percent for testing and use draw because
you don't want x to be sales price and
why to be the sales price okay and then
you test size then the band random state
will tell you
the
uh means every time you run the data
should not be changed
okay so if you run this now let's take a
look at the shape 404 and 13 columns for
training and furniture for testing and
for them for labels and one and two
labels okay so let's let's start with uh
let me make one more little little bit
more uh so that it should be clearly
visible okay so you just uh import uh
from scikit-learn which is a linear
regression and you just instantiate it
and then you fit the model x strain and
y train which we have used for training
and why training extreme are the these
are the input and this is that by a
target variable and then if you run this
now it's instantiated now we can now we
can make prediction okay so you can see
over the actual label because we know we
we know what y test is 0 because this
actual label and this is the prediction
which is 3.36 is a predicted value from
the model and three point two one
eight eight eight eight seven five eight
two nine is etcetera is the
is the actual value which is little bit
uh different from this but it's um good
for perform very very good in terms of
linear regression as we have seen so far
okay now if you want to check the
accuracy for checking the accuracy we
have seen a cost function you can run
this and msc mean square error and let's
say if you want to see msc there is
0.035 which is good and if you want to
take out the rmse the square root you
just npd or square root and you are
getting the rmse so you can just print
it out our msc
okay and you have seen that it's pretty
much good okay you will learn more about
how we can improve this by using xgboost
tagging boosting etc later on okay now
we have done our full prediction project
the code will be in uh
my github which is in the description
down box below there is a lot more
project which which is available in
computer vision natural language
processing which you can take a look if
you want to my projects okay so now i
think i have not quoted just now because
it will take a lot of time so i just
wait and have done just annotated each
and every line of statement
okay so if you have any kind of prop in
a search on internet because you have to
master google to if you if you have
encountered any kind of problem and in
the next tutorial we'll be talking about
regularized linear models which we'll
talk about lasso and which which we'll
also use in this uh
to check uh as a last one regression and
a ridge regression okay so let's let's
get into the
next uh
section okay so now we have talked to
talk talked about a linear regression
and we have made one project now it's
time for getting into the regularized
linear models linear models okay so uh
if you remember that we have a pointed
out or some problem which is uh
overfitting which is overfitting which
we have pointed out earlier
okay so how does overfitting happen
let's say if your model has learned too
much so let me draw one uh
x and y plane and let me draw some data
points okay so these these are the data
points and let's see or you have a
complex model which is a complex
function which maps your input variable
to output variable so you just uh make
the complex function like this which is
which is touching each and every line so
let's say a new uh example comes in and
it's making a bad prediction so you can
see over here it learned too much onto
the training data which are inner
trained and it's it is it is very going
bad it is it is uh not generalizing well
onto the new examples okay so that's
that's called overfitting if your model
working better best 100 accuracy under
training and working worse on the
validation accuracy then your model is
likely to fit overfitting
okay so how it is cost let's you have a
lot of features and you um let's say a
thousand features and so it will learn
obviously the complex functions and then
it will perform very very bad okay so uh
for that we have some solution and the
solution are uh
either uh you do reduce some features
reduce some features
uh reduce some features this is you can
do this another thing is what you can do
you can uh this is the same as like this
regularization
in simple terms regularization is just
uh eliminating the features that are not
useful okay so it is just equals to this
so we give another name which is called
the regularization so let's see some
other regularization techniques so the
first one is lasso regression so let's
see a lasso regression
so what is last regression last
regression is a regularized linear
models what we do we just add a simple
term with a simple a regularization term
at the
at the end of the cost function let's
say this this term lambda 1 over 2
i equals to 1 all the way down to the n
theta squared i
okay so you this is uh this is for a
ridge regression this is for a ridge
regression
okay so this is for raised regression i
will talk about lasso just just after
this okay so just you add this at the
end of the cost function so your now new
cost function will become like this 1
over m plus i equals to 1 all the way
down to the m
uh theta transpose x i and this this is
the model predicted minus y i
squared plus your regularization term
uh this one i equals to 1 all the way
down to the n theta squared i
okay so you can do like this now let's
let's understand what is doing it is
just let's say you have some features
which is the let's say the size of the
house let's say the price uh this is the
number of fans number of bedrooms and a
number of uh grass okay num number for
grass so you can see whether this this
this seems to be a less important
feature so it will it will simply make
the theta means the parameter feature
means the feature weight of this
column to be zero
okay so it simply penalizes or closer
and closer to zero in rich regression it
makes the feature weights closer and
closer to zero okay so
what is doing it is
whatever the less important features are
is just penalizing the theta of that and
the theta is the is used to make
prediction and let's say theta times the
number of graphs equals to prediction so
let's see it's a very very very very
small okay so it just penalizes your
theta okay so that's a ridge regression
is doing just penalizing or eliminating
the or
by how how it eliminating just making
theta to be equal to zero okay but if a
but in ridge regression it is it is
making closer and closer to zero but in
case of last regression it is simply it
is in case of last regression in case of
lasso
regression i'm talking about lasso
regression it's it's whatever the less
important feature are it simply makes it
simply eliminate it simply make the
theta zero so whatever let's say theta
times the number of a graph uh so theta
equals zero zero times the let's say
seven which is equal to zero so this
feature says eliminate net so that's a
lasso is very strict okay so these two
and just just to use l2 norm um in in
that case in range regression you are
using l1 norm but in lasso you're using
l two norm okay just adding the
regularization term which is like this
uh
at the end of the cost function i equals
to 1 all the way down to the n the
absolute value i and one yeah there's
this one okay okay so uh but one one
more thing that you can see over here
that we we do not penalize our theta
zero which is the biased term which is
only the bias term so we don't want to
penalize this so we start with i goes to
1 so we start with i equals to 1 rather
than starting with i 0 so we do
separately of all the things okay so
what
what what we do
we just uh take um we just start with
the
i equals to 1
all the way down to the j which is the
theta we do we separately do zero okay
uh and it's and i i think it's very
clear let me make you clear what i'm
saying i'm saying that you do
let's say for theta zero j of theta zero
you do separately this you do separately
this without the regular regularization
term without okay but uh for other other
thetas one all the way around to the j
you do you do at the regularization term
at the end of
the equation and then you separately
update this also uh this theta zero and
you separately update this theta 1 and
you just take this as a gradient of this
theta for theta 1 all the branches of j
and this gradient this the gradient of
this cos function theta 0 for updating
your theta 0 and getting the best theta
0 okay so you do not want to penalize
because only the bias term you don't
want to penalize this
okay so i think that is very clear to
you and again for recap regularization
is just penalizing or eliminating the
less important features by making the
parameter weights equals to zero
okay now i hope that's pretty much clear
now we hope that is very clear and in
the next tutorial we'll be working on
two uh uh
last regression sorry uh largest
regression which is the now we'll start
with the specification uh which is which
will cover logistic regression as a same
as a linear regression but it's a
classification not regression okay so
let's uh
i will be happy to see you in the next
section
okay so now we'll talk about a
regularization order one other favorite
topic that i like to talk on i will take
around 10 to 15 minutes to complete
something called as a regularization
topic and i think this is one of the
most important topic in machine learning
or when maybe you go to deep learning
okay so we learned about uh l1 arm l1
and l2 regularization which is often
called a rich and lasso regularization
and i hope that you will understand that
and why what is a regularization so
first of all this is the problem that
should come into mind and what is and
why regularization i think these two
questions must be your first question
over here so but before that i'm going
to highlight one uh something called as
overfitting and i think overfitting um
you all know but just as uh just to
those who are forgetting about it let's
uh revisit that
so uh let's assume that you have an x
and y plane x in x here
and y here okay and here is here you
have a data point okay so you have a
data point like this
okay and you fit it and your model
learns a lot your model learns a lot
means your model is performing very very
best on the training set let's take an
example that it performs it is it is the
the error the cost function over to here
means that the residual error or the
cost function over here will be
approximately or very very low to zero
and accuracy or on the training set will
very very high because this tries to
touch each and every point over here
okay and here your cost function means
the difference between your predicted
and actual value um summation of i
equals to 1 all around the m will be
approximately equals to zero and if it
is if it is if you if if it is touching
each and every point so it's obvious
that it is very very best onto the
training set on which it is trained so
it is it has learned a lot but let's for
the sake of example some example come
over here
and some example come over here so what
will happen
your model will fail to generalize well
under the testing set okay so that's why
i'm telling that your model will fail to
generalize well on testing set so you
can assume that that this this this you
can you can say that this this model is
one overfitting because you find out
that your model is performing a very
very best on a training set and then if
you evaluate it then you will see that
your model is performing very very bad
okay so that's the sign of overfitting
so we we always wanted to reduce the
overfitting so how we how can we reduce
our overfilling we have something called
as a regularization and how it happens
it can happen if you have a lot of
features a lot of features
a lot of features or your polynomial
degree is very high if you're using
polynomial regression okay so the the
measure for the problem is lots of
features okay
okay so
now let's see uh how we can remove this
uh how how we can prevent or how we can
make our our model less prone to
overfitting so some we have something
called as regularization
regularization will help you to
eliminate to eliminate the features to
eliminate the features which are less
important so again i'm saying it will
help you it will
help you
it will help you
to eliminate to eliminate
the features to eliminate the features
which are
which are
which are
less
which are less helpful or contains less
less information okay so it will
eliminate that so that's how we that's
how that's what the regularization is
doing it is saying that if the feature
is less important remove that okay or
make the make their respective and make
their respective hyper parameter to be
equals to zero okay make the respective
hyper parameter to be equal to zero
means i make make the respective not a
hyper primer make the respective theta
to be zero so we will see we will see
how what what it will do just just for
as an example let's assume that it will
help you to eliminate the features which
are less helpful now let's see how
how how it will do okay so let's assume
let's assume that you're working on uh
some problem which is house price
prediction okay so so you're working on
house price prediction and there you
have some features so here you have x1
so maybe
the size of the house my favorite size
of the house okay then x2 is maybe your
favorite the number of fans in a house
number of fans in a house okay number of
x3 maybe the number of bedrooms number
of bedrooms maybe another feature maybe
another feature number of
uh
maybe some fan no no fancies or well
maybe acs okay air conditioners so here
we have four features okay
and let's uh now what we'll do so we so
for each for each feature for each
feature for each feature x1 x2 x3 x4
we'll be having some parameter weights
we'll be having some parameter which
like theta theta one times x one plus
theta two times x two plus theta three
times x three plus theta four times x
four and you can see over here that we
have this this is this called the
hypothesis function so here these two
only the these are the weights these
these are the weights of these features
and we only have to learn these weights
by just tweaking it okay by just
tweaking it tweaking means let's take an
example i hope that you already seen a
linear regression just as an overview
that your theta was this equals to zero
to two point one theta zero equals to
two point one previously and you just
take out the partial derivative of your
cost function with respect to this theta
and then you update the theta okay why
and just see the linear regression part
you all all will be very clear okay
so here if you're if you're if you are
being confused please go to linear
regression part um you will be not able
to further continue so please please go
back and lay in your regression if
you're not able to understand why
what is theta and why it is okay so this
theta is a wait for the feature and we
can simply give let's take an example
that our theta 1 is equals to 2 theta 2
equals to 4 theta 3 equals to 2 okay and
theta 4 equals to 2 okay so we can
simply multiply so these f these thetas
to be learned okay so um our user will
give input
let's say the size of the house so two
times size of the house maybe 24 square
feet plus uh then num number of fans
though so four times number of fans
maybe four plus number of bedrooms two
times because here we have theta three
equals to two let's assume that the user
given two plus uh two times two times uh
maybe
number of ac is equals to one okay and
this the the this this is the y hat of
your model so here you learned some
weights you learned some weights and
usually you do the same you have some
parameter weights you have some
parameter weights which you learn by by
tweaking or by changing and taking a
look if it is if you if your model is
performing best and we just take out the
partial derivative of our cost function
with respect to this theta and then see
if our if our cost function decreasing
if it is then we update the new theta
and then we update our old theta with
the new theta okay so that's that's
that's what we are doing over here and i
hope that you are understanding what i'm
trying to say over here so
just for an um just for this intuitive
example i hope that you understood what
i'm trying to convey over here can i
convey you over here okay so let's
assume that you have this now
uh let's assume that this number of uh
like your model is overfilling okay so
what you do in regularization you apply
something called as uh rigid so let's
see the ridge regression what it does
rich regression rich regression okay so
the the equation for this regression is
just add is just add a regularization
term at the end of the cost function
okay at the end of the cost function so
again here we have theta 0 also here we
have oops what happens
here we have theta 0 also here we have
theta 0 times x 0 just a biased term
because then x 0 is always equals to 1
okay so in the range of regression in
ridge regression we add uh a
regularization term so here here's what
i'm here's what i mean so j of theta j
of theta equals to 1 over m 1 over m
plus 1 over m plus
i equals to 1 all the way down to the m
theta transpose theta transpose x i
theta transpose x i minus y i
squared plus i'm saying plus
and here we have something called as
learning rate
and this is just alpha okay so don't
assume that is the learning this is just
alpha
uh or you can say that someone can write
it as a lambda okay so it is just a
greek letter uh just within note okay so
don't don't compare with that uh
learning rate alpha do not compare here
i've i will tell you i will tell you
what is this what is what this alpha
does
1 over 1 over 2
i equals to 1 all the way down to the m
theta square i
okay so here we have added a new uh a
new regularization term a regularization
term over here a regularization term
over here so what is this so this is
simply what it does it's simply it
simply make it simply take the features
which are
which are less important and make that
parameter weights closer and closer to
zero okay so what do i mean with this so
for an example let's let's assume let's
assume that uh that you
that the number of
your model this you using the eq this
using this equation this is the l1 norm
the it is the l1 norm okay so let's
assume sorry l2 norm this is l2 norm
okay in ridge regression we have l2 norm
and here it's simply penalizing your
theta who is the very less important so
let's assume that the number of ac or
modern model find out that the number of
ac is less important so what it will do
so uh theta 4 our indicating the number
of ac though theta 4 is the weight of
our number of ac then it will make theta
4 to be to be closer and closer to 0
0.0001
okay so it penalizes your theta it
penalizes your theta as it found as you
as it found that your number of ac is
less important so it penalizes your
theta and whenever you are multiply with
penalize
penalize times the number of ac then it
will be also very uh means low okay so
that that just helps you to less prone
to overfitting okay so it is not doing
anything with your with your input value
it is doing because if you multiply
0.0001 with whatever the number number
feature it will be approximately zero
points there is a reservation okay so
like like that okay so what it does
simply it simply eliminates or penalizes
your theta value by just making closer
and closer to zero okay so this is the
l2 norm okay
and here we have something called as
alpha and alpha contains alpha contains
how harsh or how strict to be on to the
solent feature so let's assume that we
have set up some alpha obviously we
don't touch alpha inside learn but here
let's assume that your alpha controls
the strictness okay so if your alpha is
large i think so if your alpha is large
or lambda is large um
some people may write this as a lambda
also okay so don't uh don't be confused
so if you had a lambda is large then it
will make it it is making close and
closer to zero now it will make theta
four equals to
zero fully zero okay so it simply
eliminates it if you it's it is very
strict if you keep this if it is very
strict okay so it kit controls it
controls the strictness
but whatever i think okay but i think
what i like to remember is controls the
strictness okay so
and here you can see that you are taking
the l one norm and you are not taking
off theta zero you are explicitly doing
for theta zero because theta 0 is your
bias term and you do not want to
penalize your theta 0 theta 0 okay so we
are not penalizing we are going from
theta i equals to 1 all the way on to
the m we are not going to i equals to 0
we are going to each and every theta
okay so we are not so we are not uh
going to uh theta zero so we explicitly
do for theta zero and we it's explicitly
between two and tweak our theta or we
take out the derivative of our theta
explicitly okay because we don't want to
penalize our uh bias uh sorry
it's uh our biased term okay so this is
the rigid regression okay so we have
something called as a lasso regression
lasso regression lasso regression means
lasso regression is very very it's it's
it uses l1 norm instead of l2 norm it's
just the same it's just the same it's
also penalizes the theta value but what
it will do i will tell you okay so theta
0 theta 0 equals to whatever your cost
function will be i'm just putting 1 2 3
plus now i'm right regularized num
writing the regularization term i equals
to 1 all the way down to the m you're
not penalizing again theta zero the norm
of
the norm of
theta i
okay so this this is what you and here
you are taking the alpha norm okay so
taking the norm
you're taking the norm of your theta
okay so here what if here you are
applying the l1 norm so what it does if
he if if the last regression is very
strict just assume it's very strict
whatever feature he finds whatever i'm
saying i'm taking the gender as a he
okay or whatever this this last
regression finds whatever feature that
less important he finds he will directly
make that theta four to zero so here we
assume here we taken theta four equals
closer and closer to now then it lasso
it will take a directly to zero okay so
it is very harsh so the both have
specific use cases okay so these are the
this is called the l2 l1 norm and this
is called the alpha norm okay so here we
have started about a regularization in
detail and i hope that you understood
very very clearly and
uh we have talked a lot and there is one
more which is elastic net which you
don't need to worry about now it's very
kind of a
just combination of both of them but
it's not used in earth industry as we
use this l1 and l2 norm okay so thank
you for seeing this video about
regularization and and you can head over
to the next section to learn more about
more about machine learning and
completing this course okay so thank you
for seeing this video head over to the
next section
okay so now we will talk about support
vector machine in detail so that you
could be more powerful in machine
learning or you or you will be having a
powerful algorithm in your toolkit of
machine learning so support vector
machine is a supervised learning and
learning algorithm which is a both for
classification and regression we have
seen logistic regression and legislation
is for classification
and linear regression is for regression
so support vector machine is for both
which is classification which is
classification
and one more which is
a regression task okay so regression
task
so support vector machine can be used in
classification either your output and
degree value or it can be used in
continuous value
okay okay so uh let's i will take
diabetes support like the machine but
before that uh let's uh let me tell you
what we are going to study in this
section so we start with the
introduction of support vector machine
then we'll go further into what svm do
and then we'll talk about linear heart
margin then we will typically go further
into non-linear specification and then
we'll talk about empirical risk
minimization
and then a semi supervisor is
transductive um
svm and then we will talk about svr
which is
support vector regression okay and the
next section we will do one project
which is stock price prediction project
okay
okay so uh what is svm what actually svm
does it's it's it's it's simply just
what is like this so let me draw one x
and y plane so here is my x and y plane
i hope that's that's beautiful
so here is my x and y plane and let let
me make a linear data okay
so here we have the one day data point
and another data point is over here
okay so we have like this
and
then we have this data okay so let's
assume that that you're working on cat
and a non-cad uh brick off recognition
system okay so you are working on cat
and non-cat recognition system so what
actually svm does is
here you can see over let's assume that
white color
is for
cat images means the labels are cat and
blue color let's take as a non-cat okay
so these are data and what svm does it
makes its its constructor hyper hybrid
plane it's construct a hyperplane like
this
let's construct a hyperplane like this
okay and now whatever new point come on
or beyond any here then then this
example will be cat otherwise if
something
come here then it will be non-cad okay
so this is what svm does um but it's i
will this is not the full procedure
i will tell you but here what it does it
simply construct a hybrid plane and two
parallel hyperplane
and uh one
two parallel hyperplane
two parallel hyperplane
with this margin okay these are called
the margin so it always tries to
maximize that margin so it may sound a
little bit
kind of confusing so let's draw it again
to
let let let me show you once more time
what actually it does okay
so here is the white examples
and here is your blue examples
is it non-cat and not cat so what it
does is construct a hyper plane and a
two
two parallel hyper plane over here
two parallel hyperplane like this
okay so and this is called the margin
this is called the margin
and svm always tries to maximize this
margin keeping away the nearest data
point far away from the hypomaine what
i've said it's very uh crucial to listen
what i'm saying i'm saying that what svm
does it simply construct a hyperplane
and a two parallel hyperplane that
separates the data point and at a
maximum margin okay
so it always wants to as we always wants
to maximize that margin in such a way in
such a way in such
a way
so that the nearest data point so that
the nearest data point let's say x i is
far away from the hyperplane this
hyperplane okay
it's far away from the hyperplane so
that uh so that it would be easily so
that whatever comes here then it would
classify as an um as a knock as a non
cat whatever comes here or here it will
be classified as a cat okay and then and
and what i'm saying that the nearest
data point and the nearest data point is
far it should should be the far away
from the hyper plane
here okay so it would be here so these
are called the support vectors who are
the nearest data point
from the hyperplane okay and that is
supported by these are the
support vectors which supports this
parallel hyperplane to separate this
okay again this may sound a little bit
unconfusing so let's revisit this again
in a more detailed way so let's say uh
let let's take another another example
that we are building a person has a
cancer or a non-cancer i think malignant
uh let's say a non-cancer okay so you
build uh x y plane so let's build one x
and y plane and then you put uh this
blue examples which is which indicates
as a cancer and this white example which
indicates is a non-cancer okay so what
is um does simply construct a hyper
plane like this oops
it simply construct a hyperplane and a
two hybrid plane like this
and a two hybrid plane
and this is this is called the margin
and it always tries to maximize this
margin so that in such a way in such a
way that the nearest data point is far
away from the from the main hyperplane
okay so you can see over here that this
this is the nearest data point is far
away so these are called the support
vectors these are called the support
vectors okay pretty much easy now i
think that's is much clearer uh with
that we have taken three examples now i
think this is much clearer okay so it's
me it may sounds you like it's just like
a linear regression you have a linear
data and you're just spitting a straight
line with two hyperplanes what does this
mean it obviously means like linear
regression but if you come to the more
in detail the data are not
not linear okay the data never a linear
so uh
there are two kinds of svm there
the first kind of is hard margin
classification
and soft margin classification okay so
let's revis visit us a heart marching
first and then we'll revisit uh soft
margin okay okay so uh you here you can
see over here all that
uh this is just like a linear regression
but wait for a few seconds few minutes
then you will understand why it is not
like cleaning your depression although
it seems like that you could simply
construct a straight line but equation
and it's used for classification it's
quite quite different okay
okay so
in
it's called the linear svm the what we
have seen is called a linear svm where
we are constructing a simple hyperplane
and separating two
data points okay so what are hard
margins hard margin means that we are
not allowing any data point to come into
that margin okay that's what the
violating the hot margin so sorry
highlighting the margin so we are not
allowing any data point to violate that
margin so in that way we end up being an
overfilling or in that way we we very
much um
go we our our model is being started
overfitted so let's see one of what i'm
trying to say of here over over here
so let's construct a hyper let's let's
construct one x and y plane again so let
me construct one x and y plane oops
here is my x and y plane and let's uh
let's just draw two data point again let
me draw two data point like this
okay and let's draw a white data point
like this
okay
okay so and now what as we have got
simply construct a straight line with
two hyperplanes
okay
with this hyperplane
okay so in hard margin we are not
allowing any data point that generally
of the it comes under in so we simply
kind of do like this we simply kind of
do means we simply uh minimize this
margin like this
so we are doing like this all it it is
very strict hard margin is very strict
hard margin
is very
strict the reason i'm saying is very
strict because it does not allow
any data point to come into that margin
but in soft margin we allow some data
points to violate that margin to avoid
overfitting okay so that's what the soft
margin and hard margin means hot margin
which means we are not allowing any data
point to come into that margin and soft
production means we are allowing a
little bit of data point to come in
right between and the width is in the
width of the margin this is the width of
the margin is is is is uh is adjusted by
c okay so
if c is very very large then uh your
fifth will be very very small like this
okay it's let's say c equals to zero
this is the margin my margin so this is
my margin so let's say your c hundred c
equals to hundred so your uh margin will
be very very uh the width of the margin
is
is kind of a
low means it's very slow kind of it's
very small but if if if c equals to one
then your the width of the margin will
be very very large okay
like like this so it's just kind of any
it's kind of a very awkward thing that
you can see over here but that's what
the gun convention site okay so we have
seen um this this kind of thing and
maybe you will see
sometimes c to be named as a lambda okay
it's just it's just the same lambda and
c are the same just as convention we
give it a c as a name okay so let's just
get now is you now you've got the
overview of this hot margin and svm so
we have seen a lot more things now it's
time for getting into
the little little mathematics which is
how do we construct that
hyperplane in linear regression we are
just making the straight line and this
is theta transpose x but this was our
favorite equations like this theta zero
times x zero and in uh logistic relation
we are just doing the sigmoid of z so
these are our hypothesis so this from
this equation we are we were making our
um straight line or maybe the sigma so
uh what happens in case of a supported
machine we have our hyper plane is diff
our hyperplane
should be is defined by w transpose x
minus b equals to z this is the
condition that our hyperplane should
satisfy okay okay so what is this uh
this w is our parameter weight is our
parameter rate and this guy in linear
question we have seen is theta and b is
our
a biased term which is in case of linear
and logistic which is theta 0 okay so we
have just just given our new name which
is w and b okay and it's
okay so we have made a w transpose x
minus b
and this is our hyperplane that we have
made
as
w and b are the parameter weights
okay
so we have just just given a new name
and transpose you all know linear
algebra and this is w is a parameter
vector
okay so
let's define some constraints in for
heart margins so let's define some
constraints for heart margin how hard
margin make predictions
okay
so
whatever whatever the output of your
model minus w transpose x minus b is
greater than or equals to one then
anything on or above this margin will be
regarded as one in this case it will be
count okay why i'm seeing like this is
let's see you have this straight line
and you have this and you have the data
point and one uh these two
parallel lines and again here you have
so whatever on this margin or above this
margin is regarded as one means the
positive attention so it is regarded
it's a cap as you as you know okay and
whatever below this is regarded as a
zero okay as a non-cat
okay so let's let's let's write the
equation for that and it's quite easy
it's quite um
remember rememberable like double
transpose x minus v whatever on or
beyond this margin this margin will be
regarded as one whatever below this
margin will be regarded as a zero okay
as a negative attention
so that is the heart margin constraints
and that's that that's how we make
predictions onto uh support vector
machine
okay
pretty much clear what i'm trying to say
over here okay so now let's dig dive
into some a little bit more further into
math is
how it truly is it it is being
constructed like this so let's say you
had made a straight line
and this
um this margin you can see over here
this these margin
is is written by this hyperplane this
the main hyperplane is written by double
transpose x minus b and this margin is
equals this margin is equals to 2 over
the norm of w so to maximize this margin
we wanted to minimize this monitor the
minimizer w okay if we want to maximize
this margin because svm always has to
maximize this margin to maximize this
margin we have to minimize this norm of
w and this margin is written by
two over the norm of w okay and so so as
you have said that as we have always
tried to maximize so uh that is written
by the uh two over uh norm of w and to
maximize that you want to minimize some
hormone of w so we can write an
objective function we can write of
objective problem object like like like
this
the distance between two hyperplane the
distance
distance between
two hyperplane two hyperplane is written
by two over the norm of w so to maximize
its margin we want to minimize the norm
of w
with sub subject to
subject to
y i
double transpose x i minus b greater
than or equals to one so what i have
said so let's understand this equation a
little bit more further what i have
written over here
so you for maximum you this is the
minimizing means we want to minimize to
maximize that margin with respect to
y i which is your ground growth means
actual label and this is your moral
predicted value moral predicted value
and you can show your if it is on or
beyond this it will be one otherwise it
will be zero so if y i
is equals to your border predicted value
then your cost function will be zero
then your loss function will be zero
otherwise if it is not equals to y then
then your loss function will be very
very high so you want to minimize this
normal w to get the good predictions
okay
so we have started this and i really
hope that you had understood the concept
that i explained to you and we can write
our false function in a hinge loss or
i'm talking about some soft margin so we
can write our
soft margin like this so we can write
uh the the
loss function the cost function the loss
function
you can write our loss function
like this uh 1 over n plus
i'm going to each and every training
examples
max
of max of 0 comma 1 minus y
double transpose x i minus b
plus the regularized section plus
lambda over was times the norm of w
straight okay so this is quite confusing
a little bit but let me try to explain
you in more detail way
so you already can see we are we are
going to each a restraining example but
taking on the max and this is the hinge
loss if you can see this is this is
called the hinge loss if i will get into
more detail about a hinge loss you can
have some wikipedia pages for knowing
about hinge loss okay and this is your
model model predicted value y a y i and
the ground this is your ground truth y i
and this is your predicted value and
this is the lambda times you can write
it c also you can write c also because
it it it help you to adjust the width of
that margin so that's why it is a very
very important hyper parameter okay
and times the non of w squared okay
okay so we are done with a kind of a
more
linear uh classifier we are lame your
svm is linear classification so we have
made our good loss function so we have
made a prediction function and now it's
okay we want to minimize the this norm
of w to get the good predictions okay
okay so yes yes we have seen only the
linears svm so let's let me form firm
formulate one example which is like this
let me make one
again x and y plane number and making
too much x and y plane it's best to have
a
this kind of things okay so let me make
one non-linear classification like this
okay so you have this kind of data
and this kind of data and let me make
the these white examples are the cat
images and these white examples are
non cat images so now if you can if you
want to make the straight line you will
be notable to do that means you're not
able to um kind of classify it so it's
very bad so what you have to do you have
to make a non-linear you have to do the
non-linear classification like this
now it will be okay now it will be okay
so svm also is also is very kind of
powerful in nonlinear specification with
something called as kernel trick it's
something called as kernel trick so we
will elaborate kernel trick in detail so
let's start with kernel trick so what
what we do in kernel tricks so let me
write an algorithm so what you do you
write an algorithm in terms of x you
write the inner product
let's say let me write you write
an algorithm you write an algorithm
in terms of
the inner product of x and z and the
these x and z are two data points are
two data points so what you do
let me tell you what what what we do in
normal in a classification we take our
data we take our data x and we transform
our data to a some more let's say we
have um one dimension data to a two
dimensional data and non-linear
specification okay so we transform our
data to be from one-dimensional to
two-dimensional like like this which
okay so we write an algorithm in the
form of x and z and x and z are the data
points so in simply in kernel trick we
transform our data to from one
dimensional to
higher dimensional space so you will get
to know what what we are doing so let's
uh let me write the steps
so after uh we have written our
algorithm in terms of the inner product
of x and z now what's what we do we map
our input input and this x without i
write we map our input x to the phi of x
okay to the phi of
x so we are just i will tell you what
this function is because
okay so we write our function we map out
x to the phi of x i will tell you what
what we do in this case so we we find a
way to map our this we find if we find a
function
[Music]
so we map our x to the phi of x so we
write a function or a final way
we find our way
so we find the x to be some
uh phi of x and it will transform your
one-dimensional data
to the uh maybe and then any kind of
your data to be the high dimensional one
okay
so you write up her you write the
function at k we transform a data the
phi of x transpose that times the
uh phi of z okay so let's see what it
does with that help an example and then
what we do we replace our x
and z with our transformed theta which
is
phi of x and z to be the beta phi of z
okay so this is what we do
so
let's see um some how what is just and
and what faced us so we write uh the
kernel functions are one of the famous
kernel is rbf kernel that will transform
your data excels into the high
dimensional space
so
the kernel function is written by the rv
of kernel function written by k of x
comma z exponent of
minus
norm of x minus z
squared over 2 over the sigma squared
okay and the x and z are the data points
okay great and some more kernels are
which is polynomial homogeneous
polynomial inhomogeneous which you can
search on internet but the most famous
one is rbf kernel which is widely used
in the end of stream okay
okay so we have seen various kind of
things and about kernel trick how we do
the non-linear the transforming data
you're able to do the non-linear
classification so here are some we will
discuss one two kind of one primal
problem which will help us to state our
optimization objective and then we will
see the sub gradient okay
so uh why why i'm talking about primal
problem it will help you to form
formalize your objective function so it
will help you to formalize
your objective function
so it's just the same just as written we
write that
so for each i
for each i
be the member
of one
two all the round to the n we introduce
a new variable
zeta we introduce a new variable zeta
where zeta i where is equal to the max
of zero comma one minus yi
so we introduce a new variable zeta i
zero comma one minus y i okay and then
in that we write w transpose x minus b
okay so this is just a hinge loss where
we introduce a new variable that hence
ross is a story okay right image you see
what i'm trying to say here okay so then
we write our function like this you want
to minimize
you want to minimize
1 over n
i equals to 1 all the way down to the
end zeta i plus
the
the regular regularization term c the
norm of w is great okay with respect to
r is subject to
subject to
y i double transpose x minus b greater
than or equal to 1 minus the
zeta i
time um
is just a where zeta i is greater than
or equal to b
for all i
okay so we have just formulated one
problem it is just equal to the hinge
loss that we have seen we want to
minimize the objective function that we
have seen so far is just equal to that
so we have formulated in such a way that
you can use this okay so we have a
object objective function which is our
cost function now we can now sum
something called a sub gradient
something called as sub gradient descent
and which what we do we we make a convex
function f of w and b we take out the
sub gradient of our of of our function
we sub take out the sub gradient of our
cos function and then we update our
parameter w and b okay and that's the
sub as the gradient descent what what we
are doing okay so it's little bit
different than gradient descent here we
are taking the sub gradient of our cos
function okay so this is what we are
doing this is called the primal problem
and then we uh with this we we take out
the sub gradient of that primal problem
okay pretty much easy what i'm trying to
say over here
okay so one more thing that the that is
very popular among beginners are
learning theory something known as
empirical risk minimization what do you
mean by empirical risk minimization
given you're given the input x1 x2 all
the way down to the xn
you want to and you and given y1 all the
way down to the yn
you want your output you want your
output you want your output yn plus 1
given
xm plus 1. so it's just the same you
give a function x and you want your
output y okay and your and the loss and
the getting the getting the error should
be minimized means the risk should be
minimized so that's the empirical risk
minimization which we have already seen
so we just have to know the definition
for itself what is this okay okay so um
ss we have talked about nonlinear and
linear now it's time for getting into
this
uh support vector regression uh i'm just
going to give you the equations okay it
will it will all it will it is kind of a
quite easy
you want to minimize your one over two
the norm of w is great you want to
minimize this to get your output with
respect to or subject to
the y i the absolute value of y i minus
the inner product of w and x i
hence p
times b and it should be greater than or
equal to the sum epsilon and epsilon be
the smallest positive in teaser okay so
just to uh be comfortable into that so i
hope that is quite clear and this this
is for regression task okay and we will
see the implementation in our next
section so i hope that you really
enjoyed this tutorial this section and
we will be carrying out this more more
into detail now we have gone too much
into math but if you haven't understood
any anyone please feel free to put a
comment uh put your comment in the
comment box i'll be very very happy to
take your comment and
and
provide your answers over there i'll i
will be uh taking taking a look at the
questions and we will be answering soon
at that point just put the timestamp
where you're commenting okay so that i
could know where you have a problem
okay so i think that's how we have gone
in too much detail if you haven't
understood grammar problems or gradient
don't worry it is not required for a
beginner machine learning so if you have
if you if you learn too much in machine
learning and bonus deploying now you can
come back to this primal problem to
understand what i'm saying but it's
quite easy to understand that the kernel
trick what i said etc okay so thank you
for seeing this video sorry thank you
for seeing this section i'll be catching
up here in the next section uh till then
you can do the programming assignment
okay i'll be catching up your next
section will be making one project which
is stock price predictor okay thank you
so now we will make a stock price
predictor which is our end-to-end
machine learning project and here's a
demo and you can see over here that i
have to use you can just remove the i
will show you where i have taken all
those things just so i do i'm not a web
developer but i had made a good front
end of this and also i made a back end
using flask okay so we will code
as i made a stock price predictor and i
will show you how you can uh build the
same website like me and you can also uh
make a beautify if you're a web
developer okay so here is my um here's
my jupiter notebook and here first of
all i'm going to download the data from
yahoo finance and you can simply pip
install live finance i've already
installed that you can install that so
you just want to import first of all the
basic libraries let me do that so first
of all you want to import the basic
libraries like this
uh
first of all i will import numpy as np
then i will import pandas as tv and then
i will import matplotlib and i'll
implode import matplot left dot
pi plot as plt
then uh with that i'm going to import
the c bar because i'm going to use
seaborn now in this case as a
visualization library so numpy is a
scientific library pandas is they're
working with the data the seaborn is an
uh visualization library and matplotlib
is also a visualization library okay oh
and one more thing that i want to import
is uh for my data for my data which is
import y finance as y f okay
as y f and y f is just allies given to
that okay let me run this out
and yeah i can to add this is optional
but i can to add over here like this mat
block level line
matplotlib inline
okay now it should work fine okay so we
had done with importation of our uh all
the libraries and now it's time for
getting in a little bit more uh detail
about the data how we can load our data
so first of all i'm i'm just going to
use um
i just want to i'm in this project i
will make a stock price predictor of
natural gas okay and you can do any of
like gold silver just go head over to
the yahoo finance just head over to the
ua yahoo finance
and
just head over to that and just to
search whatever let's say i want to go
for gold so if you go over gold then you
will see over here that you have a gc
equals to f which is the code of that
okay so you just take take copy the code
and here's just uh i will just show you
how what you can do first of all i will
take input i will take input which is
enter the code of this talk enter the
code of this talk to download
enter the code of the stock to download
okay now it will take an input now i
will just uh make a variable
now i'll just make a variable yf dot
download
and it will take off the code from the
stocks okay and it will download from uh
it will download from let's say 2008 it
will download from 2008
in january to one till
uh it will down it
download till two two two zero two one
till uh zero let's say
let's a two let's say one and tell 18.
okay so this is the favorite thing and
now what you can do we can simply do
this kind of thing and let me run this
and let's ask the code of this talk
okay so you just give the code of the
stock so let me give the natural gas
equals to f this is the code so it will
download a stock like this and then it
will simply tell you the data how this
looks okay now if you can see see over
here that you have open
high low close adjust and close and
volume okay so one more and one more
thing that studies that you can do you
can write auto adjust or to adjust
equals to true what it does is adjust
your uh
all of the
kind of data frame and then you can see
over here like this okay so that's what
it's doing till now
okay so we are done with this now it's
time for getting into a little bit more
detail about uh now we have loaded the
data now let's take a look at the shape
of the data like that
so data dot shape
and would tell us that we have a total
of thousand two hundred fifty six uh
training examples and five columns
including date one two three four uh
three two four five we have five columns
and uh
information about the data you can take
a look we have a non-null values we have
this we have that was the data type you
can also take a look at the
mean standard deviation maximum minimum
of all the stuff so let me do that
okay so you just uh see this and now you
can see that you have a all of the count
the minimum mean standard deviation
minimum 25 and etc
okay now if you wanted to take a look at
the now we are done with data
exploration now let's literally go
further into how it uh because stock
price prediction is very very non-linear
okay but uh one thing that i want to
mention over here they do not use it for
personal purposes it's only for
educational purposes okay only for uh
educational purposes the reason why it's
very non-linear and you can't uh and
then you and you can't depend on your
algorithm to to simply predict the
output okay our other good it's it it
may give you uh the wrong output i don't
know about this very very non-linear so
be sure to do not use it just for
educational purposes not working company
you're just making a simple project so
that you could get a concept of how you
implement how the process hold looks
like okay so don't immediate by yourself
um kind of a use in yourself and do not
kind of
make a website like that do not it is
only for educational purposes okay now
if you are done with this now we can
analyze our data now if you followed an
an analyzer with data you can write this
close dot plot you can just plot it out
and now it will look like this oops
you can fix size
let's say i'm just want to make it
10 7
and
we have this and here our target
variable is close
okay our target variable is closed
and
uh means we it will just tell you the
direction of the stock let's say
if the close is very high then your
direction of a stock is very high means
it will close will very high so here's
very nonlinear so it just starts with
2008 in very low way and gets up up in
2009 then gone drastically down in 2010
and then um kind of that so you can see
the non-linearity like this so it's very
very non-linear it's not uh you can you
can depend on this algorithm or this
predictor to predict your output in a
good way okay so now now i think that we
are done with everything now let me see
what i have to do
okay now let's take a look at that this
how we can plot the distribution plot
what's the distribution plot of our open
then what's the distribution plot our
close
okay so it will give us a more feel how
we are proceeding with our data or it
will help us to choose the algorithm
okay so
here's the thing that i wanted to
mention so first of all um just i'm
going to use as
c bar and
just i'm going to use seaborn and then
here i'm going to name as uh data i just
want to name it as data and i'm going to
put over here
uh this open let's say close okay so we
will see if this is normally if this is
non-linear etc to take a little bit more
field okay so you can see it's a little
bit
non uh
it's just it's a non-normally
distributed okay so you can apply and
lock transformation that's called
feature engineering but that does not
work well in this case so we should
leave like this and then we will take a
look at this plot and then if you wanted
to take a look at the open
then you will again see it's again
normally disputed now you can do the
same for other other things to get the
feel of what we are doing let's say we
are we have done for high
so we are done for high
and if you take a look at the highs also
like there's a sweet okay so we are done
uh we are done with you can you can play
with the data visualization and it say
take out the inferences about the data
and about the data inferences okay now
we have understood the data what we have
understood okay let's write the
conclusion what we have understood till
now so we have understood the first and
first foremost
is the shape of the data shape of the
data
and then we have understood the
uh how a data is distributed how our
data is distributed our data is
distributed then we have understood
that then we have understood
how our
uh it's it's very very non-linear it's
very very non-linear okay so you can't
cannot use for own purpose
maybe you can use deep learning
architectures like lstm to get the
direction of your stocks and let's say
if you uh maybe the 99 95 percent that
works correct or remember 80 works
correct maybe 725 works correct uh so
you can
just turn down do not use linear
regression or any kind of things to make
your own use but definitely in future
let's see what the research
comes with uh for stock price predictor
because stock price prediction is also
competitive uh project to work on
because it's very very non-linear
okay so we are done with this and now
it's time for we have started how much
algorithm you have started linear we
have started linear then we have studied
logistic
then we have studied some regularized
linear models regularized linear models
then we have a started support vector
machine then we have studied principle
combat analysis which will study uh
which we have not studied so we will
study principle common analysis and then
furthermore okay so we will use support
vector machine we will use support
vector machine uh but we will see that
linear regression and regularized linear
models works best in this case and we
will go with our saving the model of
regularized linear model okay so let's
start with linear regression before that
let's split our data into x and y and
then the training and testing set so
here i am um just i'm going to x so i
like my convention so i'm just going to
make it like this
and
our x variable will be all the except
close so i'm just going to remove this
and then an axis number one
and then y equals to data and then y
equals data dot drop
i'm not saying we will not drop it we
will just simply keep the close okay now
if yeah we
we are done with this now x and y data
to drop close x now we are done now what
what we can do we can simply uh
import more uh kind of a moral selection
uh which is trained to split we'll
import one thing which is train to split
which let's say you want to split your
data let's you have 100 of data so you
will uh split your data 80 for training
and 20 for testing to validate your
model okay so here i'm doing what i'm
see you can see over here we have a x
train x test and y train y test okay so
this is the you can make the variable
and all the training elements the labels
of x train will be in y train and label
of x test will be in y test like this
okay now if you now you have just give x
and y and just give the size of that uh
test set which is let's say give the 20
percent means you just want to use 20 20
percent of your whole data for testing
then you want to do this random
state and you may think hey you schwarz
run random stage does it simply uh let's
say if you if you run it one more time
then your data will not be changed to
your shuffle because shuffles also so
your data will be not changed
okay so we will take a look at the
shapes of that so that we can get a more
feel what we are doing so you could
understand what to whom we are working
with
uh let me just copy and paste one over
here and just gonna to make it like this
and
then i'm just going to
make it wide swing
and this one by test okay and just meant
to make it a little bit more detail okay
when you run this you can you can see
over here that you have a two thousand
six hundred four and four columns and
the fifth column is two two thousand uh
this the labels of y okay so that's the
thing and now what we can do we can go
further and we have taken the close as
our target variable which will tell us
the direction of our stock stocks
okay
okay so now we are done with splitting
now it's time for getting into a little
bit more depth is uh modeling part means
we are going to first of all i'm going
to import the linear regression because
everyone thinks linear regression is
very bad but let me tell you it's very
powerful algorithm when it comes to
linearity but here we don't have a
linearity but still it works best when
you apply your polynomial saturated
question okay
but let's uh keep let's use the
logistics or linear regression and you
can see over here that this is a
regression problem and so supervised
learning problem so we cannot use
logistic it will be very very bad for us
okay so just i'm going to instantiate
just i'm going to instantiate
instantiate and i'm just going to call
lr.fit and i'm just going to give xtrain
and the labels y train which is the
labels of x-ray
okay the predict one means i'm going to
use that
lr which is train model to predict my x
test okay
now if i run this now if you see the
predicted output you can see over here
that the uh let's
see the first training example
so you can see over here oops this y
test now
so you can see over 2.918 and the
predicted is 2.90 and the
actual value is 2.918
okay see that things that that is over
here this
quite uh it's quite very very good
because you can see away that's quite
working very very good and yeah linear
regression works out best but it may
happen that may overfit your data
but let's see let's calculate a matrix
so we are going to use some matrix which
is m a we are going to use m a which is
uh
sorry mse which is a mean square adder
which is a mean squared error which we
have talked about the cost function for
linear regression
then we are going to use
uh then we are going to use uh
rmse and simply is it does simply the
square root of a square root of
mean square error
and then what you do here and then we
will calculate the r2 square okay and
you can see if you want to get into
mathematically we'll we'll talk about
some matrices matrix later on but you
know the best output of r2 if your model
giving output
r2 equals to 1.0 then you have a very
bad sorry good model and it's a good
model if if it's giving good okay so
we'll see how much hour r2 etc so i will
write one helper function like this
we'll write one helper function
calculate matrices
i'll just write a matrix and then it
simply takes the actual value which is a
grand truth and it simply strikes the
predicted value of your model to
calculate and then first of all i'm
going to calculate the mse and it's just
uh first of all i have to import because
you can also make your own function but
it's better to use vectorized or cyclone
because it's already provided to you but
you know it's very kind of easy if you
wanted to define msc so you just write
and define msc and just
take the sum of everyday data point and
the residuals and then just
square them up and then like that you
can do that we have already i think your
area have implemented programming
assignments
okay so you can just to make it import
uh let's say oops i don't want to i just
want to import the matrix and i'm going
to import uh mse and mean square error
obviously we do have mean absolute error
which you can also use but for now i'm
going to use this
but by the way we don't have rmse we
have to code rmse buyers by ourselves
okay we only have r2 squared so first of
all let's uh do this kind of thing means
being a square giving the for our
parameters y test and y and wipe fret
and then
rmstn you may think here use how how you
can calculate the
root mean square error just write np dot
square root is just taking the square
root of mse okay that's easy so r2 score
which is r2 scores i'm just now on the
right is doing a spelling wrong because
maybe it will cause some error if you
have a reserved keyword or like that's
function okay so you have r2 squared and
then uh score and now you just give y
test
and now you just give y test sorry yeah
y test and wipe red
okay and these are white as in white red
are just so let me write that what is
this
so why test is your
ground truth is your ground truth is
your ground truth
and why fret why pred is your moral
predicted value okay moral predicted
predicted value
oops i'm i think that i'm doing it wrong
uh you can see the spelling
okay okay so we are now whatever what i
will do i'll just print it out msc then
i will print rmse
then i will print rmsc then i will print
r2 okay
r2 is coarse
okay and this i'm just gonna to
msc
uh just going to make it mse like this
[Applause]
and here also i'm going to make it rmsc
okay and here also i'm going to make r2
square
r2
score sorry score it's score okay now i
think that it should work now we are
done now if you wanted to now we are
done with helper function now if you
want to calculate the matrix so you
where we will just calculate the for a
linear regression so we would just give
a y test which is our ground truth which
i have made while splitting out data now
we will make a y prediction y prediction
and sorry it's a prediction one
uh that that we have made in linear
regression predicted okay so you can see
the msc is equal equals to zero means
approximately equal to zero is quite
good because in cost function your cost
function should be very very
approximately equal to zero your root
mean square is also and your r two is
zero point nine nine nine this
is approximately equals to 1.0
okay so it's quite good linear
regression performs quite good okay now
let's a little bit let me go go further
into uh some regularized linear models
like rich and lasso so
let's use that from sklearn
sklearn dot model sorry linear models
linear model i'm just going to import
lasso
and you if you know if your name may
know about this lasso and rich lasso
what it's doing simply eliminates the
less important features simply
eliminates the less important features
and rich is just
penalizes your less important features
okay
so now let's uh make the two of them so
let's say la as a lasso
so i'm just going to fit it over like
this is a short form giving the
x train and y train
is a short form for doing that and then
i will do for the same for a rich
i'm just going to go for the ridge
and it just fits the same thing and oops
i should give it r a i think r i
l a p i'll just go l a p is the lasso
predicted value and then i'm l a
x test okay
and here also i'm just going to make r r
i p
equals to r i dot predict
and i'm just going to give x test
let's run this now we are done now if
you want to take a look let's first take
a look at the lasso what lasso performs
l a
first of all we are going to give the
ground truth which is y test and then we
will gonna give the lap now it's quite
uh not good it's zero point it's quite
not good because simply it's very strict
it simply eliminates so but it's you're
you're with lasso your modal in your
model is less prone to overfitting but
here you can see if i take a look at the
rich it's quite uh for now it's quite
good because uh it is also a
regularization now it's quite a similar
to linear regression but this is less
prone to overfitting okay it's less
prone to overfitting so we are going to
use uh rich regression to save our model
and build a website under this
okay so one one more thing that i want
to mention over here that we can use
support vector machine i mean support
vector regression uh for this task so
let's see how we can make this kind of
thing so let's let me uh
svm so you can just and i think that the
portable machine will not work well
but it should work well if you have a
lot of features like index voltage and
then we have a different different
features which contain different
different uh importance okay so i'm just
going to import and here you can
obviously will not use it but here you
will learn how to so how to do the fine
tuning of any other model using grid
source cv okay so dot model selection
and just going to import the grid source
cv okay first of all i'm going to
instantiate svr and that is just going
to um
i'm just going to make it params and
then and then i'm going to make it
params and then here i'm going to make
it c to be uh maybe and c is just a
lambda which will tell us the width of
your margin so i'm just going to copy it
out this i'm just going to write it from
my there i've already written over there
it's just i'm going to write it to
minimize the length of the video
okay so it's just like this and i'm
taking c as uh to use these values and
check how is model performing with
different different values and kernel
will be obviously the rvf kernel because
it's very kind of non-linear okay now if
you now what we'll do we will just uh we
will just make this and then i will call
my greatsword cv and i'll give my params
i just gonna to give my params and svr
first of all svr obviously
svr and then i'm going to give it the
rams red
ram grid and then
i just want to rough it equal to true
and just wrap it will tell you means the
warnings you can see the documentation
verbose equals to three
okay messages
done now if you wanted to run it let's
fit now now we'll fit grid
onto our training to check different
different values
y twain
okay now let's run this it will take a
little bit of our own time but yeah i'm
just gonna to
uh code it further
it will take a little bit amount of time
it is checking for each and every uh
this zero point one zero point twos
etcetera and checking the score and
whatever works best it just will give
out
okay just want to make it small
okay now let's wait for a few seconds
and i think this will uh end up being in
a few seconds
uh in the meanwhile i'm just going to
just copy it out these things because
the parameter which we are going to get
is like this the c equals to 10 and
gamma equals to 0.1 and kernel equals to
rbf and if you run this if here you will
be left with a very good matrices but it
means it is very bad i think so this is
we are performing is very very bad
because of that we have a don't have a
lot of features over here
and spr is not able to
find learn in the model actually but
regular regularized linear models are
more powerful in here okay
that image is what i'm trying to say you
here okay now i'm gonna do is to see
this how much it was still running it's
just checking for each and every uh this
will take 1.8 seconds more to i think
it's 1.9 seconds it's just taking a
little bit of one time but i'm just
going to wait for a few seconds and you
can see over here that is trying for
each and every value gamma then c then
this then that
okay so we will just wait and then i
will uh let's come back
i think we are we will just code it
further because um we will just code it
for the import job lib
and here we will import job left to save
our model to save our model because we
are going to use a regularized linear
models okay so model job lib dot dump
job lib dot dum
i'll just dumps and just going to save
this model dot pkl
okay and then i will simply uh if i want
to load my model equals to joblib.load
i'm just going to if you want to load
your model you can just write it down
and you can just make it model.pkl
okay
that's what we are going to do over here
and now i think that's done now if you
want to like this and now if you want to
make it like this now you're done with
this kind of thing now if you run this
this support victim uh regression and
now if you run this now the dumps is not
there particularly very good okay so we
are done with this now let's see the in
folder where we have the pkl file and we
can use this model to make predictions
okay so we can use this model to make
predictions so let's keep making
predictions with this so let's me let me
go to my
let let me go to my uh one of the mlo
one and then stock price predictor and
here i'm going to open with code okay i
do have made which i will just copy if i
want to save my time i'll just copy and
paste over there to save my time so that
it would be more perfect if i just copy
the prediction.html because it's just uh
simple html blocks
you're just going to
cut it down because i don't think that
this should require further
it's just active
let me cut it down
okay so now i think that we are on to
this now what what i can do i can just
make a app.pi
app.pi and here first of all i'm going
to i think that all are able to see ya
so from flask
i'm just going to import
import flask
and then i'm going to import the vendor
template
render template
and if you don't know what plan don't
worry it's quite uh easy to understand i
will walk through each and every process
but i don't know why it's not working
but it's okay if it's not working it's
uh it's my vs code box a lot
i don't know why but yeah i will just
keep trying it out let me again open
with code
it's again open with code
and then let's see what i can do over
here that we have just imported the
flash till now and
render template now we'll just
instantiate my model like this flask
uh name oops it's just i think name
it's correct yeah so now i'm just to
make a route app.route
and it's just uh this
simple homepage to validate our server
is working return render template
i just want to take a render template
from the index.html
index.html
and you may think hey you should haven't
made index.html so let's make that uh
this i'm not made just i'm going to make
it over here so flask looks for html
files into the templates folder to just
make one templates older over here
okay just make it and then one more
folder you have to make for your images
which is static folder okay static and
all your images will be here
now you can also make from here just to
templates like this now just make a new
file which is index.html
okay now after making index.html you can
just type this down like this
and now if you go away stock price
predictor i just i will just copy it
down i will tell you where i have taken
all those stops so let me show you where
i've taken from these all so but let's
see before that
how is it working or not
like writing a hello world
okay just save this down and now if now
it's time for uh like this
instantiating for setting up your server
name
equal equals to
main
and then i will just uh
app
dot run
debug equals to true
anything going wrong
i think yeah uh no
it's true
okay now if i save this if i run this
down it will take a little bit of time
and it will run and so it's starting
over here and this is my url address
if i see over here now you can see over
here that we have a
a beautiful
website but now you can see why it is
running the reason why it's i have to
stop that server to get running so let
me stop that server because another
server is running
um into the ml01 projects folder over
here which i have to stop it
i will debug it i have to reinstall my
visual studio code but i will show you
where i have taken this all so the first
thing first you have to keep in mind
from where you have to take this it's
from uh see a tail block so i will just
annotate the code in my
mlo1 projects folder this i will
annotate from where i have taken
it says from first of all i have
imported the cdn first of all i've
imported the cdn
of bootstrap and talvin css and then
i've gone to tailblocks.cc i will gone
to tailblocks.cc
and grabbed my header grabbed my header
then this nav navigation menu then i
have to grab my header and then i have
this predictor and you can see
all the code is in my github okay
now if i show you what the
prediction.html does it's simply uh
first of all what i've done i i have
written a form into that you can uh the
code will be in the description
description elements that get up you can
head over to that okay so i'm just using
the request to get the form the open the
high which is the input variables and
then i'm pretty preprocessing it so how
it's how i'm preprocessing it and
putting into the 2d array to make
prediction then i'm loading the model
then i'm predicting on the test data and
then returning the prediction and then
i'm just running the template from
prediction.html
and prediction equals to prediction
which has gone through here so if i go
to the prediction.html you can see that
i have just extra i have made one layout
i use flask
flask inheritance to inherit the
template from
layout or html and you can see the
layout of this similar just a chunk of
code so prediction is just a prediction
and the prediction is derived from here
okay and it's just prediction is there's
prediction status just given okay
pretty much easy let's see if it's
working still now or not it's still
working so let me put some value
so it's just and it will tell the
closing price
and it will tell when it sells at
closing prices tells the direction of
the stocks okay so the closing price is
four point eight six five eight eight
zero five four okay so that's the pretty
much easy that we need uh to understand
about uh uh making a flask of flask
website and end-to-end machine learning
project i really really hope that you
enjoyed this tutorial a section in this
project in the next section we will be
talking about principal combat analysis
then we'll do one of our project and
then we have done step 10 now two
projects which is an end-to-end machine
learning project to get on the resume
and you can also modify it let me tell
you how you can modify it you can see
over that that we have an open high low
close volume then a research paper or
something called the stock price
prediction using machine learning they
have given what the features they have
used like index volatility like uh mean
etc selling price of the sorry
three three days price three days
previous price and nine days pre selling
previous price so you can do that kind
of features and integrate over there to
make it the more powerful model with the
complex model okay but do not make it
too complex we can see we had we had
worked on lots of data to understand and
how we understood that this is good for
linear regression the reason why we have
understood because our data is not
multiple linear what do i mean by
multiple linear because many of the
interviewer asks that how you will
perform when your data is
multi-co-linear with linear regression
algorithm your answer will be no we
cannot perform when a linear regression
when your data is multi-core linear it's
only because
it's only because your because the
variables linear regression does not
work well when your variables are highly
intercourse correlated okay when you're
let's say on it will be all same means
correlated very highly into intercollect
correlated so if they ask you what's the
way to remove this so you can say okay
we can use principal component analysis
which will study in the next section so
you can say hey we can use principal
component analysis to remove the
uh multi-collinearity from our data and
then it's boom you are done with your
interview it means kind of just one
question as an astronaut interview as i
was in one of my interview okay so
that's the basic thing that we need to
understand and i really hope that you
enjoy this section the next section will
head over to the pca and we've had done
the two projects now it's good to see
that all of you are doing projects and
it's i hope that you're very enjoying
okay you can leave your questions in the
comment box i will definitely pick up
that question
okay thank you for seeing this section
i'll be catching up in the next section
okay so now we will talk about principle
component analysis which is a
dimensionality reduction algorithm okay
so uh you will get to know what is
dimensionality reduction etc but before
that we we should have a toolkit of some
some other concept of linear algebra
like linear combinations or linear
transformations and eigenvectors and
eigenvalues okay so we will review the
linear transformation and eigenvectors
and eigenvalues so that we can be on the
same page
okay so
if you want to get in more detail there
is a youtube channel named three blue
one brown like this you can head over to
that they have it he has a very good
playlist on linear algebra they have a
series of section videos you can watch
that if you want to get dick dive into
that but for this you don't need that
okay but
uh what is linear transformation
if you have linear transformation just
like a is a function as we have seen f
of x which is a function so it just
transforms your function transform this
x to maybe the squared of x so this is
just is a function
the transform or the transform from one
vector space
to another is that respects to
underlying linear structure of each
vector space okay
so if you if you have seen the three
blue one brown videos he has clearly
mentioned that
is a function lean linear transformation
is a function that transforms your one
vector space to another with linear
structure okay are we parallel to each
other it's a linear structure of each
vector space if a little bit of
nonlinear gains you will be not able to
do the transformation of your vector
okay so that's called the linear
transformation so linear transformation
can be written as t
column we are transforming our vector r
to that okay okay so here is here's an
example of 1d linear uh
transformation so here's the function t
of x and a be the sum is scalar and
their one dimensional linear
transformation t of x which is our
function that maps your
that that maps your from from interval
of zero to one to the interval of three
to zero so we have a vector the zero to
one and it's just scales okay by the
factor of three but a factor of three to
the three end to inter looks like this
okay so that's the linear transformation
if you head over to the three blue one
brown channel for more detail
so uh
i know vectors are nice and values i'm
not going to take dividend math of
eigenvectors and eigenvalues but it's
just like what it does let's say you
have the new transform vector it's just
a scaled version of the original vector
so you have some vector let's say
well v you have a vector we have a
vector let's say this and it's the new
transform it's just a scale means the uh
the new vector is just scaled from this
vector like this if i choose new pen
yeah so it's
like this
then the original vector then the
original vector is the eisen vector of
the original matrix okay so you just if
your new transform you just scale from
the original then your original vector
is known as to be a eigenvector and the
factor by which it is stretched like
this green color is known as eyes in
values okay and vectors that have this
characteristics are known as eyes and
vectors okay and eisen values means the
factor by which it is scaled or
stretched are known as the eigenvalues
which is denoted by this symbol which is
lambda okay so that's the simple idea
behind eigenvectors and eigenvalues
again let's revise what we have studied
uh till now
until now we have studied about linear
transformation and a linear
transformation is a function that
transforms you from one vector space to
another with respect to lying under a
linear structure of each vector space
okay we can write out here because we
can write our value linear
transformation as a t of x
uh for example for only one d linear
equals to a x and a b to some a linear
sorry scalar okay so what we are doing
over in this example here we have this
vector of form from the interval of zero
to one we are transforming it to zero to
three by scaling it by two by a factor
of three okay
that's the linear transformation
okay and here an eigenvectorized value
we have a new transform vector which is
the linear transformation which is
happening okay it's a linear
transformation which is a new transform
vector it's a scale from the original
vector means from the original vector
like this it has been shown you over
here
then it is it is the original vector is
known as the eisen vector of the
original matrix otherwise it's just a
vector and the factor by which it is
scaled here is three the factor by which
is scale here is three then the three is
your eigenvalue okay
it's this is what the simple eisen
vector analyzing values are okay
pretty much easy what i'm trying to say
you here okay if you want to get in more
detail there is a video of
give by gilbert strang gilbert i think
i'm pronouncing correct gilbert strang
lean new algebra videos or a book by
introduction to lean your ass bra
introduction to linear algebra you can
have a look by gilbert strand or you can
have a look for a quick look at three
blue one brown video the blue one brand
video on linear algebra on youtube okay
so that's the
uh
kind of uh resources to learn more but
for now if you know this then you are
good to learn about principle covenant
analysis
okay
so you may think yeah i don't want to do
so much of math etc so you have a
library known as numpy
which you can have a look which i have
given the notebook in the description
downloads below about numpad panda so
you can have a look so we can just
implement we can just implement by this
la la is allies
l a is allies as a linear algebra we are
taking out the eyes e i z of the input
and input here is our vector okay
and this is your the eigenvector and
either value as in vector of the or this
matrix sorry yeah this is a matrix okay
so and this this matrix is just a 2
comma minus 1 4
okay so that's the matrix of 2 by 2
matrix okay
so we have started about um
linear um
algebra that is required for us for a
principal common analysis now it's time
for understanding why we are studying
this all and why why we need
dimensionality reduction
so let's say you're working on
kind of a large amount of dataset so
this is 3 000 dimensions and what do you
mean by dimensions is like the size of
the house is one dimension then floor of
a house is second dimension the number
of fans is a third dimension then etc so
unlikely that we have three thousand
features okay so we have three thousand
features so for that it you first of all
it will cause storage
second it will cost time it will even
take months to train your model so it
may even take months so you don't have
too much of computer resources okay so
that's why but in real world we have a
millions of dimensions data available so
what we do we simply use dimensionality
reduction method or technique which is a
pca to reduce your model feature with
data features or variables okay and we
typically see this in text data or image
data so let's say you have some image
let me draw one image of mine so here's
my image so it will the eye has one
dimension and it may be a millions of
dimensional data sets only one image
millions of dimensions one image i have
worked on i have worked on to that which
is
which has 75 dimensions 75 dimensions so
we have what we have to work on this
typically will be seen on your text data
where you will working on ash range
processing like what embeddings or image
data will be working on
images okay so you need the principal
common analysis
okay so what is principal common
analysis principle common analysis is a
method for dimensionality reduction that
is used to reduce the variables or the
dimensions of the data by transforming
large set of features
large set of features into smaller ones
that contains most of the information so
let's see
you have x1 then you have x2 then you
have x3 and all the parameters let's say
x 40 let's say 50 okay so what it will
common analysis does it ask you a
component let's say you have given a two
component so it will try to put it will
try to put
most of the information into the first
component x1 and it will try to put
let's say p1 and and and in the second
component most of the most of the
information in these two components
because we have say to do
reduce from 40 dimension to two
dimensions okay so so it will simply um
compress that like that or put all the
information into the first data
variation first and second if you say it
is one so it will try to put every with
most of the information in the first and
it will remove this all so obviously you
will lose some of the information from
the data but it's good to have uh not
more than dimensions okay i will give a
tip when you when you have to work on
principle component analysis
okay so what is the basic intuition
basic intuition behind principal common
analysis is that we have a principal
components which is a new variable which
are the new variable like let's say i
have i given you know p1 and p2 they are
the new principal components which are
new variables okay that are constructed
as a linear combinations of the initial
variables okay so what what what we do
uh let's say we have x1 x2
all the way down to x40 so we just try
to put in all the first and second so
it's v it's a hyperbranner two is a
complex number of accomplish the high
parameter so let's say we have taken two
okay so it will try to put most of the
information into p1 and p2 and these are
the new vectors or the unit vectors or
the variables like this all and
it's just a linear combination of these
variables okay of the initial variables
okay you will get to know the through
visualization what i'm saying and these
combinations are done in such a way that
the principal components are
uncorrelated they are uncorrelated and
most of the information
from these variables i mean size branch
etc will be compressed into the first
components and so on
okay and we're projecting each data
point on t1 onto only the first few
components to obtain a lower dimensions
of data please preserving as much as of
the data variation as possible so what
is this we are projecting etc if you
have seen orthogonality concept into
an uh linear algebra orthogonality so
what it tells so here's an uh
visualization of that so here we have a
data and what we do we take out the two
columns let's say we have two components
like this uh first dimension and then we
have a second dimension like this
okay so we have a second dimension like
this okay is these these are the
principal components which are
constructed which is which are
constructed as the linear combinations
of the initial variables so what is what
we do we project our data point onto
this we project our each and every data
point onto these
diamond uh principle components like
this
and now our data point will be on this
so here's the visualization which is
showing more about this so we are
projecting each data point onto the two
components here we have
first component and here we have second
component
okay this is the basic contribution
behind principal components so basically
we have let's say this and let's say
this one and you have a data point like
this okay so you just project the data
point onto here you project data point
under here to reduce the dimension of
the data preserving as much as
information as you can in the first
component okay so we will see the
algorithm so let's start seeing the
algorithm to understand a little bit
more detail what what we are doing okay
but for that let's review some other
concept from previous uh sites
okay so principal components are the
unit vectors uh means they are the unit
vectors like the new variables that come
out as a p one and p two whatever the p
orbital p and p c is the number of
components as constructed because
from the
linear combinations of the initial
variables
and these combination combinations are
done in such a way that the principal
components are uncorrelated okay you
will see the algorithm by this one
correlated etc and most of your
information within the initial variables
are just in a compressed in the first
and then second like this number of
components you are given okay very much
easy what i'm trying to say here okay
and
we have seen the basic intuition now
it's time for getting into the algorithm
so the first step and the first and
foremost step of this principal common
analysis is data pre-processing what do
i mean by data pre-processing means we
have to standardize our data so in this
step you standardize your data it simply
means that your data should be falling
in the same range
okay so let's say you are working on a
sum system like let's say the h uh like
the one one one where you have a one
variable which is the age
so
you have eight and let's say the first
person is twenty second person is 40
like like this so let's say a new
percentage is 1 200
is far away or far different from these
means it is it's called an outlier it's
called an outlier which is which which
is which is not in the range of age okay
and it's which is not in the range of
the common ones okay so let's say your
data is like 20 40 it's a two three so
let's use the five four four thousand so
you this is this is kind of a outlier
and principal combat analysis is
sensitive to outliers okay so what it
would do
for them for so uh so that's why we do
the standardization of the data some
sometimes we do normalization also so we
do the standardization of the data so
our data falls in the same range and the
reason why it's critical form because
it's quite sensitive regarding the
variances of the initial variables okay
if you have seen the variance and mean
if you and the formula for this is x
scale equals to x minus the mean of
x x i by the standard deviations okay
standard deviation and then you will get
the scale formula of your um
data and don't worry how to implement
this you can also implement this just by
coding in python
so let's say you have made a function
this is standardized it takes the value
of x then you should make a new variable
x scale then you subtract x minus the
mean is np dot mean of x divided by the
np dot standard deviation of x okay you
can do this but if more formula
vectorized code is in scikit-learn you
can use scikit-learn to implement it
just three lines of code okay don't
worry if you're if you are um not able
to implement from scratch
after first step after you standardize
your data now it's time for getting into
the computing your covariance matrix of
your data so what do you mean by
covariance maintenance in the cover is
basically a p by p symmetric matrix
where the diagonal are the variances of
whatever the um data but if you will t
you can have i will go to internet what
about what is covariance matrix but here
after taking out the covariance matrix
it will tell you that um that that tell
us how to feature how the features of
the input data set is varying from the
mean with respect to each other okay so
here's tells the
correlation like that that's not a
really correlation but here we have an
input date data set like x and it's va
out of how much the input data set are
varying from the mean with respect to
each other means the x1 how it's varying
from x2 and etc it is sometimes
important because they are some
variables highly uh are highly
correlated and they contain unnecessary
information to work on okay so you
should you have to you can remove that
okay so that's how we compute the
covariance matrix
pretty much easy one i'm trying to save
here okay so you just denote covariance
matrix with c and for implementing
covariance matrix you can use the again
numpy for the scientific numpy dot np
dot cough and you just give the data as
your features let's say x and you'll get
your output as a covariance matrix
okay pretty much just see i'm trying to
say you here so let's um see whatever
i've seen so far we've seen first we
have to pre-process your data like a
state of standardization or
normalization then we have to compute
the covariance matrix of your data which
tells you how the input variables are
varying from the mean with respect to
each other variables okay because it's
sometimes important because some
variables highly correlated and they
contain unnecessary information
okay the next step is computing the
eisen vectors and eigenvalues of the
covariance matrix so let's review what
we have seen in eigenvectors and
eigenvalues
so in either vectors we have seen that
if our new transform vector
is just a scale from the original vector
and the factor is called the horizon
vectors and the factored by which is
stretched is known as eisen values okay
and so that's the eigenvectors and
either values
the reason why i made this ppt is i if
if i write in blackboard that would be
not beneficial for you because i would
be saying so i had megan know so you can
have a look on the future also to see
how it's working and it's better to have
a text onto the screen to uh while
you're listening
okay okay so what we do you compute the
eyes and vectorize a value of the
covariance matrix means you come from
eigenvectors are the transform vector
from the original vector and the factor
by which the
is stretched is called the eigenvalues
okay you can easily compute the
eigenvectors and eigenvalues in python
and then what you do you sort the
columns of eisen vectors matrix v and
i's in value matrix d in order of
decreasing value what do you mean by
step four
let's say your computer eisen vectors
are nice and values and those who has um
high means high information or high
numbers so you just sort the means the
larger word in the first then larger one
in the first and larger second second
third fourth year six seven like this
okay and then after that what you do you
simply um you'll see oops let me do that
you simply uh compute the cumulative
energy content how much the content is
each eisen vector is having okay and
then you select a subset of eigenvectors
as a basis vector means let's say
you are in cyclone there is a sorry and
any other you should choose
how many number of components to use
okay that's the main thing so what you
do you simply
sort in decrease in decreasing order and
you come
the content of each engine vector and
then you select who has the high
energy or content from the top and if it
is your if you choose the principal
component two then only two highest to
highest will be choose those who have
highest number of information okay
and then you take this and then you take
this two and to project onto the
final you project data onto the new
basis okay so you prob you have a large
amount of again and and then what you do
you remove this or you project this um
pretty simple component uh this
eigenvector onto the new vectors okay
and this is the formula and this is
random device and this is the feature
vector transpose okay so we have seen so
far and here's uh uh sap what's the
algorithm of steps and i have not
written last step which is uh
projecting the data you can have a look
but because my uh kind of was not
fitting okay so first you cross
pre-process your data then you compute
the covariance matrix then you compute
the eigenvector and either values of the
covariance matrix then you rearrange the
eigenvectors and either values then you
compute the cumulative energy content of
each engine vectors although it is not
necessary because when you sort the
integrating order you the top will be
having the highest information and then
you select a subset of the eigenvectors
as basis vectors
okay so i think that we have seen so far
and i really really hope that you have
enjoyed this tutorial and in this
section uh previously i think you may
find it's quite uh intimidating now i
think that you are able to grasp that
con
concept of linear regression logistic
regression support vector machine
principal common analysis and then we
have current projects and then you have
coded boston health risk prediction
stock price prediction one
classification project you have coded
logistic and linear from scratch now in
the next section we'll we will cover the
principal component analysis from
scratch we will do by uh with ourselves
to get the more feel of the principal
color analysis okay
so i really hope that you have enjoyed
i'll be catching up your next section uh
so let's start with the next section to
learn something new okay so now we'll
start with learning theory again one of
the most important concept to learn in
machine learning and
i think gaining
some something or less
we will see the topics which will start
in this course
in this section is we will see why it is
very important means maybe it might look
a little bit more nonsense over here but
maybe if you are going to tell advanced
version of machine learning like deep
learning or nlp or computer vision it
should surely make sense type that
learning theory actually works and in
learning theory in this section we'll
learn about these three topics our main
uh
main communication main talk on to this
like bias and variance tradeoff and then
we'll move on to approximation
estimation error then we will move on
empirical versus minimization and this
this will be our new concept this this
this this will be this is these are two
just a definition just i don't just just
just a problem framed okay just a
definition which which is which is
needed because in many of these research
papers they have listed uh empirical
risk minimization of or approximation
estimation error the reason why they
have maybe some in history they may
might be have different something out of
different choices okay so we will study
we will just see the definition of these
and and it will surely make sense but if
it is not please be sure to
ignore it for now continue with this
course and you are free for your feel
free to come again okay you're feel free
to come again and then watch this do
concept because it will surely make
sense okay so let's start with bias and
variance okay so in bias and variance
here we will study about bias and
various tradeoffs and here is your
warning warning is is learning is is
this is one of the easiest concept to
learn as instructed by even uh whenever
i heard that this easiest concept to
learn and it seems to easiest but it's
very hard to master very hard to master
and i hope that you heard andrew nung
saying this and i think this this
actually makes sense if you're a
beginner then it might not because you
will understand everything but it when
you are actually developing the product
it's a very very important to keep track
of bias and various trade-offs and etc
okay so let's start with
bias and variance but before that we are
going to recall our two problems which
is
my favorite overfitting oops not my
favorite it's an overfitting and under
fitting okay so here is my favorite
diagram uh from the google so here uh
let's assume that we have a
time and x axis and values and y-axis
okay so maybe some kind of problem okay
so here you have these data points here
you have this data points and what you
do you just flip a straight line that's
a simple linear regression simple
simple
linear
regression okay you just fitted a simple
linear regression which is just theta
zero times uh x0 plus theta 1 times x1
okay so um plus theta 2 times x2 okay so
here you just assume that we have a
straight line using a linear regression
okay but you can see over here that the
tree it is not performing well on the
training set also means
this is my training set so it is not
performing well uh the the residual
error or the cost function will be very
very high will be very very high
okay the cost function which is j of
theta which will be very very high in
this case so we call it as under fill
okay so the major problem makes a major
major problem that make this problem
occur is that you have a low amount of
features
low
amount of features
or you have low amount of data or you
have a low amount or you have a low
amount of data okay so these two causes
the problem so your low amount of
features low amount of data okay and
that can be that that can be sensed
using just by
adding more data or adding more feature
or if you don't have feature you can do
feature engineering to generate more
features okay so uh just to do not focus
on future engineering for now because
it's not a data science course but
obviously you just need a simple feature
engineering means it's just generating
more features based on our features so
let's what an example that you are
building a spam detection system so
let's assume that we are building a spam
detection system where you have a one
column which is of text another column
which is the label whether the whether
that text is a spam or ham so it is a
label okay so you can generate more
feature like length of the text what is
the now how many number what is the
number of a text in that what is the
number of words in that text what is the
number of characters so you can you take
you using this this this text feature
you generate more three features and
that's called a feature engineering okay
so i think we if you if you if you see
i'll be very happy to make a video on a
feature engineering okay it will it will
be a full place data science course
okay so here after this we have our
simple linear question which is just
like this now this is called underfitted
and major problem that i've seen so far
in my experience is a low amount of
feature stack that we have okay so
in general the underfooted me the under
underfitting means is just that your
model is not performing well on the
training set and it's obvious that
you'll not perform well onto the testing
set so that's why we call this under
fitting okay the next picture of here is
good fit slash robust robust means it
will it will be very robust which is a
very good fit you can see you it is a
very good fit the cost the residual
error is low the residual error is low
and it says we have a very good
polynomial kind of thing um
a
non-linear uh or or i can see here
against a nonlinear
or a polynomial regression over here we
have applied polynomial regression and
here's what we get the as a as a as a
hypothesis okay so here you can see that
is a very good fit and this is this is
the robust model okay so we can say that
this model is performing well under the
training set
as well as on the testing set because
whatever example will come here the
residual error will be low okay so like
like that is perfecting well under
training and testing set another picture
which tells you about overfitting what
do you mean by overfitting overfitting
simply means that your model performs
very very well or i can say that your
model wants very very well under
training set where your cost function
your cost function of j of theta is
equals to zero okay where you you don't
have any residual error or approximately
equals to zero okay so your cost
function is very very low so you can
assume that your model learned a lot
which is touching each and every
examples your model learned a lot so
that's why your cost function is very
very low and cost function is just
denoted by the submission over i equals
to 1 all the way down to the m
h of x i h of x i
minus y i squared okay and just taking
out the difference between the predicted
and actual value and here the the
predicted and actual value are on the
same line so here you you your model
want a very nonlinear
hypothesis it all it happens
that if if you have a lot of features a
lot of features and here you have a low
features and here if you have a lot of
features that happens okay and maybe you
have used too much of degree in
polynomial regression so that's why it
happens or maybe something kind of a
other no a very kind of complex
architecture or you have or you have
made a very complex function f of x with
the highest
x4 etc like that like that okay so this
is this is the this is the problem for
overfitting and whatever new example
come over here your model will be very
very high whatever come here the
residual layer will be very very high
okay so your model will fail to
generalize well onto the new training
examples okay so
in general overfitting means over
overfitting means that your model
perform bad or or against your model
perform very very well under training
setting which your cost function is low
is is it is equal to zero which is
actually good but but you you may think
it is good but just just wait that your
testing set error is very very high okay
so that indicates the problem of
overfitting so
we can prevent overfilling by selecting
some of the important features
selecting important features or
regularization so regularization is just
advanced version of selection of
features so let's see what it does
okay so i have already told you about
regularization now in our regularized
linear models and i hope that you
understood that okay so now we will uh
see the bias and variance trade-off by
taking a look at some scenario of your
model okay so let's assume that you are
building some model okay so you are
building some model and your model gives
one percent error one percent error on a
training set so you have one training
training set like this
and you divided this training set into
uh training
and evaluation set so you have this
whole data you have this whole data and
you divided this in training and
evaluation set okay so what you've done
you've taken a one percent adder under
the training set one percent adder on a
training set which is uh if you see oh
you one percent error one percent error
on a training set and fifteen percent
error on the evaluation set so you can
assume that your model is you can see
that your model is overfilling because
your error is very very low end training
set but your error in validation set is
actually 15 which is very high okay
according to this okay so it is
performing a very very well on a
training set but it's fails to
generalize well onto the testing set so
it is overfitting and in this case we
say that the model is having high
variance and we use bagging we use
bagging to reduce high variance which
you will see in ensembl learning methods
or sections so don't don't worry you can
come back again to this section to watch
this okay so this is this is how you
identify if your model is having high
variance next
next is that let's assume that your
model is giving a 15 percent adder on a
training set on the training set okay
15 percent add-on training set and
sixteen percent adderall
on evaluation set so it is not
performing well under training set
obviously to not perform well on the
evaluation set so it seems to be
underfitting so here it has high bias
and we use boosting we use boosting to
reduce bias
okay so this is this this is what i'm
saying and let's take let's stick for
the sake of an example again again
example that your model is having both
high bias and high variance where you
have a 15 percent error which is
obviously high variance and 30 percent
error on evaluation which is obviously
high bias okay so it is both overfilling
and unfitting and obviously it has a
high bias and high variance okay the
next our favor and last example of this
bias and variance tradeoff is your model
gives 0.5 percent model gifts 0.5
percent or training set and one percent
underscore testing set so it seems to be
a perfect model or a robust model where
it's not learned too much on training
setting for it is a very robust and good
model okay here it seems to be a good so
we can say it is it has a low bias where
it has a very small error and it has a
low variance where it has on training
set is a very good okay so this is this
is what we consider for low bias and low
variance and all of these all of these
we take assumption do you know what
assumption oops you don't know but
because you're watching but uh
when we take an assumption that base
error or human level performance or
human or human
level performance human level
performance is approximately equal to
zero percent is approximately equal to
zero percent so what do i mean with this
assumption i what what do i mean with
this assumption that we take our base
error to be base error base error to be
approximately zero percent in all of
these examples in all of this example
this example this example this example
okay so let's see what's that human
level of bayes error is so here you can
see that you're you're you're going to
build some uh classification model or
maybe the face detection model okay so
your build your you have built the face
detection or face recognition or real
time face recognition so your algorithm
even you will fail to identify this
person even i will fail to identify this
person the reason why because it's very
blurred very very very with blood okay
so even a human even a human
human error okay hlp you even in human
error will be very very high very very
high because he will be not able to he
will be not able to uh either identify
who's this person is okay so so so and
you can cannot expect that your model
should be very great over here you can
expect that your model is very your
model is also giving the same error as
you are giving because you are also not
able to identify as well as your model
also not not able to identify and
actually this is not this is here the
hlp hlp is very very high or i can say
the base error is very very high so we
can say that here um you can
you cannot expect your algorithm to work
best but let's assume that that you have
a fresh image and where the hlp is
equals to zero means human level
performance is equal to zero and you now
you can expect your algorithm
performance to be good because it is the
human performance is equals to zero so
that's called the base error and and i
hope that you understood the next
uh we we have talked about bias and
variance trade-off you can again rebound
this video to understand again but what
is approximation estimation error this
is just a definition
so the approximation estimation error
approximation error in some data is the
difference between exact value and the
approximation of it and this
approximation indicates your f of x
means the outputted model uh the output
from the model so we here your f x given
some approximation and this is the
ground truth which is y hat okay so
difference between these both is called
as approximation error okay so here i've
taken one example from wikipedia again
it's a scale example but that's that's
that's generally mean i i already told
you 9 cost function you take out the
difference between that's an
approximation estimation error okay so
it's just like this if the exact value
is 50 and the approximation is 449.9
then the error will be 0.1 and that's
actually what you do when taking out the
error for one training example you just
subtract this and the regression problem
what you do you just subtract y hat
minus y and then and you get your answer
okay and then you add submission for
every i for every eye etc okay so this
is what you do and this is just a
definition because you will see a lot in
your research papers okay next one is
empirical risk minimization again we
have seen so an algorithm receives as an
input on a training set so i'm going to
just i make you familiar with this what
i'm saying that an algorithm receives as
an input a training set as means
we we get and we get our training set
which is a sample from the large
distribution d okay so we get our sample
from the distribution d means large we
just take out some
sample and label by some target function
y okay so here we have our training set
as well as we'll be having the labels
for it because this is a this is framed
on supervised learning okay so here we
will be having label as well as the
samples for each training example okay
and should make a predictor we should
make a f
the predictor that maps our input
variable x means these features to the
output variable y okay and the goal of
this algorithm is to minimize the error
outputted with the respect to the
unknown d means now we will feed a new
example that a model has not have
even seen
and your model should be very minimal or
you or your or your model should be
audio model errors should be very
minimal okay so this is what the full
definition is saying
and it simply means that we want to come
up with the predictor l
subscript s h we're going to come up
with the l of h with sub subscript s
where s emphasis the fact that the
output predictor depends on s okay so
whatever the output will be it depends
on s because we have taken we have
learned we have learned the weights we
have learned the w we have learned the
theta one theta two all around n from
these s so that's emphasizes that
minimizes the risk or the error which is
called the erm which is called the
empirical risk minimization okay so i
hope that you understood this concept
very much clearly and i really hope that
you had enjoyed seeing this section and
we i have talked a lot on empirical risk
minimization learning theory and et
cetera so i hope that you will utilize
this uh way and we have already talked
about uh
the job and now you can continue further
if you haven't understood anything you
can feel free to ask in the comment box
below i'll be very happy to take your
down and be sure to have a look at the
course website which is already
available in the description box below
so meet you in the next section
okay a very warm welcome in this section
and
in this section we will be talking about
decision tree one of my favorite topic
to talk on as i will go in depth of
decision tree to make you understand
everything and decision free with
intuitive examples with solved examples
of decision tree as i have seen on
youtube that they are there some
instructors are doing great job but they
are not doing that into decision tree
means for free so i just want to make
you familiar with decision tree whoever
is watching this tutorial into depth and
i really hope that you will enjoy this
section but before that what we are
going to cover in this section are as
follows first we will start with the
introduction geometric intuition a basic
intuition about decision tree what the
actual the decision trees are
and then we will go further into how we
were building that decision tree so for
building we will learn some sub tasks of
concept which is like entropy
information gain a guinea impurity okay
then after that we will build our own
decision trees and then i will show you
the implementation of decision tree okay
but before that let's uh understand the
basic intuition of decision tree as
there will be more topics which we'll
cover
as i will discuss later on okay okay so
let's start so uh first of all what is
decision tree decision tree is a
supervised learning algorithm okay so it
is a supervised learning algorithm and
what do i mean by supervised learning is
that we are having our uh
x rx 1 with our label y1 all the way
down to the x2 then we have i2 all the
way down to the xn
and we have y okay so we are having
labels so it is a supervised learning
algorithm
and it is used for both like support
with the machine is used for both
regression classification so it is used
for both uh classification and
regression okay so uh you will see how
we do how we construct the distant tree
like that okay so let's start with um
the basic intuition of decision tree so
the definition of decision trees that
they are nested if an else
statements okay if you're a programmer
then you will be relating this concept
which is if and else and the python is a
prerequisite or any programming language
is a prerequisite so
what is this entry it is just a nested
if and l statement so it is a nested it
is a nested if and else statement so i
don't know why it is so bold so it is a
nested if and else statement
um so is what it does is just ask a
question and it splits the data okay so
let me write the formal definition to
make your more uh intuitive intuition
behind so they are
nested
nested
if and else
statements okay so he's just ask
questions is just ask questions
is just ask questions and splits the
data okay so it's just ask question and
splits the data so
let me take one example of iris data set
let me take one example
of iris
data set okay so what we do when iris
data set so but
what let me make you familiar with what
is that this data set to make you more
clear understanding of this topic okay
so iris data is simply like this you
have a data set which has four features
like sepal length sepal with petal and
parallel petalworth okay and you have
the label which is the species of the
flower okay so this is a task of flower
species detection under the basis of
four features okay so this is a
classification data set a binary class
classification data set so you were
having and like this so let me change my
color i don't know why it is so bold
okay so you have like this uh first you
have sepal length sepal length and then
i i i hope that you understand what is
sepal and what is parallel so sepal
width then you have petal length
and then you have a petal width okay and
then you have a one more column which is
the label which indicates for the
species so let's take an example 2.2
4.30 that's a 3.2
4.6 and the label is um acetosa satosa
okay so you have three classes in this
data set as a label which is cetosa
which we label as one sorry zero
versicolor versicolor which we label as
one and virginica virginica which is
labeled as two okay so the output will
be either zero means a tossa then either
it will be one means we're cycler or
virginica as in quotas as two okay so
that's the iris data set that i had just
make you familiar with okay so let's
what what we will do we will not make
use of any library will not be used and
then anything we will simply what what
we will do we will simply make a
decision tree by yourself by making just
if an else condition okay so we'll make
a simple classifier obviously it is not
so formal but we'll make a simple
classifier that will simply classify
your flowers okay so that's what we are
going to do
so let me remove this and i really hope
that you understand what this data set
is and more uh understand uh if you want
to more in detail about what the data
set is you can search online this is a
famous data set like iris state data set
which is just for flower species
detection system okay so
let's start so first uh
here we have an um variable x's here we
have our x's which is sepal length sepal
width parallel length and parallel width
okay so we are having these features and
we have a y i which indicates either one
or two or two or zero or two okay so
that's the basic intuition uh means of
the data set part we are given this data
set now what we will do we will make
classifier like this first if we write
if let me choose another pen okay i i
hope that i should choose a better pen
like this blue okay okay so if
the parallel length is smaller than some
a and may a may be some number a maybe
some number let's say let's say 2.3 a
maybe some number if petal length is
smaller than a then consider
y
to be um
for cycler okay so let's consider y to
be one okay
if not if it is parallel length is
greater than a then what do what what to
do oops i hope that it is getting not
clear
what what happened
i have to buy my new computer why do i
don't know what to why it is so much
lagging okay so you'd if it is smaller
than a the parallel length then consider
your flower is means of
a versailles color and we have we have
made one one and if if it is parallel
and if your parallel length is not is is
greater than a then what you will do you
will write else
if
separate you take again one feature you
take a game one feature and says if it
is smaller than b if sepal length is
smaller than b
then you will you consider your y to be
uh virginians too okay
if it is not if it is not if both is
both condition fails then say if both
condition fails then say that your
output is setosa okay so here is our
simple decision tree we're using two
features we have made the decision trees
using two features so let me make it
more intuitive i i i hope so that you
are able to understand okay so that's
why i'm speaking very slow so here let
me tell you what i'm if petal length
here we are we have taken two features
which is petal length and sepal length
okay we had not taken this uh this two
features okay but you can make that but
this is not a formal decision tree this
is just for an example this is obviously
not correct okay so
you had to
make a mid one if condition that if the
parallel length is smaller than some a
and a can be anything 2.3
4.3 that that is usually i'm taking
anything but it is usually taken uh
which will see um in one of our data set
we will see how it is chosen and you
will obviously see how it is selected
okay so if it is smaller than a parallel
length then consider that y
to be equals to one if it is not let me
check that this recording is on here
okay regarding is on okay so we if the
parallel length smaller than a then we
consider our y to be this uh versionica
okay if the pedal length is greater than
a or is it this this this condition
fails this condition fails it then goes
to else condition and in else condition
it this is again a nested loop nested
sorry not if an assess control flow just
check if your sepal length is smaller
than b if it is then you say that y
equals to virginica okay and otherwise
if this condition also fails then it
says else your y means y should be
satosa and you have this hole into the
this
nested loop in this and you have this
whole classifier and this is your whole
classifier so that this is the decision
tree yeah so let me make this
diagrammatically in the terms of
decision tree so
in terms of decision tree we can write
this equation this uh
this if
statement first we have our root node
this uh we have first we make our root
node like this
let me make one root node here we have
our root node
with this condition if a parallel length
parallel length is smaller than a okay
then if it is if it is yes
then you say your y to be
one okay if it is no if your parallel
length is no okay you consider you again
make one more condition which is sepal
length is smaller than b if it is yes
then you what you do you classify this y
equals to two if it is not if it is not
then you take it as a zero and your
whole three variable uh target variables
are covered and this is the decision
tree and this is whole this is the
decision tree i have made in yellow this
is the decision
tree is just ask a question on the data
set if the pedal is smaller than a if it
is then consider y equals to one if it
is not then again we have made another
another decision and then we uh if it is
yes or if it is known like this okay so
that's the this is the decision tree
it's damn is like this okay so here
again i'm saying this is what you do
just believe me yeah we had this is the
decision tree and how it is constructed
we will see okay so we have made this as
a final statement yesterday if an else
statement like this and this is what the
decision tree is so here are certain
terminology that we will have to see
over here
so here are the the details that we
should
know okay so the the
the first node or head node is no is
known as root node is known as a root
node or parent node okay this is this is
a root node obviously this is also a
parent node and these are the child node
these are the child node
okay child node and this is the parents
node and this is also the parent node
and this is the terminal node this is
the terminal or leaf node because you
are not splitting this node into further
nodes so this is called the terminal and
this is also a terminal node this is
also a terminal node okay this is also
terminal or a leaf node this is some
sometimes called a leaf node when you
are not spitting further okay so this is
a leaf node or you consider it as a leaf
node this is the whole thing is called
the branch this whole thing is called
branch
use
this whole thing is called branch okay
and that's the basic terminology of this
okay and this is the splitting of your
data okay this is the this is what you
are doing doing which is splitting okay
if you're removing some node let's take
an example this then you are pruning it
okay then you are pruning this node but
we and we don't know we don't want right
now okay so that's the that's what
that's the decision free and i hope that
you understood this example
clearly and i really really hope that
you will uh that you got a very good
intuition of decision tree in much
smaller span of time in much easy way
okay so i hope that you remember this
terminology either i will make you
familiar with terminology by the time
also if it is not required for
remembering all those things okay but
this is it's it's best to
take a paper and a pen and write notes
with me whatever i'm writing okay and
just listen me carefully
after listening me you can make notes
okay so now let's see what's the
decision boundaries will look like
okay what's the decision boundaries will
look like or the hyperplanes will look
like but what do i mean with hype
airplanes i mean with hyperplane
decision boundary is let's take an
example of linear regression in linear
regression we are making a straight line
this is called the hypothesis decision
boundary then we have a hyperplane it's
called the hyperplane in support victim
machine we are also making hyperplane in
logistic regression we are also making
hyperplane means a decision boundary so
in the decision decision tree we also
have the diffusion boundaries okay or
hydroplanes so let's see how it is
constructed so i don't know i will be
able to make that image or not but i
will fully try that okay so here uh let
let me make one x and y plane x and y
oops i'm
please anyone help me to make this
okay let me do that oops i'm just
freaking out let me do it again
yeah okay great so i have made one and
this is my x-axis
this is this is my x-axis and this is my
y-axis and we have a two features which
is sample length and uh parallel uh
length i think so yeah so we have
parallel length in the x-axis and we
have separate length in the y-axis okay
so we i i have just made it you can
remove this y-axis maybe it will confuse
you in in our x's we have petal length
and y axis pf zeppelin because we have
taken only two features in this example
we have we are not taking more features
like parallel with and past apple width
okay so what what we consider what we
have done we have considered we have
considered
this full reason we have considered this
full reason
this full reason
to be y equals to one okay
this hyperplane this hyperplane list
let's name it as a first type of plane
so this full reason is our y equals to
one means whatever data point will come
is considered y equals to one and this
is just this is just the if statement
that we have seen if parallel length if
parallel length is smaller than a okay
then y equals to one so that's this is
the full reason okay means we have not
for this bit so it is just a full reason
where y equals to one if that condition
passes
okay then another hyperplane we can
construct let me choose another pen
another hyperplane be construct that
this reason
this reason
would consider
y equals to
2 okay y equals to 2. if
the sepal length is smaller than b if
the points come in this
region then it is it will consider y
equals to 2.
another we have hyper plane let me take
another pen that let me take another pen
let's take an example of blue
okay
another outcome we can consider that as
a y equals to three okay if that
if that falls in this region so here we
are constructing hyper planes and if
some with something come here then
control y goes to one it's y equals to
two or y equals to three with these two
features obviously it will be more
dimensionally high when you plot the
four features okay so
you can see that we have a hyper planes
where we are able to make predictions
okay and we have made a simple
classifier okay but something to note
over here that all your hyper planes are
axis parallel okay our x is parallel
means this is parallel and this is
parallel so you can see over here that
all the hyperplanes are x is parallel
okay so that's the i i hope that you
understood decision trees in that and
um this is the basic exam intuition that
i want to give it to you in more uh
sophisticated way or not sophisticated
it's just a good way okay
okay so as i've tried it to keep it as
simple as i can and i kept it okay so
let's uh let's
let's start building or let's start with
mathematical region that's how we
construct these kind of decision trees
these kind of decision trees how we
construct okay so
but before that we have what what what
we do we uh
how we choose the variable or how we
choose the feature to be the root node
or the bran or this this how we split so
we have attribute selection measure and
you if you select run randomly like i
have choose a petal land of you if you
choose ran randomly then you will be
ended a very bad model so we have
different attribute selection measure we
like entropy information gain gain
impurity which we'll see in detail to
understand the how we select the
attribute to be as a root node or like
this okay so let's take a let's take an
example of this data set if you want to
split this data set what feature you
will use you
what are you going to use outlook as
your feature root node or temperature as
a root nor or humidity as a root node or
when as a root node okay and play tennis
is our uh label so which you will use if
you choose run randomly maybe you will
be end up ending up with a bad model
okay so you have to do that kind of
thing no so we will we will uh
scientists or researchers have done a
very great job even you all have to do
all this kind of thing research and
please keep contributing to the ai
community that maybe and i'm also doing
research in machine learning and
definitely will come up with something
extra okay so um different measures
different measures are
different attribute selection measure
are entropy we have entropy
then we have the second number we have
information gain information gain
information gain
which we usually write as ig
then we have guinea impurity then we
have
guinea impurity
and is simply
uh
i
g okay so we denote like this okay so uh
we will talk about all of these three
and i and i hope that you will uh
understand each of them okay so let's
start with entropy okay
so
uh
entropy let me write it more formally
yeah so what first of all what is
entropy entropy is the attribute
selection measure it's the measure of a
randomness okay how pure or how pure
that attribute is to be used as some
nodes or a root node okay so it's the
measure of randomness so let me write
the definition because definition is
also important and if you want this kind
of all my notes you can simply write me
right with me along either you can
comment or
join the newer community discord
community and ask me there i will be
able to give okay so ask me there i will
be able to give all this entropy etc is
the measure is the measure
of randomness it's the measure
of
randomness okay the higher the entropy
is the higher the the higher the entropy
is the harder to draw any information
from them okay so it's if the higher the
entropy is it's very hard to break your
uh
node okay or to choose the node so um
our entropy should be low to to be
considered as is uh leaf node but still
don't don't worry i will dig dive into
the cases to make you more understand
what do i mean with these terms okay but
first of all uh let's take and i will
show you one equation and then i will
show you um how some first of all one
example and then i will show you
properties of entropy okay so first of
all uh
let's take an example where you were
given you have y
to be maybe uh
y1
y2 all the way down to the y k and in
this case you are naughty this is not
examples this is a this this is like
maybe satosa means what is the number of
classes you have okay so um maybe you
have binary classifier or you have a
multi-class classifier okay so you what
is the number of a classifier so maybe
you have in the in the iris satosa we
have here's uh versus
tosa vergenic and ver cycler so we here
we have y equals y equals to y1 to
vctosa then we have virginica then we
have very cycler means three wise okay
so that's what i mean with this okay so
let's first of all let me give you um
let let me give you the equation okay so
the equation is defined as like this
h we define our entropy by h
equals
to let me choose white color because i
like white much okay
minus mini uh this is this minus is very
important minus
the submission
i equals to 1 all the way around to the
k and k here is the number of your what
is the class what is the number of a
class okay
p of y probability being y i
log
of base and b is usually taken as 2 or e
okay to a 2.713
okay so b is usually taken as 2 or 3 but
usually take b as a 2. so if you were
taking p as a 2 then you can consider it
as l g if you're taking b as a e then
then you take as l and natural logarithm
and you have a log 2 base a log 2 um
with a log with a base 2 okay this means
lg okay so you take log
of
p
of
y i okay and that's the full equation of
your entropy means it's just measures
the randomness okay so let's let's take
one example because it is i i i i know
that is making no sense to you and i
know that is making no sense to you but
i will make sure that it will make sense
okay so
first
is
you we want to measure our randomness
for playing golf okay you want to
measure your randomness for playing golf
okay so let me write play
golf
oops uh let me write the data set first
what's the data set we'll be using so we
have this play golf data set play
goal data set
where if it is what is the number of
yes
which is
9
and what is the number of uh no which is
5
okay so this is our data set like this
and let me make this also okay so this
is a day-to-day data set and you want to
take out the entropy of playing golf
okay playing golf
okay and here we want to take out
entropy of being no
being no
and being yes
okay so what you do first
you take out
the entropy entropy of 0.36
log 2
0.36 minus means this is your first this
is your first
y i this is your first y means yes sorry
no this is for no and minus let me make
it
up okay minus
0.64
log
base 2
0.64
okay
this is what we have and the answer is
0.94
okay so here what we what what we are
doing over here that first we are
writing this this equation p of y i
times the log of for no and then we are
writing for a yes okay and there is
subtracting and we have um entropy at
0.94 and it can be further splitted okay
okay so this this this was the
basic calculation of entropy but let's
see some cases of entropy to make you
more sense of this uh entropy um
attribute selection measure okay so we
will see some properties so let's uh
consider let's consider that that we
have y to be two class means we have a
binary classifier we have where we have
two class one is yes one is yes and
other one is no okay
any kind of yes or no whether it is
playing tennis or etcetera that's yes or
no okay so let's take an example of
let's let's take one scenario let's take
one scenario number one okay so here is
our scenario which tells
we here use data here is your data and
number of a yes is a 99
number of a yes is 99 in your data means
these are the your y labels so we have
two unique values in your y labels so
here you have yes and no so in that case
your yes is around 99
and your no is about one percent
is about one percent okay this is your
case one so let's take out the entropy
for this
h
of y
minus you're taking minus 0.99
means 99
log means lg i'm writing log not two
maybe i'm writing a log of
0.99 minus
this this is for my
yes means this is for my yes because we
have added a summation for each for each
uh y variable so we are for we are doing
for each for each y variable okay minus
0.01
the log of 0.01 and your output is
0.0801
okay so that's the your entropy okay so
let's take one more scenario let's take
one more scenario
scenario number two
and here let's take an example of your
data having the yes to be around 50
and
your no
is around 50
okay
so um if you take out entropy of this if
you take out entropy of this minus 0.5
log of 0.5 minus 0.5 log of 0.5 which is
equals to 1 which is equals to 1 and the
maximum maximum entropy is 1 and it is
and this is very very hard to add to
split this to split this it's very very
hard okay so it's maximum entropy is one
let's take another scenario and if you
have a binary classifier i'm taking an
example your maximum entropy is one if
you have a binary classifier if you have
a multi-class then the equation changes
okay which you can see on internet but
most of most of the cases if you
understand binary you will be able to
understand multi-class okay let's take
another scenario scenario number three
okay scenario number three tells you so
now your number tells you that you're a
d
which has
yes to be around zero percent
and you have
no to be around hundred percent so
you're in trophy over here would be
zero okay your entropy will be zero and
minimum entropy is zero over here okay
so you can see some cases that is
if you have id3 follows if you have um
if you have a some algorithm means a
decision tree follows that if you have
entropy equals to zero then you consider
that as a leaf node and what is leaf
node
as a your prediction if your entropy is
zero then you consider that as a leaf
node if your entropy is one then it
needs further splitting or if your
entropy is
big means uh your entropy
for binary is generally
greater is
like this your entropy is generally
like this
entropy is in between or equals to okay
so your entropy will be in in this range
so
some
means uh algorithm follow id3 there is
one one algorithm called id3 instance
sub subset of uh decision tree algorithm
so id3 follows if your entropy is zero
then you consider r is small then you
consider as a root a leaf node if it is
one or large entropy then then you then
it needs further splitting okay so
that's the entropy and i really hope
that you understood entropy in detail so
let me make you familiar with what what
we have seen so far so we had talked
about decision tree which you can
reverse back to c more but i'm going to
uh recapitulate the entropy so what do i
mean by entropy entropy is the measure
of a randomness that measures if your
attribute needs for the splitting or
it's considered as a root node or it
could consider as a leaf node or like
that okay
so we have taken one example of playing
golf and then uh and
then we have taken us some three
scenario where we have seen that it is
very hard to split it is very hard to
split if you have it is it is
it's very hard to
get you get information if your entropy
is high so it needs for this splitting
okay so if you have years to be have 50
percent know to be 50 percent then
entropy will be one if you have another
scenario then then it will be like this
i can um just see the cal calculation
you can see the calculation if you want
to be uh to understand it much better
okay so that's what uh
these certain trophy is but let's see
the diagram of entropy visually it's a
bit interesting okay it's a bit
interesting so let me draw one diagram
of entropy okay so here we have our let
me draw one let me draw a good one so
here we have zero here we have one okay
so
i i hope so that i'm i'm not able to
draw it but let me try at least okay and
the highest entropy is one the highest
entropy is one okay is one and this is
the diagram of entropy this is the
diagram of entropy okay so the highest
entropy can be one
if you're taking with this equation okay
i have already showed you approved you
so this is an example of entropy
okay
great so we have seen the entropy which
is a measure of a randomness so now
let's talk about the another attribute
selection measure which is information
gain okay we'll talk about information
gain
let me write it down
in for formation
gain
and i will take an example
of i i will explain you information gain
with the help of one data set
which is
all i have already showed you i thought
i will give you a surprise with that but
i've already showed you
let me show you again
so here we have that data set
let me show you yeah here is our data
set
okay let me
draw back like this
okay so here is our data set which is
played tennis okay um this is a play
tennis data set and what we will do we
will i will make you familiar just see
this data set and look at this data set
i will be looking i have already looked
at okay so here you have a plate and
this is target variable and you have
these features so we will see which
feature to use or which feature to not
okay so here um you can just see what
i'm uh you have around
one two three four five as a no and one
two three four five six seven eight nine
nine as a yes okay
so we will uh we just see the cities and
now let's come back to information game
to understand first i will give you an
overview of what information gain is and
then we will dive deep oops where is my
i don't know why my computer is lagging
just give me a comment why it is very
lagging
okay so here is my information gain
okay great
i hope that everyone is able to see
yeah okay great so let's consider you
have the data set b okay so you have the
data set d like this let me consider
this as a data set let me consider d
oops wow it's we have a data set which
is d and what you do you further divide
this data set into your uh
uh
for the data sets for the smaller sub
subset of this data set and
how we will divide this subset of this
data set it means that you divide this
data into versions and what versions
maybe let's take an example of iris data
set okay so what you what you do what
you do you divide this uh satosa
versicolor and virginica into three data
set which concerns citosa
versailles color and virginica okay so
whatever examples of versitosa
will go in this data set whatever
examples of virginica will come will go
in this data set whatever
whatever examples will go where cycler
will go in this data set so that's for
you what you do you divide your data
bases on the number of labels and i'm
talking about binary classification
classical for classifier or uh
classification task over here okay so
what you do you divide your data set uh
first to divide
for d v one then you divide for dv2 then
you divide it for dv3 okay dv3 okay and
what you do you take out the entropy you
take out the entropy of this the v1 you
take out the entropy of dv2 then you
take out the entropy of dv3 okay and
maybe there's this kind of cytosa
versicolor virginia you take out entropy
and then you take out the entropy of
your whole data distribution okay before
splitting so you take out the entropy
before splitting and then you take out
the entropy after splitting okay so take
out entropy before splitting like this
okay
after that you you minus it you subtract
you subtract your uh h of d at
the function the entropy means
previous entropy means previous entropy
this entropy h of t which is the
entropy before splitting minus
minus
let me write it down minus
the weighted entropy which is this which
is whatever the weighted entropy will
come so let's see how we that having
helped the help of an example what the
what i'm talking about uh this how to
calculate one one example to make it
more familiar uh weighted entropy how do
you take of the intubated entropy so you
just multiple uh minus it with the
weighted entropy okay after splitting
entropy after splitting so let's see how
it is done in more detail okay so i've
just given you you what do what the
formula is just to divide your data into
success of your data like the divisions
and then you take out the entropy before
the splitting and then you take out the
entropy after splitting okay so let's
see
so uh first let's take out the entropy
of division number one of division
number one
here i'm going to take out entropy of
division number one with the help of
that plate in its data set okay so oops
h
of dv1
which is he there we have
three
five means first time writing for uh
three means first i'm writing for yes
okay first i'm writing for yes
where we have our where we had divided
our data data set into a yes or no so
there we are having total of five
examples where three examples are yes
and two examples are no
and out of five okay then the entropy
will be 0.64 okay but you then again
what you do you take out entropy of your
division number two
you it will be zero and it in the same
you take out a division number for
division number three zero point ninety
seven okay what then what you do you do
the you take out the average entropy and
that's that's equals to zero point sixty
four then that's equals to zero point
sixty four and the
formula for calculating your weighted
entropy is like they just wait for a few
seconds the formula for calculating your
entropy
weighted entropy is like this let me
write it down
first what you do you take out this i
think it says it's not 64 it's yeah so i
will just multiply with the first
division number one here we
at d1 the norm of d1
divided by d
times
the entropy
of d1
then you what you do you
plus
d2 the norm of d2
times
an entropy of d2
plus
norm of d3 norm of d3 and this is the
division number three data set divided
by the norm of d okay and this is your
full data this is d is a full data so
you take out the size of that full data
okay then you again d3
y okay and then this is your average
entropy that you get after all of this
after you've taken out the weighted
entropy then that that will be
equal to some number and then what you
do you subtract you subtract your
entropy previous entropy you subtract
your entropy before the splitting you
subtract to entropy before the spitting
minus
minus you get after splitting so let me
write the formal equation for ig what
you get okay so id
ig
equals to y
and any var means variable maybe
variable can be outlook a variable can
be outlook or temperature
temperature of that from that or windy
or humidity okay so in that we will
check if though if the higher the
entropy higher the
information gain is we can select that
as a root node okay so what you do you
just
you just take the entropy of your data
full data and then you
pre premise of your data and then you
minus it minus i equals to one although
all the way on to the key the norm of di
means the division of your data and this
is simply uh the maybe satosa or then
verse cycle or yes or no like that so
divided by the full full d
times
the
entropy of di okay
so this is your weighted entropy this is
your
weighted
weighted
entropy
and this is your
this is your entropy okay before you're
splitting and then you will get the
information gain for that you for that
variable okay so we will see uh one more
example later on when we will be
building our own uh
decision tree by yourself mathematically
so again let's recapitulate what we have
seen so far we have simply seen we have
simply seen so let's uh go back to that
data set let's go back to that data set
so here is my data set
i don't know actually where yeah
here is my data set
and here what what we do we take this
data set and we simply um
divide this data set into multiple
divisions into two divisions okay so we
divide this data data set into
yes
and no
okay and whatever number of examples
will come we take out let's take an
example here we have
9 over total number of data examples and
here we have a five over total number of
examples okay so what you do you simply
nine by fourteen
log of nine by fourteen minus five by
fourteen
log of phi by 14 okay then you will get
some entropy which is your entropy of
your data okay entropy of your
data before is splitting okay so that's
what the entropy is and i and i hope
that you understood what i'm trying to
say over here
and this is your for yes and this is
your for no because you have added a
submission of your entropy like this i
equals to 1 all the way down to the k
then you have a probability of y i minus
the log of means with base 2 probability
of y i okay so that's what we are doing
you are doing the same over here
but this time you have 2 so that's what
you're doing too and this is only for
binary you can see equations for
multi-class okay so that's what the an
info
information gain is and here what what
we do we take out data in the our first
we take out the entropy of that data and
then we divide our data into multiple
divisions and here we have three cluster
um
categories so we divided into three
categories with two categories you could
develop two categories and then take our
entropy of that categories and then you
take out the weighted entropy okay
without uh rather thinking of the
average you take out the weighted
entropy of that uh after splitting these
all you take out the fader entropy then
you subtract and how you take out the
weighted entropy here is an equation i'm
going to give it to you it's just i have
already given but more formally this is
the equation for weighted entropy okay
so what you do you simply it's the norm
of d means no divided by what is the
number of a full since here we have
number of no number of a number of no
divided by total number of examples
times the entropy of that di okay so
that's why who you how you take out the
weighted entropy so after taking out the
weighted entropy you subtract the
previous entropy minus the weighted
entropy okay so that's what we are doing
an information gain i really hope that
you understood information gain okay
okay so please im see if on some blocks
if you want uh either you can ask me in
discord so i'll be very happy to help
you in the newer you can find the
discord server in any new era new video
or new era you can find at it and you
can join and there is a lot more of that
you can and also if you want to support
please kindly go to newer youtube
channel
newer youtube channel and please
subscribe that youtube channel okay and
if you can watch the whole tutorial on
new era okay because you are going to
get the uh whole at free over there okay
so now we have seen entropy then we have
seen in formation gain now it's time for
uh talking about uh guinea impurity
guinea impurity okay so this is also the
most famous it's a most dissimilar and
most famous that is used today which is
guinea impurity
gin impurity and it's just equals to
it's very very similar
to entropy
it's a very very similar to entropy let
me
this is i use things very very similar
sign okay
don't comment it like this just i have
just said it like this it's not i using
it's just i have it's very very similar
to entropy so let me give you one
equation uh the equation for calculating
the guinea impurity so i
g and it is not an information gain this
is a sign for a given impurity
of y equals to the
1 minus
i equals to 1 all the way around to the
k and again it is the your y variable
not anything it's the y variable again i
have already seen y equals two and yes
or no mean two or is it also versus
color so unique values in your i
times the probability of y i squared
okay so that's the that's the thing and
again it's if if we take us same
scenarios if we how i'm saying it's if
you take the same scenario as we have
taken entropy some scenarios let's take
an example of scenario number one
scenario number two scenario number one
we are your yes we have let's take a l
let's take you have y to be two class
category where you have the unique value
as a yes or no okay so uh what is the
probability means what is the number of
yes is
0.5 and which is the number of nodes
50 okay 0.5 okay so what will be the
guinea impurity gain impurity will be 1
minus
0.25 is
0.25 because if you square this
because here we are squaring so if you
square this and again you subtract it
again you
subtract it minus
20
uh 0.25
0.25 then you are going to get a 0.5 and
0.5 is maximum and gaining impurity 0.5
is maximum in entropy we have one as a
maximum
if it is this zero point impurity is
zero point five then it sneezes for the
splitting if it is zero then it's not
neat if we can consider that as a leaf
node okay so that's the scenario that we
have already seen in and if it is in in
the case of giving impurity our gain
impurity in this case where you have 50
percent yes then it that that will be
one so we have if you but you may ask
here what is the ad advantage of gain
impurity use rather than using the
entropy so it is an alternative to
entropy just to increase the computation
just to increase to make it fast because
in gain impurity if you have seen we are
just taking a
h
of y equals to the minus the summation i
equals to 1 all the way down to the k p
of y i
minus the log of p of y i so here you
can see we are taking a log and take a
look takes time okay so as an
alternative a researchers comes with a
very easy and fun
under understandable way one minus and
this these are this can be derived these
are derived in information theory okay
but i'm not going to go in information
theory but you can see
uh this is the for
gain impurity and this is most used as
an alternative to guinea impure uh
entropy guinea purity is most yields as
an alternative to entropy okay
so that's the thing and i hope that you
understood guinea impurity also so let's
uh let me make you familiar with the
diagram so here is the diagram let me
make first for um
entropy first here is for entropy so
here we have zero here we have one
so here this is for entropy we are here
maximum is one
and this is for
obviously some something will differ so
but uh the maximum is 0.5 you know
engine impurity so yellow one is guinea
impurity and the white one is entropy
okay white one is entropy so i hope that
you understood the why why i'm saying
but why do you use gain impurity because
because just and because it is more
faster because we are taking log and
that takes time this more faster
than um entropy okay so that's the whole
definition of all decision tree and that
is i'm recording till 51 minutes
and i hope that you understood all of
this i hope that i've written a lot
okay
so uh we have learned a lot and i really
hope that you understood also okay
so now we will
make one a decision tree classifier and
i will show you uh the decision tree
numerically okay how we do uh regression
task and decision trees okay so
first uh let's let's do in a fast way i
i i do have not a lot of time over here
but i will show you this data set so
here is my data set which i'm going to
use okay so first of all what we do we
take out the entropy okay we take out
the entropy we take out the entropy of
this whole data set we take out the
entropy of this data set h of d
oops where is my pen
h of d and simply what what we are doing
here we have two y's so here we are
taking the entropy of our data
distribution d
okay so that that will simply equal to
0.94
as i've told that you have to take out
entropy before splitting okay for
information gain so we take out the
entropy where this of this data set as
you have around
five no five no and nine yes okay
okay so and that way you can take it out
uh if if i want to make i can simply
make like like this
five
by fourteen five by fourteen log uh five
by 14 minus 9 by 14 log of
9 by 14 okay so after you calculate you
will get this okay so but feel free to
collect correct me if
i do anything wrong in calculation okay
feel free to correct me in the
comment box okay in mathematics we do
i'm just doing it faster just we have to
remember the concepts okay so after you
calculate the edge of
entropy of your distribution now what
you do you calculate the information
gain you calculate you calculate the
information gain you calculate the
information
you calculate the information gain okay
how first you calculate the information
gain
for you calculate the information gain
for whether for why with respect to
outlook variable means we have to check
how much information that outlook
variable contains okay so in output in
outlook here we have outlook variable
you can see over here that here we have
outlook variable so let me uh
let me take out so in outlook
if you see the y variable we have
in sunny in sunny we have two yes and
three nos
we have two years and three nos then we
have in outcast we have four yes and
zero nose
okay
then in rainy we have two yes and three
nos
okay so this is their outlook variable
and here you have a two yes and three
knows four yes zero knows two years
three knows and this is for sunny this
is for overcast and this for rainy and
you can see over here okay sunny
overcast and rainy okay so this is this
you can see that if you take out the
entropy of this entropy of
this h
of d2 d2
h of d2 then you will see that this is
equals to zero and you can you can take
this as a leaf node and it does not need
further splitting okay so you can take
this as a leaf node you can take this as
a leaf node because this does not need
further splitting okay now what you do
you take out the entropy of this h of
d1
of y
okay then you take out this h of
d2
d3 y okay so the you have taken this
data set large data set okay taken this
day it is set and it's split you have
taken this feature split it okay so we
have this
before spreading and then you what you
will do you take out the beta entropy
you take out the weighted entropy
weighted entropy weighted entropy
which is equal to 0.69 okay so what you
would for information gain you simply
subtract 0.94 means the previous entropy
minus the bit end drop is 0.69
okay and we entropy i've already shown
you previously okay and you do the same
for
uh temperature you do the same for
temperature very very temperature you
have y
in temperature where you have around in
you have three classes high
mean i think
mil
let me see
hi mild and hot hi hot
mild and cold okay so in what we have
two years and two nos
and here we have in mild we have four
years and two nose
and then in cool we have three yes and
one nose okay then you take out then you
take out like this and then you do for
humidity then then you do for humidity
humidity and then you do for
a windy okay then you do and it's found
that the that the information gain in
over outlook is very high okay so what
you do you take that and you take that
only that
outlook as your root note as your root
node
okay then then you take that outlook as
a root node then you
divide this then you divide this so here
let me go to one of the one of my
favorite
decision tree pdf where i i will just
explain you what this is okay so you
think take this outlook as a root note
then what you do you um divide this you
divide this as as we have divided into
sunny overcast and rainy sunny overcast
and rainy and overcast you can see that
we have entropy equals to zero so it
does not need further splitting so we
can consider that as a yes means we have
four years so we can consider that as a
yes because it's very pure and then its
needs for the splitting and this also
needs for this spitting and then at some
point they are they also become pure
where the entropy equals to zero so or
the given impurity equals to zero then
you consider as a leaf node okay so this
is how we make the decision freeze and
this is how we calculate the information
gain this is how we made our decision
free okay
okay great now i really hope that you
understood decision tree and now it's i
i i also enjoy very much when i make
these kind of tutorials this kind of
tutorials and because it's just amazing
just um helping students to make this uh
understandable things okay okay great
now uh one as we have only talked about
classification so as regression is not
too too much hard also so in regression
let me show you what you are what what
what we do in regression so let me take
one let me go to the cycle learn
decision tree
decision tree
cycle learn i hope that
is stable yeah here it is so it explains
very good it's explains very in in very
good way so let me uh uh make you what
the what do i mean with this so let me
take an example of this a parallel and
petrol width so in the same way here you
what you do your petal length is smaller
than or equals to zero two zero two
point four five then guinea purity is
high then you would split it okay here
the guinea purity equals zero then it
does not need for the splitting but it's
needs for the splitting so it splits
that okay so here it seems to be
overfilling because
if you if you
leave the decision tree to be go as to
ask as much question then it will over
fit then it will overfit so what you do
you either stopped at certain depth you
either stop your decision to add a
certain depth to make it more robust to
make it more robust or you prune your
decision tree by removing some some
branches from here okay and you can see
the same way that we have seen that we
have made the this kind of this kind of
decision boundary decisions uh
hyperplanes okay
great let's see some more
oops
i use brave as my browser but soon we'll
get
but soon we'll try something some please
make sure that you can put your
comment below if i can see okay and
regression what what decision
we can apply in regression also so you
can see over here that here what what we
do let me get back to some good pictures
decision
uh trees
regression regression but i will soon go
to documentation to show you uh more
sophisticated
in a good way okay
so here is my
decision tree regression
and let's take an example of this
as you can see from this also yeah so
here is here we have a good example so
here your predictor here you have a
target variable okay so here you what
you have taken you take an outlook and
then you divide into sunny overcast and
rainy and sunny needs for this fitting
but overcast does not okay so most of
the time you average it and then you
take 46.3 okay and then you split it
again you what you what you do is split
it if
you take out the average again i'm
saying you take out the average okay
that's what you're doing and again if
you if i go further into this it is very
well explained it is very well explained
you can go to this it's very well
explained but yeah it's only for
regression but it's so much of um but
what what we do we simply again the
whole the things are same for attribute
selection measure you simply uh you can
sunny overcast rainy overcast over here
is we have four um
this is your leaf this is your concept
this is a so pure so that's what is
considered as a leaf and then what you
do you take out the average like this
you take out the average and then you
take out the 39.8
46.3 over here after taking on average
then you split your sunny into false or
true then if it is false then your
outward output will be 47.7 and if it is
true then it is 26.5 in the same way you
do the regression okay so i hope that
you understood and you can go again to
understand it more detail so so what you
what you do you take out the hours
played and our average standard
deviation average and hours played and
then you count it and then you simply uh
do some
calculation and that's not too much hard
okay
great so we have seen so far about a
decision trees regression and i really
hope that you understood this also okay
so you can go to this node uh this tree
uh this
website say theresa dot com distribution
we regret reg you will be able to
understand them but it's more important
to understand attribute selection
measure because people usually confuse
us at this and we have taken lots of
examples for this okay okay great so now
what we will do we will
i will show you i will show you some
i will show you the documentation the
implementation
the implementation for decision tree i
will show you the implementation of
digital regressor and residential
classifier okay so that you can on
because it's very important to learn
from implementation okay so i will
explain you in more intuitive way so let
me open my ink to go i hope that i'm not
i'm just using it uh let me see if this
works for not for me or not okay
okay great
let me choose this pen yeah so uh here
you can go to this website this table
dot com and here you will be able to
find more uh you can go to
cyclelearn.org and documentation of this
generic classifier okay so here again it
should what is the criteria to choose
the
attribute here we have guinea and here
we have entropy okay so you guinea is a
default you can choose entropy also okay
the quality of a split supported
criteria is guinea and the entropy is
for the input and the for the
information gain
after splitter splitter means do you
want to choose the best splitter or
random splitter okay best means is which
was the best random is any ran randomly
okay max that this is very important
hyper parameter which you can tune it
using great search cv using grid search
cv or a randomized search randomized
search okay you can tune it okay so
that's what you will do
and what you do you just you just um
make your decision to if you do not make
then it will fed or then the new
decision will overfit okay so the
maximum depth of the tree okay if it is
default as none okay um if you do it
will learn a lot it will make a lot of
decision boundary to learn a lot until
unless it's leaves are pr okay so it
will learn a lot so that's why it will
overfit so this is a very important
hyper parameter then again you have a
minimum sample split means here the
default is two again you have to tune it
again you have to tune it the minimum
number of samples required to split an
internal node okay an internal node is
just uh
that know the minimum number of splits
that require okay this is two but you
need to be uh very cautious under this
okay
then we have minimum sample split then
we have minimum samples leaf
and then the minimum number of samples
required to be at a leaf node okay so
what is the minimum number of a samples
required to be a leaf node again is one
but you can also tune it but it's not
that but it's very uh
good to tune it using great source cv
then we have a minimum weight fraction
leaf then we have what is the max
features means uh the number of features
to consider when looking for the best
plate for a larger number of features
than you can consider as an uh the
default is none but you can use this but
it it it also has some disadvantages
okay
okay then we have a random state control
the randomness of your estimator again
it's you can read some more details on
random state uh max max leaf node the
grow of a tree in a best first fashion
uh it is the default none it's just like
a max leaf node or the minimum purity
decrease the node will will be split if
the split induces
induces a decrease for the impurity
greater than or equals to this value but
i've not used it uh if i say very much
right it's just a limitation that you
can make to prevent overfitting okay i
think this is deprecated then you have a
class weight what is the default is none
always then we have alpha non-negative
value so that that's the basic intuition
okay so we had talked about this and
then you can see some examples and then
there is something called as uh
um let me show you uh you can also use
this as a
understanding residential structure so i
will just show you one example of this
okay so here you can use the graphis
tool here you can use the graphics tool
to plot your decision tree like this
yeah uh you can he he has you three dot
plot tree it is plotting the tree like
this okay you because recently has one
more is advantage it is easy to
interpret okay so that's the basic
intuition behind decision entry okay so
let's go to decision tree regression
okay so let me see where is regression
okay let me see one more
great where is decision tree regression
here it is okay
so in decentralized regression it can be
used for this um uh this is uh for
regression task also so here uh you have
to choose certain criteria the function
to measure here we are not using any
entropy here we are using the quality of
your split you can use mean square error
means how how much it how much it
differs okay so a mean square error
error or mean absolute error or poison
so you can see a frying freedman msc but
most uses mse or ma or rmse okay
a splitter again it's best
again the same thing max step obviously
to control your adapt to prevent
overfitting this is an important hyper
parameter again i'm saying this is a
very very important
vvi
this is also very very important to
attune okay then you have minimum sample
leaf and then you have the same as we
have discussed okay and then you can see
some examples of decision tree like this
how we make and then
there are certain methods like plot or
etc
then you have
uh
some some some examples which you can
see from here and this is usually uh you
can use we will talk about ada boost
also later on okay so you can see some
visualization in this library and this
entry is used to fit this curve with
addition noise or observation and it's
just controlled by the depth of that map
by the max step
and the blue line considers the two and
the max depth of a5 if you take then it
will perform very very well on the
training set but that interesting set of
you do not control your max that okay so
we have talked a lot on decision trees
and i really hope that you understood
decision tree and that okay so in the
next section the reason why i've taken
this too long to make you understand
decision tree because very very
important concept to understand and
and i think it's very very important
okay so you can have a look if you want
onto this notes okay but uh you can you
can ping me on discord or linkedin i
will very happy to give you these notes
if you're not able to write either i
will recommend you to write these things
okay i will i will just
you can ask me to make this all wrong
okay so that's it for this video for
this section so sorry um for this
section and i'm my throat is also so
much paining but yeah that's it for
that's it for this section and in the
next section we will start with ensembl
learning and again
then we will go to unsupervised learning
then we'll talk a little bit about
neural networks and then we will end up
this course and you will be having
enough understanding of machine learning
to get started making projects in
machine learning and getting a job or an
internship but you have to lot of
practice okay so uh you can do that okay
great so thank you for this seeing this
section and again if you have any kind
of question you can ask me to the new
era be sure to subscribe if you wanted
to support this content
okay so let's meet at the next section
till then bye bye okay so now we'll talk
about example learning one of my
favorite topic to teach and to use in my
professional experience
so
why why i think ensemble learning is one
of the
best for cargo competitions for cargo
competitions and sample learning
methods or techniques are most popular
99
of the kaggle winners uses some kind of
ensemble learning techniques so that's
why uh i think that ensemble learning is
a must-know technique it does not
involve a lot of mathematics but it do
involves only techniques concepts and a
little bit more uh maths okay but in
decision tree we involve some
mathematics but here we do not end a lot
of mathematics we require a little bit
of mathematics but there are a lot of
techniques and concepts that we need and
approaches that a particular kaggle
governor's thieves okay so
it's very um we will give david and
symbol learning covering the four
three techniques i think the three
techniques of ensemble learning the
first technique will be a bagging which
we'll talk about um not in it will will
be in a separate section sub sections
okay so this is our main section and in
a separate subsection we will talk about
bagging
then we will talk about
boosting
then we will talk about stacking okay so
these are the three techniques that we
will talk about in ensembl learning and
also we will see the implementation of
each one of them and it and i will also
show you some of the kaggle competition
winners approach or we will make one
model
seeing the changes for changes they uh
bring into your system how do your model
accuracy increases okay okay so great
but before that let's a little bit uh
let me just forget about dominant sample
learning let me recall use some concept
which is high variance uh concept okay
so
high variance and high bias concept so
it
it should make sense to you so let's
recall in high variance we have uh
overfitting model we have our
overfitting model if i'm if i'm correct
in high variance we have our overfitting
model and in high bias we have our under
fitting model okay so our models should
be low bias
and low variance
low variance model if you have a high
variance if you have a high variance
then you have then your model is
overfitting if you have a
high bias then your model is under
fitting and uh that's that's what the
recollection that that we need for this
ensemble learning just to make sure that
that we are in the same path okay
okay so let's start with an a simple
example of um of a small example okay
so if we have played some quiz okay if
you have played some quiz let's take an
example that we have played some quiz of
uh maybe in kahoot or anything any kind
of quiz or if you are in competition you
have played some quiz so it's a maximum
percent a maximum percentage that the
let's take an example that we have some
question let's we have some question we
have some question here and we have some
option which is a
b and c okay so let's let's take an
example that the particular that the
majority let's take an example a is a
correct answer so
it is it is very obvious that majority
of the students will go with a and if
the majority is on a then is likely to
be a be the correct answer and it's
actually the correct answer okay so it's
like whatever the majority will say we
will go with that okay here majority is
saying a and in this case is a correct
answer and if you think about the
majority is more accurate than one
majority is more accurate than one and
in some exceptional conditions that can
be different but in 99
the majority will win okay majority will
win
if you have seen some quiz okay so if
you see that the option has got the
highest majority and what also into that
then you can think that is the correct
answer so in the same way ensemble
learning works in ensemble learning is a
example of models is ensemble of models
okay
so let's take one more example to get
more feel let's take an example that
some election is happening some election
is happening some election is happening
and in that election and that election
uh let's take an example that why we do
not take only one person vote and select
any prime minister or president why we
take the majority the majority of votes
which will go on to that party that will
win okay so the majority will make a
right decision okay we'll we will uh
will make a right decision in most cases
okay so that's what the ensemble
learning also says and semi-learning has
ensemble of models so let's uh let me
say let me tell you um
what what we do in symbol learning we
have a model one
model two all the way down to the more
okay okay so let me make you make this
that it is visible yeah okay so you have
these kind of models and you train your
model you train your model you train
your model onto your data okay you train
your model onto your data and you can
you take predictions from each of the
model so let's take an example that
you're trying you are making a
diabetes prediction system diabetes
projection system so your output will be
either zero means non-diabetes or one
okay so let's take an example that model
number one says it's uh it's a zero
model number two say it's a zero model
number three says zero model of a force
is a one and model number five says is
zero so the the then what what we have a
one more model a big model which which
what it will do it will check the
majority of votes and here the majority
is zero and only one has given one and
the majority of zero so we will give our
prediction as a zero okay so we will see
how it is trained later on but here what
the actual thing is what is happening we
train our model and each model is giving
predictions and in these predictions we
are taking into classification we are
taking in class classification we are
taking majority of votes means majority
means m1 is saying is zero and two is
saying zero the frequency of zero is
more than the frequency of one okay so
that's why our final prediction which is
y hat is equals to zero
okay and it's more it will be it will be
high chance that if one model predicts
if one model predicts it's a one or zero
uh and the ensemble of a model predicts
a zero then they are more accurate
rather than this okay so that's the um
that's the basic overview of ensembl
learning and you may think here use in
classification we choose the majority of
votes but what about regression what
about regression
what about regression problems in
regression problems what we do we take
out the mean
or a median uh um
of
out outputted from each model so let's
take an example that your model m1 given
some prediction which is regression
value 2.4 model 2 given 2.6 model 3
given 2.5 so what you do the final
prediction will be the average of these
outputs the average or mean or a median
of these outputs okay so that's what
that's how we do in regression
we do not take the majority we take the
mean or the median of the output from
the base models and these are called the
base models over here okay so these are
called the
base
models and then symbol
okay so don't be confused what is base
model base motors are the ensemble of
models that are being trained
uh and
okay so that's that's the basic
intuition behind our ensemble learning
and i really hope that you understood
ensemble learning and that okay so um
just want to make sure that what how we
train uh what are the some of the
techniques used in
this um used in
bagging what means what are the
techniques using assemble learning so we
have a techniques like bagging then we
have a boosting then we have a stacking
okay
these are and one one more which is
cascading which is which which you can
learn which is not yet in the industry
yet but yeah one was just gas scanning
which we will see if we want otherwise
it's not necessary okay so in bagging we
will see one algorithm which is a random
forest which is which is something
called as a random forest okay
which is just an ensemble of a decision
trees and then in boosting we will more
probably focus on um
we will in boosting we'll more prone to
focus on gradient boosting we will more
prone to focus on
gradient boosting
and we will focus on adaptive boosting
which is just a advanced uh version of
gradient boosting we will focus on
adaptive boosting then we will see one
winner which is xg boost okay so we will
see these algorithms or these techniques
in this boosting then in stacking we
will see amal extend library how we do
this stacking and what's the intuitive
understanding and you can see there no
money any kind of math this is only the
concepts okay so that's how
that's what we are going to see and the
study motivation for this for ensembl
learning why do we study ensembl
learning has a great reason behind them
the reason being why do we study this is
the great question to ask whenever you
do any kind of thing why let me use this
good color why do we study i think that
is not visible in most of the cases let
me stick to white okay so why do we
study
and we study this ensemble learning the
reason being is most of the cargo
competitions
most of the gaggle competition winners
most of the kaggle competition winners
competition winners
uses some kind of ensemble learning
either they use bagging either they use
boosting either they use stacking either
they use cascading they use some kind of
ensemble learning techniques if it is a
machine learning problem if it is a
machine learning problem ml problem okay
okay just think that machine learning
has also a power okay
so but there is a difference in in
internet companies like amazon google
they also uses these algorithms xgboost
adaboost gradient boosting then we have
a random forest in their
own uh
products of import production okay so um
cora uses random forest to uh for
quotient matching okay so they they also
use machine learning these kind of
algorithm and these are very very
powerful algorithm a very powerful
algorithm which is often used in
industry also which is often used in
many kind of kaggle competitions and
around
99 of the kaggle competition winners are
uses this kind of um
any kind of ensemble learning either if
it is a machine learning problem in deep
learning problem you obviously go with
it if it is image problem you will go
with cnn if it is a text
text you will go with some word
embeddings and then you can use any
other techniques and you can use r and n
so it depends so you can use any of the
technique if you want but in most of the
competition in the past we have seen
that they are the winners of the user
okay so you can see the case studies if
you want in detail
okay great so we have talked about
ensembl learning and in this section and
now we will start a sub section which is
bagging okay we will start a sub section
which is bagging which we will dip dive
into the bagging okay so it's also
called the bootstrap aggregation or
bootstrap aggregated okay so we will see
uh late just one second okay so just to
recall and sample learning
is a b is an example of base model it
can be logistically version it can be
nine based it can be supported with the
machine okay it's a classification
algorithm whatever the majority of votes
will be it will take the majority of
votes and then gives you a y hat okay so
that's how it works okay so um let's
let's and in regression we take out the
mean or median of your values
great
now we'll start a sub section now we
will start a sub section which is
something called as bagging
subsection which is called as bagging
okay so in bagging
so in bagging uh it's again ensemble
learning technique and sometimes it's
called bootstrap aggregation and from
bootstrap we deserve we derive the word
which is backing like this
bootstrap
bootstrap
aggregation agreement
okay i think i'm my spinning is little
bit wrong but uh just bear with me bad
game okay so that's what the from the
derived world from bootstrap aggregation
justin shaw okay okay great so
it's a statistics term if you've heard
about bootstrap
aggregation means it's a it's a
statistics term if you can relate with
your statistics and probability classes
a statistics term so let's see the
geometric intuition okay let's see the
basic overview or intuition behind
bagging intuition behind
bagging
intuition behind bagging so what we do
in bagging so let's take an example that
you have a data set that we have a data
set d okay you have a training data
which is d
so you have a data so you have a data
like this
and what you have done you divided your
data 80 percent for training and 20
for testing okay so now what you do
that's just to make sure that you are on
the same page on the dividation of your
data also okay so you take your training
data you trade your training data and
your data is just um you take your
training data like this and it's for
your training it's a supervised learning
algorithm so um
you have x i and y i so you have your
in x i
with your label by i for all i
one i equals to one all the way down to
the m and m r is the length of your
training examples okay so this is your
data this is your training data this is
your training data now what you do you
sample
some points let's take this sample k
point or i uh let's see an example that
you sample k points from this data set
you sample
you sample
k points
with the resp replacement with the
replacement you sample k points with
displacement from this data and you feed
this to this model which is uh let's uh
now you got d
one which is d1 okay so you have sampled
the subsystem sub subset of a data
from this large data set okay sample k
points you sample k points and now what
you do you train your model using this
subset of a data you train your model
using this subset of the data and now
you've got your model as a m1 okay this
is your m1 mark okay but you may think
here you just can you repeat it again
it's all goes uh all gone above your
head no worries again i'm explaining
it's usually gone okay so what you do
so i'm highlighting i in
white so what you do you take your
training data which is the which is a
supervised running problem where you
have a labels now you take out the
samples with the replacement samples
with a replacement and what do i mean by
sample with a replacement i will talk
about just after i make another sample
okay so
as of now just just understand we take
out some sample with a replacement
around the k points we sample k points
or m points and um
sam we sample some points um
or we take out a sample of a data from
this let's take an example this this
amount of data from this uh this amount
of data which any random data means and
we have this is a hybrid parameter we
have to choose the number of samples
from this data and then we and then we
call it as a d-1 okay then we feed to
the model means we train our model onto
this data okay then what we do we again
take out the sample again take out the
sample
again take out the sample k points with
the replacement sample k points with
replacement and what do i mean
if your data is here if your data is
here means if your data
is here then it can be also here then it
can be also here it is it is not
necessary that your data should be
different
it can be same it is some data can be
same here and here also okay so that's
the sampling with replacement okay now
your samples again that random data and
it's not necessary that your data should
be different from the d1 it can some
data points can be included okay so you
again sample k points and the and here
you have a sample of a data from the
large data and then you train your model
onto this data
m2
okay you train your model onto this m2
now again what you do you take out the
sample you take out the sample
you take out the sample
k points
you do it for your number of um base
models means
number of times if this this is also
have a parameter okay how much you want
to sample until you have your data
points
till
k okay till k
till k dash okay and then you train your
model till am okay and then what you do
you have your k models now you aggregate
this into a large model you aggregate
this into a large model
okay
and large m okay and in case of
classification the majority of votes the
majority of votes will go uh as let's
take an example of ensemble learning
that we have seen that let's take an
example of diabetes and prediction okay
so if m1 gives 0 m2 gives 0 and m3 gives
0 and m4 gives less than level 1. so the
majority is 0. so the majority of votes
will lead to the final prediction by
okay in case of classification we think
of the majority in case of regression we
take out the mean or a median okay so
that's the basic intuition behind and
bagging and i really hope that you
understood okay
so let me explain it again those who
have not understood please fast this
video if you can because many students
are still here that are not under that
may not understand this i cannot do uh
recapitulate or give a summary of this
okay
great so here what we do we have a large
training data set which is d now what we
do
we sample our data sample k points from
that data we sample k points from the
large training data and let's say any
sample sample sample of a data and then
we train our model on these sample which
is m1 it can be largest regression okay
now we sample again k points with
replacement and also it is with a
replacement so it is not necessary that
your data should be different from the
d1 it can be same or it can be some data
points can be same and then you again
train so
let's say example you train support with
the machine let's take example you're
saying uh nine days okay so you train
and the majority of votes is like
ensemble learning okay so that's what
your backing is intuitively and you can
see that we are not involving any
mathematics yeah this is just a bunch of
concepts okay so um just i will make
sure that
you all are on the same page that what
it helps
it is great great question it helps you
in reducing the variance
bagging let let me write
bagging
bagging helps you
bagging
helps you
in reducing the variance
it's we will discuss uh 10 minutes onto
this also okay
yeah okay so bagging helps in reducing
the variance okay but before that there
is one term that i want to highlight
over here that
here we have our all base models these
are our base models m1 m2 and all of
them are bmk these are our base models
these base models are usually
high variance model
these are usually high variance
with a low bias model with low bias
model and what do i mean by this
it is usually we do not do a lot of fine
tuning we do not do a lot of fine tuning
so that's why it is just overfitting and
we had done overfilling so that's why
just go down to any data so that's why
it is not under filling okay so we have
our the base models are high variance
and low bias model so we do not do lots
of fine tuning just we do a simple uh
list in random form which just
initialized with it with no no number of
depth okay it can go as much as they can
so it is overwhelming okay so here we
have high variance model and low bias so
what it helps
what it helps backing helps in reducing
your variance how it helps in reducing
your variance from making your model
more robust okay
this is just um what it does is combines
them
so you have a low bias
low bias
high variance model now if you combine
them if you combine the majority of
votes then obviously we'll get a good
amount of good
good
output or a
correct output okay so you combine the
models you combine these models
you combine base models
and then you get
you then then you get low bias
and low variance problem
low variance
okay
this is what you get this is what you
get after doing backing and this helps
this helps in reducing your variance and
this is very good and this is very good
okay
so there is some uh there is some i want
to highlight over here
that here we are doing the
row sampling so just understand that
this is a point that bagging helps in
reducing your variance because usually
your base learners or base models have
high variance and low bias the bias and
variance of that trade-off that is high
variance and low bias models so what you
do you combine them uh combined based
models with a lot into a large model and
then you get a low bias and no variance
models
low bias and no variance m which is a
large model okay so that's the that's
the different uh now i think that you've
understood why we call it as it reduces
variance okay so here
okay so here um
what how we sample our data how we
sample our data okay how we sample this
is a great uh topic to talk on how we
sample our data
okay so here we are doing a row sampling
we are doing row sampling we are not
doing column sampling we are doing a row
sampling so let me write it down
while sampling while sampling our data
from the large distribution of our data
so let's take an example this is my
large data in screening data now while
sampling what we do we have this we'll
do the row sampling we do the
row sampling
row sampling
while sampling our data okay so let's
take an example that we have
d columns d columns
and m
are rows okay so we have this
we have b columns and we have ambrose
okay so we sample only rows and backing
we sample only rows in backing okay so
it can be like it can it can be go to d1
okay only those and backing
okay so that's what we do in uh like a
row sampling okay so we'll see in random
forest we also do the column sampling
plus column sampling okay and random
forest we do this we do this but in
bagging we do not do the column sampling
we only do the row sampling so i hope
that you understood the bagging also
okay it's also got the bootstrap
aggregation first your bootstrap and
then you aggregate your base models okay
so that's why the name it has a
bootstrap aggregation okay so just to
make sure that you all understood so i'm
just recapitulating the sub section as
you can reverse the video to know about
ensembl learning because i don't want to
just spend my time under that okay
so here um just to just want to make
sure that here you have your training
data here let me see here
here you have a training data which is
you have a training data and then what
you have done you take out the sample
endpoints where the replacement okay
into your data subset of the data and
then you train your model m1 which is
your base model it can register linear
okay then you again sample k points and
d2 then you again put a new model onto
these subset of a data you do for k you
do for k models or k subsets and then
you combine the majority of votes
majority of what will lead to
classification and and if you use this
regression problem we take out a mean or
median of a most output from the model
space models okay so that's the
intuition behind bagging and it helps in
reducing your variance it helps and
reducing your variance because your base
models are usually high variance and low
bias model so it combines the base
models to bring up low bias and low
variance model that's actually good okay
so and and in bagging we do the row
sampling we do the row sampling means we
we have a d features and we have m
column and rows so we do sample of our m
not d okay so we take whole column we
take all the columns okay but we make
subset of a rows for training okay so
that's what we do in uh bagging and i
really hope that you understood this
bagging technique now it's time for
learning well one algorithm would be one
good algorithm one powerful one kaggle
binning algorithm one production level
algorithm which is random forest
okay why i think random forest is a very
very powerful algorithm to work on is a
very very powerful algorithm to work on
let me write a random
random forests
okay
random forest it's a bargaining
algorithm it's a bagging technique or
you can call bagging algorithm okay so
why do i call this uh very powerful
because in also my professional
experience i think that i have also used
a random course a lot and it's it seems
like it's this very powerful algorithm
whether you want to win a card
competitions and which is a machine
learning problem or you wanted to make a
production level machine learning okay
so random forest usually used by quora
then we have google amazon they they all
use this random forest but it has some a
basic intuition a basic concept that
instructors are not teaching and it's
very very important okay so first of all
what we do in random forest so let's
recall our decision trees let's recall
our decision trees into this now our
now our decision tree will play a role
now here we have a decision tree so
let's recall our decision tree so what
we are doing in this entry uh we are
doing an it is a simple it's makes a
decision and splits your node okay so
what you're doing it's a simple if and a
nested if and else statements nested if
and else statements nested if an else
statement so we take if the sepal length
is smaller than parallel and then you
take a y equals to one like this okay
which is a nested if and l statements
just ask a question
is just ask a question is just ask a
question to the null and then splits the
note and then it splits the note okay so
you can the reverse stuff for the
section of decision tree we have some
attribute selection measure like entropy
then we have uh information gain in
formation gain then we have a guinea
impurity which we have seen in detail in
one hour of section of decision tree and
i hope that you enjoyed that also okay
so that's the decision tree
okay so what is random forest random
forest
random
forest
is a combination of
decision trees bt plus
bagging plus
bagging plus
feature bagging plus feature bagging or
we call it as a column sampling column
sampling okay so what do i mean with
this let's understand this is step by
step so it's it makes sense to you also
okay so what we do in random products we
have our decision trees okay so you know
about different trees so we have uh
there's a 500 decision tree okay
so random forest is an assembled
learning algorithm so we have a lot of
base models means decision trees lots of
base models so here we have a large
distribution of a data okay and here we
sample our data d1 and we train a
decision tree onto this data okay
decision tree then we sample the two
with the replacement then we train our
decision tree onto this subset okay so
you're not using different algorithm you
are using only decision trees okay with
the row sampling with bagging here we
are doing bagging means the sample
sampling with replacement which here we
are doing a row sampling okay plus
in bagging you're doing a row sampling
row sampling and aggregating your model
means whatever the majority of votes you
will aggregate your model okay so you're
doing the row sampling plus the column
sampling also okay so here and this uh
in a bagging we have only doing the row
sampling we are taking whole column
whole features but you are not but you
are only taking the rows okay as a
subset but here we are taking we are
doing also the column sampling okay so
let's learn to understand what do i mean
by column sampling or feature bagging
okay
so the column sampling means column
sampling means that you have this your
data you have this your data like this
you have this your data okay now you
have
d features you have your leaf features
d features d columns like a b c d
and you have
ambrose amaros okay we have ambrose okay
so what you do you for replacement you
take any rows you sports for sampling
you take your rows
random rows let's take an example you
took this row this row okay this row and
and you took a
and b as your column and then you train
onto this you are not taking full
columns or features you have taken this
a and b and in their frame and then the
next you t you took c
and d okay you took c
and d
okay and then you train with one one row
just an example you join this entry so
they're different they are different and
if they are different it's much higher
chance that your model will be very very
good okay ensemble learning if your
model is different then this is then
it's very very good okay okay great so
that's the that's the random forest okay
so we have a large number of
decision-free maintenance base learners
as a base learners that are trained
using a bagging technique means it's
sampling rules with row sampling plus
column sampling okay with a row sampling
plus column sampling which is column
sampling also called the feature bagging
okay between different distributors and
then you in majority of boats and and
then classification you take them
authority or in regression you take the
mean or a median of the outputs from the
base model okay so that's what you do in
this so that's what you do in
uh this car
a random forest and i hope that you
understood okay so uh let's understand
it uh more intuitively uh that there is
something called as oob
it is something called as
o o b
out of bad points outer bag and this is
called in that point so it's uh
something called as outer back point so
let me not recall this concept just now
so let's let's take an example let's
take an example
that what you have done you have this dn
you have this uh you have this large
blouse training set set which is b okay
which is d okay so what you do
let's see an example that you've taken
this sample of a data as a b1 and the
rest of the data is called the outer
back points it's called the outer back
points so what you do you subtract
means the train data minus the d i and i
is the sample so these are called the
left points after the sampling which is
outer bag
points okay out of bag
out of bag
points okay and this this this can be
used for cross validation for evaluating
your model okay so if you set omc cycle
learn there is a very good library which
is cycle learn if you set ob score to ob
score to true
if you said ob score to true then it
will uh give you the ob score also okay
so that's the basic or
out of bag um
points and i hope that you understood um
out of ob uh
points okay
so now let's uh let's recapitulate our
bagging and a random forest what we have
seen in random forest and diamond okay
so
in bagging we have seen that we have our
data we have our data d we have our data
d okay what you do you take out a sample
you sample with a replacement d1 okay
then you train your model under this
subset m1 then you're into d2 little
trading water onto d2 and what you're
doing you're doing is sampling with row
sampling plus all i'm sampling with the
replacement okay and d3
d3 then you getting your model b3
getting your model m2 m3 okay so the
majority of vote majority will go and a
large model means you just aggregate
your model aggregate your model and then
you get your final prediction which is
why
okay this is the whole pipeline so in
in bagging you want to do the row
sampling and random forest you will you
do with column sampling as well as you
only take decision trees as your base
models okay so in bagging into different
different kind of models by the decision
tree and random forest to take your uh
decision tree as your base model and
distill through our train or different
different data okay so that's the basic
uh intuition behind the random forest
and i hope that you understood also
about what is com column sampling or
watch it what is feature bagging okay
and
obviously this also helps in reducing
your uh variance as it is a bagging
technique so obviously it will help you
to reduce your variance okay so that's
the basic intuition behind branham
forest so let's see the run time uh
train train and run time complexity of
this because if you if it is very uh uh
it's very required to trade talk about
train and run complexity of this random
forest okay so in decision trees
in decision trees uh the train
complexity that
the train complexity in decision trees
the train complexity let me write in dt
the train complexity is order of n log m
n log n times d okay times three
times uh yeah so it is a in distance we
have n log n so in random forest we have
d number of decision trees signed k
number of samples okay number of models
so that's the that's your model that's
the uh
train and run time control train uh
training complexity of your random
forest and the decision tree is just a
analog n okay so that's the and d here
is the number of k is the number of the
models okay so uh it it makes sense also
if you take an example of your d as a
large data set okay let's take an
example that you have a d okay now you
take out a sample with a replacement
with row sampling plus column sampling
with like feature packing okay you take
out a subset and then you train your
model like m1 then you again do the d2
then you take out m2 so here the all the
way down to the mk here you have a k
models and then you have a d uh d
decision trees okay so and also this is
a trained uh
trivially paralyzed it's a trivially
paralyzed what do i mean you can train
this model onto parallely okay you can
train the model you cannot you you can
train this parallelly okay you can take
out a subset you train d1 parallely d2
parallely d3 parallely so this is a
trivially
paralyzed
parallelized parallelized i think i'm
pronouncing this correct okay this is a
trivially parallelized you can do
trivially parallelized also okay so
that's the decision i'm sorry i'll train
around turn around and complexity of
random forest and i hope that we have
talked a lot in short span of time and i
hope that you're enjoying this video war
section also and and i hope that you are
enjoying a lot okay
so there is one more concept that i will
um talk on and end this video which is
sort of this section which is extremely
a
randomized trees okay
extremely a randomized tree so what we
do with extremely randomized trees is
very become popular after the cycle and
releases its uh this api which is
something called as extremely
extremely
randomized
randomized
trees okay
trees so what is this this is in random
forest we are doing a column sampling
plus row sampling with bagging okay with
bootstrap aggregation with bootstrap
aggregation which is bagging okay so in
uh run random forest and rf we are doing
like this so in extreme trees uh
in extreme trees we try out the possible
values of um
fi to determine the threshold means the
decision trees and decision trees let's
take an example that in decision trees
we uh we have we have some epsilon and
its checks is greater than ordinals like
that for identifying in uh
decision tree we are trying out every
value and that is that is time that is
that is taking time that is taking time
okay so uh what we can do instead of
trying out every values we sample we
sample some subset of columns some
subset of rows with some supplies of
rows and check with that and
choose the pressure according to that
because
in random forest we have a lot of
decision trees and identifying the
threshold is a key over there okay so if
you if you take all possible values then
and that will be computationally time
complex time taking so what you do you
try out the sample of values from that
whole
column okay then you'll try and that's
called the extremely
randomized trees okay
so that's what i'm going to talk about
extremely randomized trees just to make
sure that we are on the same place that
what what we were doing in random forest
we have a lot we have decision trees we
have column and row sampling okay
okay and that reduces the variance okay
so here um instead in random form we are
trying out every in
indianapolis and we are trying out every
possible values and we are for for that
epsilon so for a not for it's trying to
time taking so what we do we take out
the sample of values from that column
and as a as a sample and then we check
that for that epsilon 2 for getting that
epsilon okay so if you're literally
getting confused don't worry it's not a
popular popular algorithm which is
extremely randomized classifier or
regressor it is not a popular algorithm
the reason being
if you take a sample there is a lot more
less chance that your moral is good
as compared to random forest so we will
rarely use i rarely use this extremely
randomized foreign
popular algorithm okay so we have talked
a lot i think that we have talked a lot
on to this now you hope that you
understood bagging
then we have understood random forest
then we have understood some decisions
we and then we have understood that in
symbol learning now we have talked about
packing okay now in the next section
subsection um
point a point two we will talk about uh
boosting okay and boosting we'll talk
about gradient adaptive xg okay so we
will talk about three algorithms here we
have talked about the random forest and
extremely randomized uh trees so in
there we'll talk about three which is
gradient adaptive and xg boost and a
gradient boosting is also called
g
b
d
t g b d p is gradient boosting precision
trees because they also use decision
tree as their base models one little
century as a base models but what are
the some of the disadvantages of random
forest
the some of the disadvantages of random
forest that it is very you it is very it
is very bad choice to use to use a
random forest or decision trees on large
data set okay if you don't because it's
very time complexive train taking okay
don't use that kind of but you can
obviously try it out
at least okay you can see some more
assumption on the internet for this okay
great so now we have talked about
everything now it's time for getting
into the implementation part of random
forests okay we will talk about random
forest and decision trees okay either
way i think that we have talked about
decision trees so we'll talk about a
random forest okay on cycle learn a a
library okay so let's uh let's see the
implementation
okay so i'm on my grave okay so here i
will write i started using brave in some
uh just uh just a days ago just some
some days ago so here what i will what i
will write i will write a random forest
random forest
cycle
okay
and we will see one project we will see
one project uh which will be doing all
of this implementation with grids or cv
fine tuning the hyper parameters okay so
let's uh let's deep dive into this let's
understand this concept
let's see the implementation a very
finest explanation of a random forest
right here so let me take out my ink to
go again because i it's my 212 days left
that
license expires okay
so here i'm i will take my pen i will
take medium i will take a good red color
yeah so you can go to this api which is
sk learn and sample you can also import
by just calling uh from sklearn from
sklearn dot ensemble from sklearn dot
ensemble you can go with this and then
you can uh use this api so the first um
you will now now you can use the random
forex classifier this is the first
parameter
is n estimators the first parameter is n
estimators and estimators is the
number of decision trees that you want
okay
like then what is the number of base
models that you want what is the number
of base models that you want so you have
this data and you take this sample this
data so what is the number of so you so
here you should take 100 decision tree
as a default okay
but also this is a very important type
of parameter so you fine tune it using a
grid search cv
or randomized search
okay we will see implementation of these
two
okay so you can use this is the number
of decision trees
after you have what is the criteria what
is the criteria to use in a decision
tree what is the attribute selection
criteria so the default is given
impurity as the best impurity either you
can use the entropy but this computation
little bit expensive means a time time
taking okay you can the default is
guinea impurity
is now uh the what is the number of
depth of your tree the minimum number of
a sample required to split and
sorry the maximum depth of the tree to
stop okay
then the nodes will expand means if it
is none then it will ah it it has a high
chance that it will overfill okay now it
is also hypergrammar minimum sample is
split with number of samples required to
split an internal node means
what is the minimum number of samples to
split okay samples means what is the
number of data points okay
then you have let me delete this again
then you have uh oops
here's my pen then you have a minimum
sample of leaf which is which we have
already seen max features means what is
that you want
auto or a square root or log you can
read the documentation impurity then
bootstrap bootstrap obviously equals to
true it involves bagging where the row
sampling with the column sampling ob
score which is out of back data points
which is out of the bag after sampling
okay which is for n jobs if you take
this n drops equals to minus one if you
take this and jobs equals to minus one
then it will obviously understand your
course and then it will run parallely
okay it will run results in parallel it
is fast if you take adjobs equals to
minus one usually people take okay but
it's i think it's it's for printing out
something texts okay now um you can see
the class page let me see i've already
also forgotten about class weight let me
see class weight
is
yeah verbosity when filling and
predicting class weight is just the
weight associated with the class okay so
it is obviously if the default is a none
but you can see how it is calculated
okay it's not max samples if bootstrap
equals to what is the number of a max
sample if you set it in none then the
default is the x dot shape 0 the number
of the samples so you can set some max
samples okay so you have some attributes
base estimator the child template used
to create the collection of finished sub
estimators then you have a number of
classes here number of features the
number of uh number of outputs when if
it is performed the feature importance
it is also you can use feature
importance uh this attribute to uh
understand what is the number of feature
means what is the importance of your
each feature in your model is columns ob
score if it's obviously it will give you
the in the float value okay so that's
the decision tree uh sorry random forest
and you can see more about this
into uh here and you can really read
about attributes and this is how the
this is how the
featured importance looks like means you
can also plot it like this you can also
plot it to so which feature and you can
use it for feature selection okay great
let's see the second one is a random
forest regressor
let me see yeah that i am under the same
path okay so let's see again it's very
similar to classifier it's very similar
to classifier here
here we have mst mirror which is number
let me oops i don't know why it is
very here we have number of estimators
criteria to be msc rms mae okay max step
max step minimum sample with bootstrap
equals to true obviously take there take
this okay ob score equals to false you
get big yes or no okay somewhat default
to get it is quite similar to that and
max sample is none and it sticks a
default as x dot
so i don't know i don't know why why it
happened
max that is x dot shape the shape of
your
okay of your samples okay so that's the
basic intuition behind this and max the
max sample is also one hypergrammar
great so we have talked about a lot
about bagging and we have spent one hour
on to this now you can see some more
attributes you can see some more
attributes over here to understand it
much better so let me show you uh
one uh one diagram that i found very
interesting okay so you can see uh some
examples using a random foreign
regressor uh using a stacking so you
will also see the stacking okay stacking
is also a very good uh technique as a
kaggle winner winning winning technique
to use okay but um
here you are here you can see that we
only have mse we don't have rmse okay so
rmse is not default you have to make
your own function for our messy just
squaring the root your mse okay but you
cannot use if you want here your rmse
okay you have to make your own you have
to make your own i don't know why it is
not running well i have to complain this
okay i think this okay so for rmse
you have to make your own okay
but here you cannot use with this
library either you can make a full
request or on cycle or an atm okay just
adding your own rmse okay great so now
we have seen these algorithms now we
have seen yes i'm going to do it
so now we have stream extremely random
there is one more left which is
extremely randomized trees it just all
got extremely
randomized
classifiers
that's cycler it's obviously in cyclone
because it's a new release of cyclone
let's see this sound let me open it
again integral it's very important now
so here again we have mst meters
criteria max depth is just the same and
then we have bootstrap equals to false
your bootstrap equals to false it should
be true you can make this as a true okay
then we have some more uh auto square
etcetera you can it's just the same as
that but there is some difference that
is that that i've just told you that
we choose randomly but what we do we
choose a randomly sorry a sample and
then we take out the sample epsilon okay
so that's what we do in a random forest
or extremely randomized classifier so
let's see for regressor and aggressor is
just the same i think that i'm not
correct over here okay
let's use the grasher and here the same
thing over as we have seen and here
bootstrap equals to false your end jobs
is obvious that you are understood to
run trivially paralyzed to create that
option
okay great so now we have seen about a
random forest and i hope that you
understood everything here okay so now
in the next sub section we will talk
about boosting now i hope that you will
understand that also okay so let's wait
at the next section till then bye bye
okay so now we will talk about
another ensemble technique which is
boosting okay so
boosting is one of the again one of the
most popular as packing that we have
already talked about bagging you just
have to recalculate something about
bagging that is necessary okay so we
have talked about bagging and now we
will talk about boosting which is one of
the technique of ensemble learning and i
really hope that you will enjoy this
section and in boosting we will talk
about
in boosting we'll talk about something
called as a gradient boosting
and gradient boosting
and then i will just give you a
geometric intuition or i will just show
you the implementation of
adaptive boosting which is often called
as arab boost
okay
then i will talk about extreme boosting
x g boost okay so these three algorithms
means xd boost works best in some cases
xd boost works best okay so uh gradient
[ __ ] boosting also works best but i
am i it is also works best so we will
see these three okay so
let's start with this tutorial but
before that um i i just want to tell you
that you can do the problem set which is
on github and you can subscribe the
youtube channel just by going to the
https https
on youtube.comera
because this highly motivates me to make
content like this for you all for
absolutely free okay so you can go to
this new era to subscribe this youtube
channel with 500 uh just just i have a
500 subscribers soon putting a deep
learning tutorial there's announcements
coming up soon putting a deep learning
tutorial soon okay so let's start with
this tutorial
and uh okay so first of all what is
bagging
what is bagging that we have already
talked about you can re-wash that the
bagging section if you want
maybe in a fast way so bagging
and bagging we have low bias model we
have low bias model and high variance uh
high variance models okay so our base
models usually have low bias
and high variance
low bias and high variance means our
base models usually have this low bias
and high variance and using bagging we
reduce
this we reduce high variance we reduce
this variance okay so our output will be
after applying bagging we have our low
bias and low variance model low bias and
low variance model okay so what what we
were doing in bagging we we are just
simply
doing the column sampling as well as the
row sampling means we are doing the
column sampling as well as the row
sampling in case of random forest but
it's just just take an example of random
forest and then we do the aggregation
aggregation
okay so that's what we are doing and
let's see um let's see uh just just uh
just a recap what we do we have this
large data set we have this large data
set d n
and then what we do we simply divide
this data set into subset of the data uh
with the replacement so i hope that you
remember what is breadth replacement
that the data which is here the data
points which is here and it needs to be
needs not to be different here it can be
same in the second data set also okay so
you sample them points then you again
sample endpoints with replacement then
you sample endpoints uh so you take in
three subsets of your data and then you
train your model
train your model onto this data like m1
onto this data maybe logistic regression
maybe linear regression or maybe support
vector machine so you have three models
and then if it is a classification
problem you simply uh take the majority
of votes majority of words that this
particular example is of a particular
class or if it is a regression problem
then you do the average or me or you
take out the mean or a median okay
in case of regression so that's what we
are doing and in random forest we this
is these these are called our base
models and in random forest we have our
base models as a decision trees we have
as a decision trees okay so the this
usually helps in reducing your bias and
reducing your bias okay so that's that's
the bagging so let's see what what we
have in uh boosting boosting is just
opposite in case of bias and variance
tradeoff
so just just now i think that you know
why we have learned bias and variance a
lot okay so in boosting we have low
variance in the in in this case we have
high variance but we have a low variance
high bias model here we our model is
under fitting we have high bias model
okay so it is not performing well on the
training set okay so here we have a high
bias model and then what we do we
additively combine
additively
additively
combined what do i mean with this this
is a very great uh question this is this
is what we do in here in bagging we are
doing the randomization we are doing the
bagging means column sampling then row
sampling then we have aggregating the
model okay but in boosting we have
additively combined that here it
combines the week with converts the weak
learners speak models into a strong
model okay so different different weak
model uh
tends to be a great model okay just we
will see how it tends to be a great
model so it is just combined so let's
see let's see the core idea so the the
basic idea of using boosting
is using boosting is to reduce bias if
you have a hard bias model then you
likely to use boosting to reduce the
bias of that model ah yeah there is uh
some other techniques also that that
we've already seen but it's just we use
boosting to reduce the bias okay so
let's see
so let's see the the basic intuition
about boosting so let's take an example
that you have your data you have your
training data so i'm just writing my
training data
uh where do i write here you have your
training data which is your
training data i'm just writing train d
okay which is usually which is this this
is a supervised learning
and a supervised learning technique so
you have x i
and y i with which is a label and it
goes i equals to 1 or we can write the i
equals to 1
all the way down to the maybe m okay
here m is the number of training
examples into that a training data okay
and then you make a model and then you
make a model
then you make a model at m1 so let's
take an example that you have made a
moral m1 that simply uh that's simply a
function f of that is simply a function
f of x which is our hypothesis okay so
now what we will do this is the this is
the core idea behind boosting so so we
have a training data you have your
training data like which is your
training data and you train your m1
model onto that now what you have seen
now what you have seen you simply take
out the error you simply take out the
error means the cost function the loss
okay loss for either example loss for
eight example so for each example you
have y i which is a ground truth which
is your ground truth minus your moral
predicted value while more predicted
value is f of x which is uh even when
you input x then you get your output so
model predicted value is f of x okay
this will give you the loss okay the
loss for if it is if it is 0 then this
is very good if it is large then it is
very bad okay so here we are using just
a simple regression loss means just a
loss so if you add a submission over
here if you add a submission i equals to
one all the way down to the m y i minus
f f of x then this is the like mse but
you do a square in msc but now because
of the gradient decent to effectively
compute the derivative but here uh you
can you can just see just just as a
simple conversation what we uh just just
we are taking the laws for each training
example so here let's take an example
that we have take take take in a loss
and then what we do
and then what we do we train our model
onto this loss means we train our model
to reduce this a residual error
to reduce this
residual a residual
uh error okay we probably focus or we we
more focus on to the data which is
misclassified or mis uh which is which
has a very large uh error okay so we
focus on that okay so what you do
um so for really so you want to reduce
this error so how you want to reduce you
want to make a model make a model m
that that
that is given x i means you fit this
residual so let's take an example i'm
just i'm just going to take take an
example to make you this statement clear
that what you do so let's take an
example that you have a regression uh
prop problem statement so you have a
regression problem statement oops i
don't know why i'm making a bad
yeah
why my x-axis is not working great
yeah here is my x-axis a bad x-axis and
you have an x like this
x like this and then what you you have
fit in a straw maybe this line okay a
straight line so here it for this train
example the loss will be very high so it
will uh more probably start focusing on
that and it'll fit on that residual
covering this okay so maybe it will
it will do like this okay it will also
cover this if the residual is very high
so it's always tries to minimize that
residual maybe it can make a knowledge
either the example is too much alandi
but either it can make a nonlinear uh
decision sorry hyperplane okay so uh for
so what what we do we fit our error so
we make up model m1 that minimizes the
error by fitting onto the error so here
is the li
for i equals to 1 all the way around to
the m okay for each way example we are
fitting a model okay so it is more
probably focusing on the data which is
either misclassified or which has a high
uh the partic mse or mae okay if it is a
regression problem then we take msu or
it is or which is misclassified so it is
more only focusing on that okay so
that's the basic intuition so let's let
me uh let me make you uh the full
equation how it looks like so you have
you have f
you have f
of x f of x with k means and some uh
just just a model a big big model means
f of x okay
for each frame example i equals to zero
all the way down to the k okay all the
way down to the k you have an alpha you
have an alpha
times your model i th model so you will
not only have one model you have in
first model that fits them that second
model that covers that that fits that
stress residual then third model that
fits that residual from this model
fourth model that fits that residual
from this model means error okay so we
have a different different model so we
have a large model this k and we go
through each and every model with some
la uh just as assume as lambda so we
have this uh
just uh just as of now just consider
this as us we have computed this somehow
so we will see how it is computed okay
we will see uh when we learn about uh
some gradient boosting okay so just to
assume that we have some uh uh just a
lambda a constant okay here this f of i
x that is that is trained to fit the
residual trained to fit the residual
from the previous model okay
from the previous model means this model
this m2
train to fit the error
we get on m1 okay so this this model may
have some different thing this this
model is able to correctly classify the
error from this first model this m3 is
able to classify the errors from the m2
so like like that okay
so that's that's the basic intuition
behind boosting okay so i think that you
have understood about boosting so now
this will end it up this this function
this function will be ended up giving
you a
low bias
low bias
and a low variance model okay but there
is a problem there is a problem so you
may think hey i use can you name a
problem yeah sure i am here to name okay
but before that you can take a break if
you want because i'm just it will just
take more one hour to complete i think
so it's my approximating time so it will
take one more hour you can take a break
or you can do just a prop problem set if
you want but start with the section and
then complete the section then see the
prop problem set then see some
challenges given to you in my github and
i really understand that you will be
able to do that okay so here you have
this one first you have a training data
then you have a low score loss for your
showing example then each model
trend each model tend to um
each model tend to
fit the residual error given from the
previous model okay and in that way they
end up being a low bias model and it's
very good on training set but there is a
problem the problem is that if it is too
much good under training set means only
100 accuracy on training set then what
will happen then what will happen it
will start overfitting new training
example will come then it will able not
to classify or
detect a good uh prediction okay so
that's way so that's why we have to take
care of how many number of base models
so that we have a lambda but we will
understand this all okay
great so we have understood this and so
the core idea behind bagging the core
idea behind bagging is not too much hard
is just saying is we just use bagging
sorry oh this is boosting oops it's
boosting the core idea behind boosting
is to reduce the bias
reduce the bias on the frame like that
okay
this this converts the weak learners
into these strong learners and here we
have a good fine-tuned models which is
converted into majority of words and
then in bagging like that okay so let's
see um so that's the basic intuition
behind boosting so there are some of the
techniques that we'll study about like a
gradient like gradient
gradient boosted
gradient boosted
gradient booster decision trees
decision trees
which is often called as g
b
d d okay
uh this is a this is because because in
random forest we have our decision tree
and here in gradient boosting we have
our base learner saturday decision tree
and gradient boosting as a base learner
has a decision tree and then we have a
adapt adaptive boost which is often
called as adap boost which is a little
bit uh more advanced version of gradient
boosting then you have extreme boosting
which is x g boost okay which is again a
family of a good algorithm and it's
always outperform it's very very
powerful algorithmic boost as i've seen
so far and we'll show you the
implementation of xgboost also with some
i will show you how it is implemented
and everything and this section valley
okay so
and that's the basic intuition behind
bagging and i really hope that you
understood bagging in detail just to
recap that boost or helps and why i'm
saying bag bagging it's a boosting okay
so boosting here in boosting we have low
variance and high bias model we
additively combine with
in which we convert our speak learners
into strong learners and the core idea
is to reduce the bias it simply means
that we want to improve our error under
training set okay so that's the basic
and we have four which we'll cover in
this section which is gradient booster
decision trees adapt adaptive boost then
we have a x g boost okay so uh i think
that you are understood about boosting
okay so now we will talk about uh
gradient boosting which is again a good
up a very fantastic brilliant uh uh
algorithm okay so to just just use an
internet companies or very big pump
companies which is used in ml in
production okay so which is usually
launched in 20s these uh algorithms okay
so we'll study in detail to make you
understand each and every concept of
gradient boosting and then we will see
the implementation then we will see the
adaptive boost then we will see that xt
boost and then we are end up with this
ensemble models okay then we will go
with uh unsupervised learning techniques
okay so uh just uh let's let's start
with gradient boosting now we have
talked about gradient sorry the boosting
uh the basic intuition behind boosting
what actually the boosting are so now i
will start talking about a gradient
boosting okay so gradient boosting is
another yet one of the most powerful
algorithm that i've seen so far uh yeah
one of one of the most powerful
algorithm which is uh which is yet to uh
uh just learn it's very to have a good
in your tool kit okay so i'm on a
wikipedia page i'm on a wikipedia page
which i found a great machine this
great uh
algorithm which is again uh which which
just tells you a very good
intuition behind gradient boosting
rather than just i
make use of my blackboard either i will
make use of my blackboard over here okay
so
uh so uh what is so what is gradient
boosting this is a great question so
creatine boosting is a boosting
algorithm that just converts the weak
learners into these strong learners okay
so let's start with in this uh gradient
boosting and you can search for gradient
boosting wiki and then you will see the
gradient boosting wikipedia articles and
then you can read the full articles
either i will cover everything in sort
uh in sort uh pdf period of a time but
i've already covered some of them and
and of my just i will cover i i have
covered more than this wikipedia okay so
i will give you some a real world
examples of gradient boosting also where
it is used and everything okay but first
of all let's understand the trend this
the
this algorithm okay so let me see my pen
is at least working or not i hope that
this is working
yeah this is working great i'm just
happy that my ink is working let's try
if the ink to go if you're watching
please help me to improve this very it
is not that much good okay just to
improve this but it's very good tool
it's some sometimes it lacks but it's a
very good tool
check it out it's very good great for
free okay so you have this training data
which is a input training data you have
this three input training data which is
your which is the set of let me write
the training data which is simply
your x i
and y i
and simply goes from i equals to 1 all
the way down to the n okay or m which is
our let's let's stick to our formal
notation which is m which is a number of
training examples number of a training
or the size of our training samples okay
so that's the that's our given data and
we have a differentiable cost function
then we have a differentiable cost
function okay so what do i mean by
differentiable cost function
differentiable cost function means that
your
this cost because we take out the
derivative of our cost function we take
out our derivative of our cost function
with respect to some
some value okay so let's take a we are
taking out the derivative of our j of
theta partial derivative over j of theta
okay so that's the
that's the basic uh about means uh
that's the differential equation that i
know if you know if you're a calculus
student then then you might interpret
that we have a differential but as if if
you're not able to get what is this
differentiable feel free to leave this
differentiable just think that it should
be derivable okay for our gradient
descent or we will be because we have to
take out the derivative of this
particular loss function with respect to
some uh
weights okay so we with that if we are
given training set which is d train we
have a given a training set which is a
value x so x i and y i which goes from i
equals to 1 all the way down to the m
okay
where is my eraser
i think that this is my eraser yeah
i equals to 1 all the way down to the m
and then we have a differentiable
equation as given so let's stick to the
j
of y
y f of x and this is simply just the
error means just a minus
the
minus uh your moral moderated value for
each and particular examples i equals to
1 all the way down to the m and then we
square it all up okay so that's the
that's the our cost function maybe it
can be mean square error or it can be
long loss for classification etc okay
then we are given the iterations then we
are giving the number of iteration which
is m and m here is the model m here is
the base learners m here is the number
of a base learners
number of a base learners
number of a base learners okay so so
this is the number of base learners
which is m
now let's start with algorithm so what
this algorithm tells you so let me
choose the different colors so it might
make sense so we initialize our model
with some constant value lambda with
some constant value lambda in that case
we have in uh alpha but now we had
changed a little bit that we have our
favorite lambda okay so we have to find
lambda oh no
okay
let's uh just think of it as that we
have a lambda we have a lambda that we
have to find that lambda that minimizes
this training error this loss function
it should be told here but i have told
you here just in my excitement so you
what you do you initialize your model
with some lambda that minimizes this
cost function okay so this first to
initialize this uh that's and we will
see how this lambda is computed here but
first of all you initialize it and then
what you do you iterate through each and
every model okay first you go
first you do this for first model then
you do again for second monuments you
apply a for loop where you for m equals
to one first u two m means you want to
go one
two three all the way down to the m okay
so you do this and then
let me first of all let me okay so here
then what you will do then i hope that
then you initialize your model then you
compute the residuals
you compute the pseudo residuals you
compute the pseudo
residuals you compute the pseudo
residuals and then here it is named as r
uh subscript i and m and m here denotes
the num which model and i here for each
20 examples okay so here you compute the
inm and then you take out the partial
derivative the partial derivative oops
what is not working
partial derivative
hey god please help me
the partial derivative of your cost
function y i of your cost function y i
and f of x so this is your loss function
with respect to this function okay f of
x your moral projected value okay and
then you want to fit your model onto
your previous uh residuals so for you go
to i equals to 1 all the way down to the
end so here you take out for f of x
means f that means here here you are uh
fitting your model means just you are
making the model to be f of m minus one
means the previous model okay so you
compute those residuals and then you fit
the base learners okay that i've just
showed you in my in my previous uh just
in just just in the boosting that we fit
the residual so let's take an example we
have n m1 m2 and m3 we have taken the
residuals we have taken the residuals
and the
here is give some residuals this m1 is
trained to fit the residuals from m1
this m2 train to fit the residuals from
m2 okay and this is m3 okay so it is
trained to fit the residuals of fam too
okay so then you fit a base learner or a
weak learner let's take an example three
closed under scaling of h of mx here is
your
two residuals to pseudo residuals means
to fit the learner to fit the
residuals from the
residuals got from the previous base
learners it is to train it using the
training set this one okay and now here
m is in our case which is l i
on m model okay so then you fit your
model that i've already showed you just
similar that we have seen and then you
come compute the multiplier which is a
constant multiplier lambda m for each
model you have lambda m okay which is a
one dimensional optimization problem
for solving the one dimensional
optimization problem so you may ask why
do we are choosing this lambda m so for
solving one dimensional optimization
problem going into 1d
1d 1d optimization
1d optimization is out of the boundary
course but you can see on the link
okay the how you compute you compute
lambda for each model that minimizes the
loss of y which is ground truth from the
previous model plus
plus
lambda
times our just the model that that we
have now okay
now what you do you update the model now
you update the model to be to with the
model to be fitted by the
the model that fitted the previous
residuals okay so f m x here m is our
moral number
the
means model number then we have it then
we have this f of m minus one previous
model plus
lambda m lambda m which is some constant
for solving the one-dimensional
optimization okay because we are taking
the partial derivative of our loss
function y i and f of x i with respect
to f of x i and f of x i is our model
predicted value okay times h of mx and
then you get your output as an f big
model m m big model all the way down to
the x okay so here you when when you
cover all of this you when the loop is
done then you get the final model which
is f m x that is simply f of m minus 1 x
plus the previous model this previous
model plus the a model that we got after
solving this or 1d optimization problem
okay so that's the gradient boosting uh
algorithm that i really hope that you
understood but let's uh let's uh just
just as a recapitulation to help you
understand a little bit much better to
uh understand this problem okay so what
we do
let's understand what we do over here so
we simply first we have our given our
training data we have a training data x
i and y i going from i equals to 1 all
the way down to the n and n here uh
and
and here
i just hope that it should work now
and n here is your and here is number
for training your number size of your
training set then you have a
differentiable loss function with the
number of base learners that you want
okay then you initialize the model with
some constant okay then you apply a for
loop in that for loop you take out the
residuals you take out the residuals for
and and then you
name it as a r subscript i which is the
number of training exam that the index
of between example and m is your number
in the index of your model okay minus
the taking of the derivative for partial
derivative for of your uh loss okay
okay and then you fit a base learner or
a weak learner because there because it
just makes you a weak learner to the
strong learner okay
to
closing under h of mx which is your
got from the weak model makes you just
fit the base learner to to the residuals
so it's simply that you know that you
are going to fit your model into x i and
your l i which is simply l i is this
okay
now you compute the multiplier lambda m
lambda sub 10 for each particular uh m
means the model index for solving the
one-dimensional problem so it's just to
find the lambda m that minimizes the
loss that you get y y i comma the output
from this model okay this is the whole
model now this is a previous model that
is this is a new model that is fitted to
fit this residual okay and then you
update your model okay then you have to
output a big model which is m ffmx that
is simply
this f minus one of x i plus your big
model uh now you just after your full
iteration you'll be ending up being a
big model okay so that's the basic
intuition behind gradient boosting i
really think that you understood about
gradient boosting now uh now it's time
for getting into the uh for getting into
the something called as a regularization
and uh shrinkage okay but before that
why do we need even regularization and
shrinkage so why do we need as we have
already talked about that we have
and that we have in boosting we have
high bias we have high bias let me see
the recordings are on here
oops
we have our high bias and low variance
problem sorry high buy so we so we use
boosting to reduce the bias to reduce
the bias so high base is just doing
barrel training set so if we just after
each iteration we are fitting the
previous model residual so yeah it is
making a knowledge it is doing very very
good on training set so very very good
on training sets so it may happen that
it may start overfitting and our low by
variance goes to
high where starts goes going to high
variance means our low variances start
increasing and now it's converged to
high variance so that actually can cause
overfilling okay so for avoiding we add
regularization and shrinkage which is
again shown in the wikipedia page let's
see so here um i think that i can teach
you better than wikipedia page okay so
you have you this big model you have
this big model f of m
x
which is here you have a h zero x plus
you do for i equals to one all the way
down to the h all the way down to the
edge it's number for your model
lambda m lambda m
or you can see m the number of a model
okay
h
of m x okay so that's your model that we
and then what do you do then if the
number of a base models increase means
it will fit more residuals if the it
will fit more residuals more residuals
then your over fit will then then over
then it will start over fitting start
over
and if it is start overfitting then your
variance will start going up okay so
that that will cause the problem so what
you do you shrink you shrink by a factor
of lamb just a there's a greek letter
that i even don't know that is something
called as a v so let's assume that is a
v which is a parameter v okay so we have
a parameter we have our parameter v
which will help us uh which is just a
parameter for controlling the or it's
just shrinks your strings it just
strings to do not go that much means it
gives a weight it is just a learnable
parameter just gives weight and
empirically it is found that v equals to
0.1 tends to be a dramatic improvements
in your models okay so that's that's why
we use uh this v this v to be 0.1
and
again your v should be in between your v
should be in between
0 and 1 and it's found that v equals 0.1
would be dramatic improvements in your
models okay so you add a new weightage
to that
model means
to this model okay you add british to
this model that i've just shown to you
advantage to that model and that's
called a learning rate for how for how
much time for how much rate it should
learn okay so that's the so that's we
add v direct model so let me add that so
let me add that
so what you do for you just shrinks your
model with
shrink your model
big model
by going f of m minus 1 x plus v times
lambda m
h of m x and v here is in between in
between
1 okay and particle is found that b
equals 0.1 works best okay so that's the
that's about uh gradient boosting and i
really hope that you understood this
also
okay so now it's time for
um we will take a look at implementation
okay so now we will take a look at the
implementation of gradient boosting
classifier and gradient boosting a
regular eraser okay but before that
let's see the training time complexity
of your model so uh let's let's recall
of decision trees and decision trees uh
we have our train and run time
complexity so here we and decision tree
dp i'm writing dt we have old and oops i
am writing this
n log
b and here d and then random forest you
have
o order of n log n number of addition
treatments k
okay now when gradient boosting decision
tree means here we we just take our base
learners as a as a decision tree rather
than different different models so we
have o
n log
d times the number of a models
okay so that's the basic uh uh time
complexity of your gradient boosting
decision trees okay
great now we will see something called
as uh now we will see the implementation
of this uh gradient boosting decision
trees and cycle learn api okay so let's
see
so let me open gradient
boosting
implementation implementation
okay and scale learn
let's see yeah here we found
this wait for a few seconds is just
loading okay great so now here you are
you are on a page of cycle learn api
gradient boosting classifier
and then you can see over here that um
now let's see the some of the parameters
that we are over here so here that you
have a loss that you have a loss which
is the deviance deviance refers to the
log loss an exponential um
refers to the
which which is just adaptive version
which is if you set exponential then
your gradient boosting will go will will
be as will be called as a adaptive
boosting or ara boost okay so in
adaptive boosting it is more pronely we
will see the implementation so in ada
boost it is more pronely focusing on
unclassified okay more more probably
focusing on unclassified but it's not
being used too much okay so we have a
loss equals to deviance which is it was
a legislation laws or log loss okay then
you have a learning rate means the rate
to string the contribution of each tree
by learning rate okay so this is used to
reduce your uh over uh variance okay so
that's your model does not start
overfitting okay so uh this is your
learning rate which is default 0.1 and
leave it 0.1 okay because it's found
that most remember dramatically that
they work best in most of the cases
and then you have a number of estimators
which is number of decision trees
subsample criterion
min sample split min sample leaf min
weight fraction max therefore e3 min
impurity these are particularly for each
freeze and then you have uh let's see
something more of
that we have a validation internal
change and then total ccp alpha that's
not not too cool okay so we have this
and these are some of the hyper
parameters that i know that you had
understood everything okay so you can
see more about this in the parameters in
detail here but we have already talked
about decision trees already okay so
let's see the implementation means the
implementation of this uh gradient
boosting is just one line of code which
is here and you can use predict
probability it simply gives the
probability of that being a true okay
for that class okay so first you import
from scalar dot in symbol input gradient
boosting classifier here is your data
means and then you call your with an
estimators learning rate 1.1 okay 1.0
max depth random
state and then you fit it and then you
get your score okay so that's the basic
intuition behind a gradient boosting uh
classifier okay now let's see the
gradient boosting regressor gradient
boosting regressor
regression
and sk learn
okay so this is a very good to learn
from the documentation
okay this is very good to learn from the
documentation
so let's see okay here here we are on uh
documentation of a cycle learn api now
what we will do we will
just let's use the pen and then you can
see over here that we have a loss
function to be optimized miss l as the
refers to the least squares l a d means
least absolute deviation is more robust
okay so if you have a uber then we have
a quantile but the default is ls okay
then you have a learning rate however
how much this is a for shrinkage then
you have a number of estimators then you
have some sample criterion min sample
split for each particular decision trees
these are for each particular decision
trees and then the same thing that we
have seen so far okay so now uh we are
uh this is the basic for the decision
trees and i hope that you understood
okay now let's uh see the implementation
of this i'm literally going fast because
i have to teach also that xg boost and
arab boost okay so you just uh
call the a gradient booster pressure
then you call the your train just split
then you split your data and then you
call your gradient boosting restore with
the default parameters okay then you fit
it okay and then you
simply do the gradient boost regressor
then you score it and it reuses the sum
scoring parameter it's the long loss or
sorry not log losses maybe it uses r2 or
msc you can see
okay
so that's the basic intuition behind how
we implement a grasshopper and
classifier which we will do in project
just to showcase you how you can assess
from documentation it's very good to
learn from the documentation now it's
time for learning from for uh now it's
time for to that you'll learn about xge
boost we'll learn about uh uh but before
that let's uh let's learn about ada
boost
okay
adapt
so let's see me upside i want implement
scalar
okay so
if you set your uh loss to be
exponential okay to be exponential then
it will be equivalent to ada boost
classifier
boost classifier okay so it will set
your laws to be like this and it's just
the same as that we have already talked
about we have two algorithm given by
sami and sammer which is in sammer which
is also for legit regression if you have
seen is the cycle and api okay so how
you implement from arab boost classifier
then you call this and then you fill
your model and then you are done okay
it's very simple i i think that you but
just remembering the concepts is very
very important because it's not always
you have to implement maybe your own
something algorithm in your company okay
you may think yeah you can't we just
study the implementation no no you
cannot study
okay but cyclone api is very very slow
very very slow but it's great but what
you can do uh you have to in in some
companies for production uh because it's
a kaggle winning uh algorithm that we
need to understand what is happening how
we can tune the hyper parameter okay so
here you can see again for regressor
okay and here you have a loss equals to
linear and then you have a square and
then you have exponential okay
and here maybe we we do have and not
lost you can see state the number of the
classes how many number of a
classification classifier okay so now we
know about this and i really hope that
you understood uh the following
now it's time for uh learning about
extreme boosting one of my favorite but
i think adaboosh is not used in
production uh many um
not uses too much in the production
maybe uh i'm not right over here but i
think so okay so now we will learn about
x g boost which is one of the most
popular algorithm which i have seen so
far okay
means a t
okay it's a it's a good algorithm it's a
good algorithm but it's one of the best
algorithm that wins your kaggle
competition okay so now we will see what
xc boost does it's just the advanced
version of gradient boosting
it have it
it it does have gradient boosting
decision trees plus
it has
randomization with row sampling plus
column sampling and in gradient boosting
we are not doing this but it's at
randomization which is grow sampling
plus column sampling so that's why maybe
name it as a extreme gradient boosting
and it's works best okay this works
brilliantly uh since some cases and
machine learning problems okay but it
needs fine tuning a lot okay so the
gradient boosting decision tree now you
have a row it's just how we differ from
gradient boosting decision trees you
have you do the randomization by doing
feature bagging and then you have a row
sampling okay and it's just for a
simplicity let let me explain you what
we
tend to learn about this
what we do we simply sample the rows
as well as the columns for our data okay
okay and
uh and specifically for bagging we don't
know columns we don't do column sampling
but in a random random forest we do both
so in xgboost we do the gradient
boosting crystalline trees as well as a
random forest plus
uh column sampling okay
so that's the that's what we do
randomization and
that's the xd boost okay so now we will
see in detail what actually the xg boost
xd boost
from the official documentation but but
it is all it is it is of course
implemented
in the
it is of course
implemented in cyclone api but it's uh
but it's very good to use because there
this is fast actually it is fast
actually it's very good to learn from
here rather than there
okay so i think that we can found get a
the
python package
because we have different different
package no
setting parameters
oops where it is xgboost
uh python package
okay so here we have some parameters an
xg boost i think that my brave is not
working i have to again switch to my
favorite chrome why i have switched it
to this
it's bad x uh brave is actually not good
for me and since some kids actually i'm
like who am i said to say bad but it's
good good but it's all of course
sometimes it does very bad okay so let's
see some of the parameters let's see
some of the parameters so we have
different different packages that we had
that already been implemented this
algorithm
so here
you have booster which is gb3 means
gradient boosting tree you can use the
gb linear or dart the means vu's will
use gb3 then you have a validate
parameters default to false means it's
just going to validate your parameters
or not then default to maximum number of
threads then you have an evaluation
matrix then
e term is learning rate okay is 0.3 okay
gamma which we have seen which is the
constant which is zero as default and
this just we just randomly initialize
means and then we
find a good gamma
and then what is the max depth for each
tree and you can read the documentation
over here more
minimum child weight minimum delta step
means what is the step should one uh
maximum delta step we allow each leaf
output to be if they it means there is
no constraint okay if if means it's just
like that it's just uh helping you to
not too much pruning to overfitting it's
more robust model okay so you can see
your lambda means l2 regularization like
a lasso and this is for red
regularization that is alpha
regularization okay then we have a tree
method which is exhibits construction
algorithm using
xgboost you can see the reference you
can see obviously see the reference it
also supports uh hist and etc then it's
a have a scale post weight updater which
is process type group policy maximum
number of leaves but is to point to zero
um to be added okay so max bin predictor
then we have a gpu cpu but this leads a
lot of fine tuning it takes a lot of
time in cpu okay so we have this much
and you can see more about this it's
very long set of parameters but we
usually use the main parameters that we
have listed okay so you can see a python
package first one you want to install it
you want to install it you can just pip
install xgboost and then we and then you
just call
xgb dot d matrix first you convert that
into a d matrix then you uh
uh do that means you can do also for
pandas using the cylon api but it's okay
to use it but you can see over your
implementation sk learn it's also for
regressor that we have seen
i think that we had they have removed
i think not they have they haven't
removed no no worries so you can see
from here how it is used and how we
train this model and how we save this
model uh it's just like a neural web as
you as you know that
tensorflow has also added decision trees
and like that in simple learning it
started adding because one of the most
powerful
uh algorithm in stem learning okay so we
have seen a lot in in
decision trees okay uh sorry in ensembl
learning like bagging and boosting okay
so now one last step is left is stacking
of your uh stacking okay so after this
section we will start with the stacking
to help you to better understand what
actually stacking is and it will
obviously help you okay so we have seen
a lot of applications of this and i
really hope that you enjoyed it also
okay so this this section is just
amazing we have learned about
boosting and we have learned about
gradient boosting they are adaptive
boosting they have learned about exege
boost okay and so one of the projects
will fine-tune we'll use xg boost ada
boost with fine-tuning okay one of our
project okay so uh that's it for this
section in the next section we'll start
with the stacking there's a one only 20
minute session on stacking will take and
then we just with some other summary or
revision of ensembl learning okay so
let's meet at the next section
okay so now we'll talk about our lawson
symbol learning technique which is uh
called stacking of our models okay so
we will see the implementations of the
stacking so and we will see how it works
and how it changes your accuracy okay so
let's recall uh something called as bias
and variance of our bagging and boosting
okay so when bagging and bagging
we have
high variance
high variance
and low bias trade-off
okay
and in boosting and then boosting you
have
low buy a high bias
high bias
and low variance tradeoff okay so
remember these two uh for stacking okay
so here i am i am on my mls extend which
is a library for implementing the
sacking classifier okay so you can we
will see the implementation of this uh
stacking classifier but before that we
will learn well how actually stacking
works you can get to this page by just
going to mlx 10 stacking classifier and
click on the first link okay so let's
start so here is our data set here is
our data set so let me take out my
favorite
uh ink to go i hope that you remember my
favorite ink to go sometimes i
roast it also but here it is very good
just for in annotating uh these these
kind of things okay so here uh let let
me take the pen that as of now let's
take a red which i like a lot let's take
a medium okay great so here is you in
bagging what what we were doing we have
a large training data we have a large
training training data and then your
multiplier or you are just taking out a
subset of this data d and one d n2 the
entry with the replacement are training
the decision trees or maybe some same
base learners okay so in the stacking we
have different different base learners
we take out the data
okay and then we train our model
different different model under the each
data like a c1 uh is a model which is
trained on different data
then again means on the data d1 then c2
is trained on d2 all the way down to the
m okay so here
c1 c2 all the way down to the cm
are a different are different
models okay so what do i mean by our
different models
is quite simple is let's take an example
let's just take an example that you have
your favorite legitimate ration
okay you have a logistic regression you
have a logistic
regression as a c1 okay as a c1
then you have your support vector
machine
as a c2 then you have your favorite
naive bayes algorithm knife base
algorithm with uh maybe with extensive
fine tuning using grid search okay so
here we have c3 here we have k nearest
neighbors
uh which is c4 okay with extensive with
maybe k equals to four okay um with
extensive fine tuning okay so we have
four base learners and we have a
different legitimate regression support
vector machine nine base k nearest
neighbors and there are four different
models okay and a train or different
different thing okay and the major
difference between uh the bagging and
boosting is in bagging that that i've
told you to recall
bagging bagging and stacking
is in bagging we have high variance high
variance
and low bias
low bias
models which is a base learners which is
the base learners and in and in bagging
we used to be used bagging for reducing
the high variance okay so base learners
are usually high variance and low bias
and trade-off between them okay so what
is the difference between stacking
in a stacking
in stacking
our base base models or base learners
are highly tuned are highly well tuned
okay highly well parameter tuned okay
highly well parameter tuned and they
have a good bias and variance trade-off
okay so in boosting so in bagging we
have high variance where our base space
owners are not that much good and also
when boosting our business are not that
much good but in stacking our base
learners are quite good are quite good
are very good with extensive fine fine
tuning so maybe you have changed the
legislation fine tuning with the
learning rate support vector machine
like c your regularization parameter and
your gamma and then maybe some
of the other parameters okay a nine
bayes algorithm we have also done it's
not required but you have done some
extensive fine tuning you have kink
nearest neighbors we have chosen what is
the number of k okay so you have done an
extensive fine tuning of your model okay
so that's what uh what i mean here i'm
taking what a classification example
okay so here um
what what we are doing
here what what we are doing is just we
are the models are highly trained it's
highly fine-tuned okay highly very very
very much a train uh extensive fine
tuning are very good models they do have
a very good bias and variance tradeoff
okay and here it gives prediction let's
take an example that
c1 gives you prediction as a y-hat one
then c2 gives you prediction as if i had
to and all the brown to the y hat m okay
so each model gives your output okay the
prediction okay so what you are doing so
what you are doing so let me do this so
as an as a motivating example so can i
delete this if i can yeah let me let me
delete that so what you are doing so
what you are actually doing is
simply uh taking your training data
which is straight taking your training
data you you are dividing your training
data you're dividing a training data
into subsets of into subset of training
data d1
d2
and d3 spotting for an example let's
take 4d3 okay and you're training your
base learners which has a good bias and
variance trade-off which has a good bias
and variance trade-off okay the base
numbers are very good bias and very good
model they are not either
low bias or high bias because here in
bagging again i'm saying in bagging you
have high variance high variance and low
bias
model and what do i mean by high
variance it means it performs very very
well under training data but it fails to
generalize well on a testing data okay
so that's why and and that's why it's
called high variance and in boosting
it is under fitting it means that your
model
uh your model is either
overfill
means uh under fitting because it has a
low high bias which is not performing
well under training data and low
variance like that okay so here we have
a intuition about bagging and boosting
okay so here we have a highly tuned
model with extensive fine tuning and
then what you do you take out the
prediction why hat one why had to why
hats we y hat3 okay after you take out
this now what you do you train your
model you train your model
you train your
model obtain your meta classifier you
train your meta classifier which is just
pretty which is just trained to on the
on the predicted class labels from the
base learners or their probabilities
from their ensemble okay so they are
usually trained on these things on these
on the predicted class of our favorite
classification or base learners
either they will either take the class
labels or the probability of being that
class okay so maybe 0.65 or in
particular class it may be zero or one
or two okay so that's what the basic
intuition behind
the
this uh stacking but again i'm i'm very
uh just just i will recalculate you so
that it works it makes sense again okay
so what you do in stacking so uh let's
uh just just for an example in the
stacking we are just taking a trading
data okay and then you're training and
then you're dividing our data into
substitute data and then you're training
different different classifier onto that
data okay here we have a c1 here we have
a c2 all about cm which is new data okay
new in new data we are training and uh
and then what it happens in trains are
c1 c2 all the parameters c3 uh scm under
the that data and takes out predictions
and the major difference is the first
difference is that the
bias
and variance rate of bias and variance
trade-off
trade-off
of
of the base learners in the stacking
learners
in stacking is good
and stacking is
good okay it's good whereas in bagging
we have
high variance and low bias okay and in
oops what happened
and in boosting
we have high bias
and low variance high bias and low
barrier oops what happened
high bias and low variance
low variance okay so that's the major
difference
next thing is that
after you get the prediction from each
of the model by because you have done a
lot more fine tuning a third hyper
parameter you'll get your p1 p2 all the
way down to the pm now you train a
big or a meta classifier which you
usually call as s dash onto the
prediction of
h1 of x means the one classifier second
s2 of vector second classifier all the
way down to the edge m of x either you
train onto the probabilities
probabilities given by these models
probabilities or the predicted class
labels from these ensembles okay and in
there is in bagging we are aggregating
the majority of votes we are aggregating
okay the majority of votes or from that
models then you're taking that as a
final prediction by hat but we have a
different chance of here we have
different approach okay so let's
let's take a quick quick uh quick look
at the at the
second at the stacking algorithm but
it's i have already explained you and
just just above but as an uh just as a
formal definition here you have your
training data which is usually x i and y
i
which is which goes from
x i equals to 1 all the way down to the
m where x i is the member of
r which has an n dimensional maybe it
can have a multiple features and whereas
the y i will be the member of the number
of the classes of y okay so that's the
thing and then what you do and it's
output will be the in symbol classifier
which is va edge dash or a big edge okay
first what you do learn first level
classifiers means you learn uh team t
classifiers maybe it can be logistic
regression
knight bass knight base it can be k
nearest neighbors and uh
[Music]
one one
all the way down to the t and t here is
the number of base models okay based on
the distribution data d now you
construct new data set now you construct
new data set going from i equals to 1
all the way down to the m and then if
that that constant contains x i hat
prime by i where x i it's simply the
prediction the prediction from the each
model the from the each base learn
learners model okay from the each models
now what you do you train your second
level classifier first to train the
first level now you train your second
level classifier and here it simply
trains together
make a hypothesis of training onto these
models and these meta class this this
meta classifier can be anything this
meta classifier can be logistic
reduction can be nine base can be
uh
carriers neighbors can be support with
the machine and even model and we are
not aggregating we are not taking mean
we are not taking anything we are just
trading a second level classifier that
is just trained on our front base
learners and base learners have a good
bias and variance tradeoff okay so
that's the stacking and i hope that you
understood about the stacking now i will
just uh take a look at the the the
formal
i would say the form without the
i could say implementation of a stacking
the implementation of the stacking okay
so you can see over here you can see
over here uh the paper
which is in some of the research papers
they usually call as a stacked
generalization you can uh sound some
some in some research paper we call that
okay
okay so let's make a simple stack
classification first what you have done
over here we have simply loaded the data
set from the sql data set which is the
iris data set and iris data set is not
too much hard we have sepal oops we have
a sepal length we have a sepal length
petal length petal width and petal
length okay so we have four features and
bases on that we have to predict what is
this species of that flower which is
either can be satoshi verse cycler or
virginica okay so that's the that's the
that's our data set
now you can see first we import the
model selection which will see what it
does then we put the logistic regression
from linear model api and then cycle
learn then we import caney knn which is
a which is again from neighbor from
neighbors api and cycle learn and then
you employ import gaussian night bass
from uh
night bass either not gone into too much
of algorithm because learning algorithm
can just you can see the wikipedia you
are now capable of learning any
algorithm okay now uh you just import
the random forest specifier from ensembl
learning uh and symbol api of cycle
learn now you import from mlx10 library
is classifier import stacking classifier
either you have been first you have to
install this using pip install if you
have a python mlx stand but then you can
do this kind of thing okay where is my
let me delete this okay after that after
that what we have to do we have to
simply import the numpy as np is allies
and import warnings okay now you want to
ignore the warnings given by the models
now first your first model is clf one
which is k neighbors which with the
neighbors of one if it is bagging if it
was bagging then we have to if it is run
random for us we have taken one of the
decision tree but we are taking
different different models and that's
what makes it perfect
okay random classifier gaussian i base
legislative regression okay now we to
now what what we have done we
instantiated our object everything now
instantiate our stacking classifier
which is the number of the classifier
will be clf 1 which is cll k neighbors
random forest which is the cl of two and
these three which we are these three
are zlf2
clf3 are the base learners it will give
output
it will give output like this okay now
what what we what you will do you want a
meta classifier which will be the
logistic regression which with the
logistic regression which is the which
will the the distribution as i have told
you can take legislation as a meta
classifier okay now you perform a
three-fold clause cross validation
right now you perform three-fold
cross-validation
and now you perform three-fold
cross-validation
now uh in three four cross validation
you are just looping through clf as well
as the label it seems uh zipping the clf
one cl of two clf three and self okay
now k n a random forest knight base and
stacking classifier now you select the
best model you now you select the base
model by training each of the model
whether you are taking a scoring equals
to accuracy now you check the accuracy
and you can see and you can see
and you can see that this stacking
classifier has around point
point four percent of increase uh
as is better i means is quite better
than this a random word the stacking
classifier works best in this case okay
and now what what you can do you can
oops what about what happened
what you can do you can actually plot
the k n and how it is plotting means the
decision boundaries of the models how
they are plotted that decision
boundaries or hyperplanes okay during
the math clock level so let me and
annotate what is doing first you import
the math plot lab then you have to
import the plot decision regions from
mlx 10 then employ the greatest pick
then you include the iter tools then you
set the set the
area then you set the area again you
loop through by dipping and then you
take out the product and then you fit it
and then you plot it and then you apply
the decision boundary then you title the
lab and lab here is just k n n a random
forest night base and stacking
classifier okay after you plot it now
you are done with the second classifier
okay now as i've already stated you
either for training the mera classifier
you can use either this uh that
i could say
i could say that uh maybe the uh
the
prediction from the base learners so you
can either take prediction class or the
probabilities as the meta features okay
so you can say that use probe
use probe
equals to true
use proba equals true and average
probably equals to false okay and you
can see uh here are a little bit of the
documentation over there okay
great now we have seen this and again
the same thing is not too much harder we
are using the
thing and now we will see uh here is an
example of a stacked classification
using grid search it's your task is to
do this but i'm just going to annotate
what the
this kind of thing will do great search
so here you are just first of all you
are just you now you will tune you will
have a good bias and variance trade-off
so you are going to check between one to
five you are going to check and then
meta classifier and the feather grid
search you find the grid best grid
search then you plot the results means
you take out the results what are the
best parameters and the accuracy so
after applying that you will get a set
of values which are the best uh k
nearest has these
best features and like that okay
now you can import the same thing for
doing the k nearest neighbors and this
and random forest classifier and then we
have one
which is the meta classifier okay now
using the grid search stacking that
operator on different subset of features
you can also do that by selecting the
column separator by calling the make
pipeline that selects the two features
okay so that's the that you can do and
you can use pre-fitted
uh classifiers which is already been
fitted uh
we previously filled out classifiers in
your models okay
fit base estimator equals to false means
you don't want to fit your base esteem
errors okay you can also plot roc curve
using and you can see the roc curve like
this and and this is first of all these
four four examples are very very
important we feel
you can see the rvc curve uh in more
detail on the internet
okay great so now we have talked a lot
about stacking classifier i showed you
the implementation of stacking
classifier here is it a very interesting
and a brilliant diagram on a stacking or
algorithm given a stacking this is a
good example on stacking that i want to
give it to you okay thanks to the author
who has given to you full credit goes to
them okay there's some add-on just on
man annotating okay so now we are done
with uh these uh with uh
ensembl learning so let's uh let's
recapitulate what what we have seen so
far
we have seen we have seen we have
completed we have
completed let me write a good
accomplishment
completed
and sample learning so what we have seen
we have seen bagging
so in bagging the basic intuition is we
have a data we take out different
different data we train a different
different model and then we aggregate
the majority of boards from each of the
model then you have
then in bagging we have learned about
one of the algorithm which is a random
forest that just uses the base learners
with row sampler uh with feature
sampling okay feature bagging and then
we take out the boosting then we learned
about the boosting we're in boosting we
learned about the technique okay and
then we're kind of converting the weak
learners to the strong learners then
then we talk about the
g
gradient
boosting decision trees then we have
talked about adaptive boosting which is
ada boost which is just to the
exponential it's a loss and then we
talked about x hd boost okay now we are
now we in this section in this sub
section we have talked about its
stacking we have talked about the
stacking where we have seen a lot of
examples a lot of examples using grid
search and saturday using that that that
okay so now i hope that you understood
everything about machine learning sorry
ensemble learning okay so if you're
watching till now i am saying that you
know
that you do everything about supervised
learning that you need to crack any kind
of interview okay so just to pat your
back and
and be sure to subscribe my youtube
channel it's it just gives you a great
motivation as the new deep learning
course will is coming soon so you can
pre-register there for free
and you can re-register that
or if you want or if you want you can go
to amtran.com
for
detailed uh cso there is cso1 course
which is uh which is on again machine
learning but it's it's this it's not
that different but it helps you to make
a resume based projects it help you to
make the uh everything means a lot paper
in laricks you will get live down
supports etc just as i step two so that
uh just as you can go to cs01 see the
benefits for the course details etc and
the launch video which has already been
launched okay so i think that it's you
can also apply for a scholarship if
you're a college student but it's
totally fine forgive but the course
price is like this okay but it's totally
based upon you if you want you can
definitely consider it just supports to
make free content more okay so um that
just just to me ask a question is is
this course
the same as cs01 yeah it's
yeah but we in that we have talked about
till
about neural networks then we have
talked about gans convolution neural
networks you have you will get a
one-to-one session you will get jupiter
notebooks which are amazing jupiter
notebooks you will get early access to
my books you will work with the team you
will be getting an internship will work
on a real world project in lantern etc
okay so you can consider android.go for
this okay if you want the lab but if you
complete this this course you all be
very very comfortable in machine
learning okay so that's it for this uh
section for this whole section on symbol
learning from the next section you can
consider subscribing obviously from the
next section we'll be starting with and
in between we can do some projects so
from the next section we'll starting
with unsupervised learning and i really
hope that you will enjoy that series
also okay so let's meet at the next
section
okay so now we have covered supervised
learning and you're gonna now consider a
comfort table and supervised learning
yourself supervised learning is one of
the very best was topic in machine
learning that you have covered very
smoothly and i hope that you understood
every each and everything about
supervised learning if you have any kind
of doubt you can either ask a new or a
discord community or you can ask over to
the uh
the you can find the discord community
or you can come comment and then we can
answer your questions
okay so uh that so let's uh let's start
with unsupervised learning so what
actually in supervised learning we are
doing we have our data set which is x i
as well as y i and we have i equals to 1
all the way down to the n and actually
we have one supervisor which is by i and
we know what our output should look like
means we know what our output should
look like either be and continuous value
which is a regression problem or a
classification or a classification
okay so that that we know that what our
output should look like
okay so here
so we know what our output should look
like so now in case of
unsupervised learning there is no
supervisor so in case of unsupervised
learning we have only x i
we have only x i okay x1 x2
x3 all the way down to the x i which
covers i equals to 1 all the way down to
the m okay so here in unsupervised
learning we don't have any kind of
supervisor that will that that will tell
us what what will be the either output
or will help us to train our model okay
and we we we don't know what our aqua
should look like either not in
continuous
and not in specification so you so you
cannot you cannot frame your problem and
you cannot even scream because if you if
you don't have your labels then then you
cannot frame it in a supervised learning
problem so what i have to do what what
we have to do
so but i'm going to just want to do is
just specify that the data
we we have a structured data as well as
on a structured data
structure data as well as unstructured
data and structured data is simply that
which is in a table or format
and unstructured data which is just
images which cannot be fed on tables or
csv files okay or in excel okay so here
so uh this is our unsupervised learning
because uh we don't have our output okay
so what what we have to do this is the
main question to ask what we have to do
if you don't have the labels so let's
consider let's consider
you have this uh you have this x and y
playing let me draw it very nicely so
that in this section i'm just going to
in this sub section i'm just going to
give you an
overview understanding and some of the
applications of unsupervised learning
okay so consider that you are working on
uh
just just you have your data points just
you have your data points like this you
have your data points
like this into an x and y plane onto the
coordinate planes and you have another
data points which is like this okay
which is like this and you may ask hey i
use why can't we make a simple
hyperplane but you don't know but you
cannot frame it in classification
problem just as a motivating example and
i'm taking it as an example okay so here
just assume that you have this type of
data set okay which is true mentioned
either you can make that
three-dimensional also you can make a
three-dimensional also just by
converting this and now let's consider
that you have a three-dimensional
feature so here you have
this
here you have another example
okay so you have this so now you only
have these types of data points which is
this this one is x1 x2 x3 these types of
okay
so
in
unsupervised learning in unsupervised
learning what you do you make cluster of
your data which is closest to one point
you make cluster of your data of your
data make cluster of your data so as a
motivating example let's take an example
of uh let's take an example that you
want to segment your customers okay uh
let's say example your data scientist at
amazon some some companies so you just
wanted to
segment your customers so how you will
segment your customers uh so what do uh
you you will just segment to customers
we have this data but you don't have the
y labels so what you will do you will
make the similar person into the one
group
similar person into the other guru
similar person let me do that my bad
okay similar person and another group
and similar person similar person
similar person into the other book
similar person on the other group so
what you would have done you have
divided your customers into segments now
data scientists are business
stakeholders what they can do they can
decide that okay we can give these uh
these customers our deal these customers
a deal basis on their activity what they
are doing or god we can make a sub on
another machinery model that will detect
what they are really what they want okay
and and we can recommend the products we
can recommend the products basically
these these types of customers like milk
or like watching the jewelry or on an on
amazon so here uh also on here
you it will show the products of books
or maybe some jewelleries which are
interested
and here maybe they will show you some
kitchen
kitchen groceries maybe these customers
are interested in these and then these
customers can be toys
maybe uh
some
tvs okay so they will be recommended
some products and according to them they
earn a huge amount of money from
recommending ads etc okay so so that's
why you can see that how we how we frame
our problem and now you now it's quite
clear to understand that as a motivating
example of
customer segmentation customer
segmentation in amazon and and if you
may think here you should you see that
uh let me go to amazon.com you will see
that i'm being i'm being
recommending and they know what i
recently viewed what i recently do and
they are recommending the products they
are recommending the products which you
can see over here that they are
recommending the products basis on my
views okay so i'm in some segment i'm in
some segment
and they are simply uh recommending the
basis products and i hope that you
understood and and i hope that you are
understanding what i'm saying as an
unsuper training framing the problem as
an unsupervised learning okay so that's
what the first customers segmentation or
and uh recommendation engine that is
happening in amazon okay so just uh just
see that just watch the too much talk
videos on youtube now what youtube will
do youtube will take yourself and add it
in a segment of the one who watches
stocks and now they will show you dog
ads maybe pedigree or etc whatever the
food of the dog is or that will
recommend you the videos of dogs okay so
that's why we have customer segmentation
as a whatever example and a
recommendation is a more motivating
example so now i hope that is start
making sense to you about why we call
this as unsupervised learning okay now
we so there's a this is a in
supervised learning in supervised
learning we have two two approaches we
have two approaches which is the
regression which is the regression
and next one is specification but in
unsupervised learning we have something
called as clustering okay so we cluster
our outputs we and if you plot in high
dimensional space then you will imagine
that the most similar items are close to
each other and most decimal items are
very much far away okay
so you can understand like this okay so
let's take a let's take a motivating
example again so let's see some of the
applications of unsupervised learning so
i will spend a little bit amount of time
telling you about the applications of
uh unsupervised learning and in the in
this next subject we'll start with the
making clusters how what is intra what
is enter how we do we make the cluster
how do we evaluate our cluster etc okay
so uh here i'm not talking about detail
i mean clustering about clustering but i
will definitely just told you that we
divide our customer into segments okay
so
here
here
let's take an example we have now we are
taking the now we are taking a look at
the applications now we are taking a
look at the applications of unsupervised
learning so the first application of
unsupervised learning is in
biology which i have taken from
wikipedia which is sequence analysis
okay
sequence analysis and it's simply
it's just put your g on just genes into
the particular segment and this will
help you in a various cases for a
biology student then you will understand
then you will understand this
concept of sequence and analysis because
you don't have what you do you segment
your genes in a particular
set segments and you can diagnose if
this person has it again any kind of
okay problem the next application which
is in business which is in business uh
maybe a grouping of similar clusters for
business and needs so let's take an
example that some company takes your
data and then
then take your data and then simply
group
grouping
the similar cluster grouping the similar
similar
clusters basis on the business data and
they can see the clusters what they are
what their activity is and they can
provide deals offers according to
activity
okay another thing is we have a
recommendation engine recommendation
engine recommendation engine that
recommends the products recommends the
product that we have seen okay so in
recommendation you have content
filtering collaborative filtering
content filtering
quantum filtering collaborative
filtering okay so which you can see uh
which which have been which is village
advanced but i'm not going to talk about
recommendation engine but as a modding
example that you whatever you see in
amazon or google they just show you what
you have seen so far because they have
each and every because if you search
anything you have the uh they have that
data okay for making annual models next
is that and the
social network analysis facebook if you
know about facebook uh they
they told hey
this this person has to uh just share
the post means that we do the social
network analysis
social
network the means these were they
the group customers into the segments
the group customers into the segments
the group customers into the segments
and the pro and they showed up
accordingly uh profiles okay another is
we have in computers uh computer systems
is we have our favorite in computer
science we have image segmentation so
what do i mean by image segment
segmentation so you have a mage you have
an image
and you segment your image you segment
if you frame this problem as
unsupervised learning so you have your
image so you have your image like this
and some someone is here someone is here
someone is here so you segment these
images
segment these images okay uh second
segment these images as a pixel device
you see that they are they have similar
pixels segmented uh so so that's what
you're saying segmenting and then this
can be used for
classification or object detection
object detection
okay
object detection like that okay so uh
just grouping your images into segments
by using maybe pixels etc okay because
we don't have uh labels for body another
motivating example in nash triangle
processing and is sentiment analysis
means uh just
just seeing whether it be a negative or
the positive okay so what uh let's take
an example that you have this uh
that that we have this sentence okay
this sentence and another sentence okay
so it will group the positive science
sentence and the negative sentence okay
so now you will see now now you will see
now what what you will do you will go
and see one of the sentence you will go
and go and see one of the sentence
go and see the one of the sentence and
see okay if it is positive then you live
a whole
whole cluster which is maybe 10 000 10
000
um
sentences as a positive and you date is
a to hold then maybe whatever the number
of as a negative so me let's just take a
word let's
let me elaborate this nlp task of
segment analysis let's take an example
sentiment analysis sentiment
analysis
so for an example assume that you have a
one
billion uh text data points in text
which are text textual okay so converter
is a word embeddings mean numbers now if
it is very very hard to label it will
compute if it will take time it will
take cost it will take because if you
hire some people you have to give them
money okay so you have to label one
billion so how you have to do so what
you will do you convert them into a high
dimensional space and you segment uh the
closest text which is called the word
embeddings closest word imbalance the
quantum headings and sentences are here
and then then you see one sentence is
from this cluster one another sentence
from this cluster now assume that this
cluster is a positive sentence you label
all let's say 50 million as a positive
and hold 50 million as the negative okay
so
so you just require it to just you don't
require a lot of times for working with
nlp tasks okay so that's the uh that's
that's for nlp tasks another is anomaly
detection okay what is a normal
dissection and and in a knowledge
section an anomaly
you have anomaly
anomaly
a detection anomaly detection where we
determine outliers in your model so as
an example that you have the exam age
like this
now assume that your data points is here
so this is actually outlier this is
actually outlier so if you cluster it if
your cluster here
then this will be ignored and this this
this can help in in removing button but
using maybe the db scan
isolation forest they but most many of
them may be some k-means
just take that outlier into this cluster
okay so let's assume there is a then it
is also closest to then they take that
into that cluster okay so we have a db
scan which helps us into a normal
distraction which is again an
unsupervised learning model okay in a
dance-based reasons
great so we have seen a lot of
applications of unsupervised learning we
have seen a lot and i hope that you
understood really
and in the in the next sub-section we
will start talking about clustering okay
we will deep dive into the clustering to
help you better understand the topic
we'll talk about clustering we will talk
about entering cluster interact and drop
cluster how we evaluate our cluster okay
how we if we evaluate our data that we
have a good clustering what what are the
some of the types of clustering like
partial
hierarchical okay then we talked about
center-based continuity based density
based and then we will talk about one
formal center-based algorithm which is k
means clustering algorithm okay and then
we are done with supervised unsupervised
learning okay
and then i will give you a little bit
overview of deep learning okay so that
you could better understand your deep
learning a journey
uh just
evaluation and then we will do some
projects based on machine learning so
that you could get more feel about
machine learning and you are more
comfortable and be sure to do the
problem sets which are uploaded and
github to help you understand the topic
or master the topic
okay so that's it for this section and i
hope that you will that you have enjoyed
this section
okay so now we'll start talking about
clustering we will get in the math and
we will see some more algorithms like
k-means clustering then we will see
hierarchical clustering algorithms which
is agglomerative and divisive and
then we are and with unsupervised
learning so we are entering the last
phases of this course and i really hope
that you enjoyed this course a lot okay
as i enjoyed making this course with
very curiosity with very energetic
moods so i think that you're also very
energetic till now and like me and you
may also thinking hey are you sure what
about the projects and the projects are
in the last section to help you to get
feel of everything about machine
learning means after you learn all of
these things performance matrix
algorithms now you will be able to build
state of the art models okay so i'm very
excited to see you all there and it
means in this section last section we'll
be building back to back project and the
course website is also in the
description box below you can see what
what problem set is that and you can
download and start working on that
problem set okay so you i i hope that
you're watching this video did totally
worth it even i was making video was
totally worth it okay so what we are
going to start talking about we are
going to start talking about
we are going to start talking about uh
clustering in the in our previous
section sub section will be we have
talked about some of the applications of
clustering we have talked about let let
me choose a pen a good pen we have
talked about
applications we have talked about
applications of clustering we have seen
what the unsupervised learning is
what unsupervised learning is and we
have seen the diagram digest some a lot
of applications like biology and
business and etc we have seen the
applications of unsupervised learning
and then i've showed you the data okay
and then i've given you an overview what
we do in clustering okay so let's start
with uh clustering okay so how what what
what with what the clustering is
what the clustering is but don't just
bear with me with
my handwriting because i don't know what
happened to my pen it's very working bad
but no worries let's start so here uh
let's assume that you have this you have
this you have the great oops
let me white is not being removed
let's assume that you have a x and y
plane where you have a two two features
uh where you have two features
like this if i draw a straight line if i
draw a straight line
okay so here
so here you have this and let's assume
that you have
here is a point here
okay you have this as a point and
another point and another point
is green once
which is here okay
so no no no
in
unsupervised learning in unsupervised
learning all datas are saying bye i
forgot no worries i usually forgot
everything okay so what you have you
have these features
red features and you have this here so
what you usually do in uh in in case of
clustering you segment your clusters you
segment your data into different
different clusters oh my god why it is
not happening is
you segment your cluster so you have
this data so you segment this cluster
you segment this cluster
to be going into this this and the
second cluster we're going into this
okay so this is the first cluster this
is your second cluster okay so this is
your basic inter basic uh thing about
clustering that that we have talked okay
so we'll see some of the terminology in
this so let's draw a very good
representation of this diagram so let me
delete all these links and let me choose
a black pen it's works best in the in
case of white
okay so you let me draw a straight line
with x plane okay
so you have
x and y plane x and y plane and here you
have the data point
here you have the data point like this
and here you have the data point like
this
okay so what do you do you segment your
uh data points into clusters you cluster
it out so some of the terminology is you
cluster this you cluster this let me
draw a good
cluster you cluster this and then you
cluster this
okay so let's leave that i don't want to
make it like that let's leave that for
now okay so you cluster this out and
then what happens so here is a
terminology alert
means the in terminology we have
something called as intra cluster we
have something called as
intra cluster
intra
cluster
and enter cluster
just
just listen what i'm saying interrupt
cluster and enter into inter cluster so
what do i mean with these intra and
enter i mean with this intel intro and
enter is enter cluster is the distance
between the cluster okay between between
the clusters across all the clusters so
enter cluster is the difference is the
distance between across the cluster so
here we have one cluster here we have
second cluster so intra inter cluster is
the distance between
this cluster and this cluster it's the
distance between this cluster and this
cluster so that's why it's known as
enter cluster okay the second type of
his intra cluster which is the distance
between
within the cluster that points within
the cluster within the cluster so it may
be like this this is called the
this is called the intracluster this is
called the intra cluster
i hope that you are uh that is making
sense you have this x and y plane and
you have this this kind of thing and
what to what we have to do this is this
is called the intra cluster where we
have the distance between two clusters
or maybe two or more than clusters
across all the clusters and intra
cluster is the
distance between the data points inside
that cluster okay
great so
we can think think something like that
is we want what we want in this case if
we are taking as a terminology that so
we want our
interact cluster to be small
interact cluster
interact cluster
to be small
to be small
and
inter cluster
inter cluster to be large
what do i mean with this small and large
i mean with this small and large is you
have this intra cluster the internet
cluster is the distance between this and
this and the clusters takes whoever is
similar or group
is a cluster is just as in is a grouping
of the similar objects that they are
similar to one another so they should be
closest the data point should be closest
and the intra cluster of these should be
closest okay and the inter cluster inter
cluster means the similarity
dissimilarity between two clusters
should be maximum okay so here we have
written our optimum optimization
objective
uh we have we we want uh our enter
cluster our inter cluster which i did
with i n should be large
and i
and a should be intracluster should be
small okay so that's the that's the
basic definition of that's the basic uh
basic terminology that we have seen and
i hope that is making sense okay so we
can frame some problem we can
frame something over here what we can
frame is we can frame an optimization
objective we can frame a
evaluation technique but before that why
do we even need so let's assume let's
assume that you have this you have this
cluster you have this cluster
you have this cluster like this you have
this cluster
one two three four five six seven
one two three four five six seven
okay so here we have this and
who can tell you who can tell you that
these are the perfect clusters these are
the perfect clusters
uh either you will tell hey you should
i'm able to see i can tell that these
are the perfect clusters but assume that
we have uh three dimensional we have
four dimensional we have fifty
dimensional we have eighty dimensional
we have hundred dimensional we have lack
dimensional so what you will do in that
case so we have evaluation techniques
okay we have optimum optim
evaluation technique that will help us
to identify evaluate our clustering or
unsupervised learning a clustering model
okay clustering
model that will help us uh ideally to
understand to to if evaluate how good
our clustering is okay so let's see how
uh some of some of the evaluation uh
techniques okay so the first one we have
which is called done index okay so the
first one we have is called
d u n
n
index so this is this is a very funny
name but it's disappearing uh you can
still read about in wikipedia page so
it's so let me first write the equation
so d
equals which is a done index equals to
the maximum
maximum of i
and j
means the maximum
should maximum distance between i
and j
divided by
or by
maximum
k
a maximum distance d dash
between k okay so here
what i'm telling here we have this
we have this
intra cluster we have this
intra cluster
here we have maximum inter cluster
distance
maximum
inter-cluster distance
enter clustered distance okay so ideally
it is framing our problem of intra and
enter that our
inter should be small and our interest
should be large okay so here we are not
assuming should be small we are assuming
what is the largest maximum distance
okay so if every everyone is small then
the largest maybe 0.00 like that okay so
maybe something like that will be there
so we are just changing this maximum
okay we have maximum over here just
don't be confused we are telling minim
minimum intra that just ideally means
that you want the distance between inter
cluster to be small so that's why you
are taking the largest whoever the
largest however the have a largest
distance okay so that's why uh so so you
so you can evaluate your model and it's
this this sim this the denominator
simply means that
the the distance between your intra
cluster okay the distance between your
clusters the distance between it should
be ideally large not too much small okay
so that's the that's the end if you if
you've seen if you see if you sense it's
math mathematically you can see that d
should be high d should be high
to be a good good cluster these should
be high okay so this is the evaluation
technique for clustering your model and
i think that you understood done index
so let's recapitulate what we have seen
so far
is we have let me remove this uh let me
let me remove this so we have seen that
we have some of some of the terminology
so we have this small
x and y plane where we have this one two
three four five six
one two three four five six
uh again one more okay so here we have
this the diff the distance between the
the distance between the
the distance
between two clusters the distance
between two clusters
is called as
intracluster means across all the
clusters maybe some cluster will be here
another cluster will be here it's across
all the clusters this is called the
intra cluster
and the distance between within the
cluster within the data points is known
as the inter cluster is known as the
inter cluster and core idea is for any
evaluation matrix of your clustering
model is your intra cluster should be
large
intra cluster should be large
large
and enter clusters should be small okay
so we have that we have talked about
about a done index we have talked about
done index
we have talked about done index and done
index is simply
uh
evaluation matrix so the done index is
written as d
equals to the max
of
the distance between i and j which are
two data points which is obviously inter
cluster which is obviously the first
enumerator
is
inter
cluster
okay and the denominator is simply the
intra cluster where you want the maximum
distance
maximum distance between the
values okay so this this is the basic
definition and you may think here you
should have told about entry inter
cluster should be small but we are
checking the maximum so that we can
evaluate we are checking the what is the
maximum in that cluster that has the
distance so we can evaluate so everyone
should minimum so our d should be high
in that case
okay so i think that you understood done
index also so let's see one more uh
one more evaluation technique which is
for uh clustering which is uh just just
i'm telling you just some some
constraints to be added i i just have
seen the equations just some conditions
to be added in ing where here in i here
in i
i should be
i should be
is greater than i should be greater than
or equals to 1 or it should be
and it should be smaller than or equals
to j and j should be smaller than or
equals to n and n here is the number of
training examples and for k constraints
of k
is your k should be smaller than or
equals to um it's sure it should be at
least a smaller should be uh smaller
than or equals to
n okay so that's the that's the basic
definition of uh
that's that's the basic clock const
constraints but i don't find it's very
uh kind of thing but here just to
understand this the numerator the
numerator is just a maximum interrupt in
inter cluster and here maximum intra
cluster okay and the reason why we we
want to evaluate so that's why we are
taking the maximum so if it is maximum
then it is bad okay so our d index
should be high if you sense it
mathematically okay so another
evaluation technique that that i have
seen so far let me let me go back
actually okay so here i am on my another
thing and let me remove this okay so
another tech technique another technique
is here in front of you
which is the davis baldin index davis
davis
baldin
baldin
index
this is also like a done index what you
want here we denote is that db equals
2
we we take it as a db equals 2
1 over
and
i equals to 1 all the way down to the n
and then you take out the maximum they
go to maximum where j is not equals to i
sigma i plus
sigma j
divided by the distance between
c i and c g okay and this is just like
the clusters and for more information
about what is this you can refer to an
uh do a wikipedia page okay there is the
more deviation etc has been already done
over there okay so that's the devious
balding index but most of most probably
this this this the dawn index used
properly in the country in the whole
except for evaluation of you of your
model so let me highlight it
this one okay so we have seen the
davis board in index now it's time for
uh learning a little bit more in that
about
what the what the approval means what
actually the definitions of what was the
definition of your favorite clustering
okay so one line definition i could tell
about clustering
is in clustering you have and it's a
it's a grouping uh can i write it yeah
it's it's better to write it okay this
bad or better with me or you can write
with me also so a clustering is simply
grouping
grouping
of
objects grouping of objects or elements
objects such that in such a way i could
say in such a way
such a way such such a way
our
our our
object
our object
in a
should be
should be similar
similar to each to the to each group
where it is in
each group
and differ
from another cluster cluster differ
from
another cluster
okay so that's the basic definition
basic definition of clustering and a
very good definition and from clustering
in clustering we have two cases intra
cluster in inter cluster where we want
our intra cluster is the measure of
distance between
um just a distance within the cluster
and inter cluster is difference between
across all the clusters okay so this is
the basic definition of a clustering and
i hope that you understood everything
okay so now we have seen done index we
have seen clustering now it's time for
learning about getting into depth of
clustering
about
types of clustering how many types of
clustering we get in our life and then
we will just after talking about types
of clustering we will end this uh
subsection and in the next section we
will be talking about uh do one
algorithm which is k-means and the next
sub-section we're talking about a
hierarchical clustering which is
agglomerative and diversive clustering
okay so but before that let's uh let's
see some of the types of clustering okay
so the types of clustering which
includes
the types
the types of clustering let me choose it
the color so some some of the types of
clustering are first one is partitional
based clustering
partitional i'm just writing in short
partitional
partitional based approach or clustering
okay so what is partitional based
clustering so assume assume that you
have this uh that you have this x and y
plane and you have this data point like
this and you have this data point like
this okay so what you will do you will
partition it you will partition it into
two clusters and you are done okay so
here we have one algorithm which is
called km means algorithm that we'll
study in our next subsection okay for in
a partitional base approach
then we have hierarchical clustering
high ra recall hierarchical
clustering clustering okay so in these
types of hierarchical clustering we have
like a dendogram if you have seen a
dendogram then you know about a
hierarchical cross string just just just
as a just if you know so let's assume
that you have this data point like this
you have this data point uh let me do it
here that we have this here like this
okay so you have this four points we
have this four points and again you have
p1
p2
p3 p4 and if you're plotted the points
looks like this so these two this p1 and
p2 looks close this p1 and p2 appears
this
uh
p2 and p3 just just assume that this is
a p2 and p3 this this this looks close
so you just cluster it out okay so the
p2 so what you do you just
make an endogram just like this uh that
p2 and p3 are now a cluster which is the
same though which which we can consider
p2 union p3 okay now these are the
two clusters now if you see the closest
structure is this
a p4 so what you will do you will again
make a nested cluster now i would now
this this will look like this and now
what you will do you will attach p4 over
your pp4 as a dendrogram okay and then
what you do then here is this this is
the p1 is the closest then you cover it
and then this whole and this whole now
after that you will be end data being a
dendogram you will be able to see a
dendrogram which you can see over here
so here after which is p1 like this okay
now you can see now we cannot burn
we have a large cluster which we have a
large
uh cluster now we are done this this is
called the traditional van der graan
because you can see on internet about
this so what we have seen so far we have
we have augmentative structure we are
going up means we are uh just we are
going up like this means we have this p1
p2 p3 p4 we are we these are own
clusters by themselves and first these
are their own clusters we have four
clusters over here we have four clusters
now we cluster this p2 and p3 then we
close cluster p3 and p4 because they are
close to each other then we construct p1
to p4 okay so now we got our full
dendrogram okay so that's that is
usually a agglomerative agglomerative
cluster we have something called as
diversif we are in diversif and i'm
talking about in hierarchical clustering
application which is agglomerative and
divisive and divisive we have given p1
uh p2
p2
we have something called as p3 let's
let's assume that that that we have abcd
okay so a it's just it will match if i
do that abcd okay so e let's assume e
also so you divide this okay so what
what what you do you simply you diverge
visit okay like this uh first you divide
a and b
a b as one cluster then you divide c d e
then you have c d e
okay then you divide a and b into
different different clusters so you have
this whole dendrogram like structure
like this now you are uh now you are
this is just opposite of fog glimmer
right here we are just here we are
making up here we are making up here we
are making uh a different different
cluster okay now we do divide our c
then we have a d e now we divide our d
and e now this is our divisive okay so
we divide our whole cluster into
different different groups which are
most closest to each other okay we will
study in detail about this uh in in our
uh next subsection where we will talking
about hierarchical clustering okay after
that we have something known as
after that we have something known as
well separated clusters where it is well
separated clusters okay just just i'm
writing it's well separated means we you
can easily your model can easily uh
separate well separated
well separated
then you have the fourth one which is
center-based which is also k-means
clustering is this center-based
algorithm okay
continuity-based we have something
called as nearest neighbors k nearest
neighbors okay and then we have density
based which is often known as db scan db
scan okay which which you have you will
get in problem set to learn about this
uh db scan okay
great so we have seen a lot about
clustering and i hope that you really
enjoyed this session there's some
sub section of clustering and from the
next section we'll be talking about lots
algorithm or k-means clustering but i
will definitely try to complete in no
time so that you can you could get a
more
more a prone uh
knowledge of clustering and uh able to
make uh unsupervised learning models
okay so let's see so let's see
as just recapitulate what you have seen
so far we have seen what is clustering
clustering is just a grouping of similar
objects in such a way that these objects
are similar to each other within the
cluster or our inter cluster our end to
enter clusters should be different
should be maximum and our intra cluster
should be small and what is the
difference between enter
inter and intra in enter we have the
distance between uh across all the
clusters and that's why we need a
maximum and we have intra in which our
points our points within the cluster
should be minimum okay means more
similar okay other than the other
clusters okay so that's that's the
that's the basic intuition about this
and uh
the clustering then we have seen how we
can evaluate so i have talked about one
index which one evaluation index which
is done index okay and on index it is
used to uh take out the evaluation is
used to evaluate your clustering model
and what is what what is what it does he
it takes out the maximum what is the
maximum in inter cluster what is the
maximum to evaluate the performance
between between two points and it takes
out the maximum of the uh this the the
the denominator is an intra cluster and
a
numerator sorry yeah the denominator is
intra clusters is the numerator is intra
cluster and the denominator is inter
cluster okay and then we have something
called as davis bounding by bolding
block and index this is just it it will
take a lot of time to teach this but
it's out of the boundary course but it's
just here and is the number of clusters
where we have a sigma i plus 6 sigma g
and where i is not equal to j we want
the maximum and then we are taking out
the distance between two clusters and
then we are dividing it up okay so
that's why that's what the
full uh clustering base models is
and now i hope that you understood about
clustering uh now it's time now now it's
time for learning about
now now now it's time to learn about
something new which is in subsection
where we will talk about uh where we
have talked about
four five types of clustering which is
partitional based hierarchical
clustering and well separated and center
based and db scan okay so we will talk
about partitional hierarchical and well
separated is also in center based where
you your prop problem set will be on db
scan okay so here we are done with this
sub-section now in the next section
we'll start talking about k-means till
then have a good day okay so now we have
talked about various things like
clustering we have given a part one in
subsection i've given you unsupervised
learning applications and then we have
talked about various applications of
unsupervised learning and then i've just
given you an overview of clustering in
this first subsection and the next
subsection i've given you the intuition
behind clustering i've given a formal
definition of a clustering we have
talked about inter cluster intra cluster
we had talked about the evaluation
matrix like done index devious balding
in index and i've made you understand
each and every equations and i've
already also helped you to understand
that what are the types of clustering
which are available like partitional
based hierarchical clustering then you
have a center based well separated
density based continuity based okay so
we have this kind of
clustering which are already available
now we will talk about a partitional and
center center based clustering which is
k means algorithm as this example was
taken from andrew non course of machine
learning but he has uh but it's too much
uh 37 years old but i have i have made
it very very updated for 2020 just that
this this example is from andrew nong
okay so
i've also included k means plus plus
algorithm what the k means plus plus
algorithm does and some of the
variations of k means and then also i
have talked about in detail what are the
what are the limitations of k-means
clustering what how we initialize the
centroids what are the time complexity
of k-means clustering okay so then we
have talked about the full machia full
k-means clustering algorithm how we
evaluate our k-means clustering
algorithm okay with the euclidean
distance so that's what we are going to
start talk about just be sure to just
sit sit somewhere and see and take copy
and pen to understand okay but before
that what we are going to study is
k-means clustering algorithm sometimes
so the synonym of came cayman's
clustering is lloyd's algorithm it's
something sometimes called lloyd's it's
sometimes called lawyers
algorithm lots algorithm okay so it may
be some people pronounce it as a lots
algorithm or a k means clustering
algorithm okay but i'd like to pronounce
what k means okay so uh just to just as
as an example we have this uh data set
we have this data set over here
now
what what we do in clustering what we do
in clustering we initialize centroid
which is k okay we initialize centroid
which is denoted by k so here what it is
a hyperparameter so what we are going to
do we are going to initialize k we are
going to initialize k as uh we are going
to initialize k which is two uh two
centroids and centroids is just uh the
the initial you will get to know up with
the visualization so what you do you
initialize with two points onto this so
here you initialize two points like this
the the first point is over here the
first point is over here and the second
point is over here and these are called
the centroids
you will get to know why we call it as a
centroids but these are called the
centroids okay these are called the
centroids and here in this example k is
equals to two because we have taken k
equals to two because uh as we have a
two centroids and and we randomly
initialize these centroids okay so we'll
see the initialization uh just after
some ppts this has some slides okay so
you initialize your model now and now
this is the first iteration now in the
first and first you initialize then what
you do you do the assignment step what
do i mean by assignment step first you
initialize then what you do you do
assignment step like this you assign
all the all the particular values red to
red color and blue to blue color you can
see over here that we have that we have
done red to all the red color which are
closest to this and centroid and this uh
blue we have covered that is all the
centers which are closest to that blue
okay now what what we will do we will
take out the average of these points we
will take out the average of these whole
blue points and then we will take out
the average of this red points and then
what and then what we will do we will
average it we will average it like this
we will average it now after averaging
we will make that percent right to at
average and then what we will do again
we take out the again we do the
assignment step like this we just assign
we we just update our values which are
so closest to this and centroid now you
can see that the blue becomes like this
now then what and then what we will do
we will again move the centroid again we
will take take out the average and move
the centroid like this we will move the
sand centroid and then we will make this
uh red red means so those those are
closest to
blue blue and these are two red okay
then again you do then again you do like
this as a taking of the average and
making the color as blue and red okay
now you can see that you were that what
you have done you have a very good
cluster means you have initialized here
and then you taken out the average then
you move to that centroid and again you
update the updated cluster then again
you move that like that okay so we have
done like that and i i have just shown
you a very good visualizations of this k
main so let's see again in a little bit
more fundamental way
okay so here is our data and then you
can see the data is looks like this so
here what we had done we had in we had
simply initialized two centroids like
this and then what we have done we had
we had just uh make the
make the points which are closer to that
blue to blue and red to that red okay
now you can see over here then what what
we have done we had taken out the
average and then we moved our centroid
to that average okay and how we take out
you do you all know how do we take out
the average you you just take out the
number of observations and then divide
uh or some the num the sum over the
observation divided by the frequency
over the observation you just do that
and then you update and then you again
make the whole uh assignment step and
then what you do then you again up
make take out the average now you again
update the points you can see like this
and then you again take the average you
again make the point says like this okay
and after until and unless your
centroids are not changing you keep
doing this okay so here is informal
algorithm
here is informal algorithm and you can
see over here after seventh iteration it
is not changing so we converged we our
algorithm is converged okay so this is
how whole k-means clustering algorithm
works in visualization so let's see uh
the algorithm in detail okay so what you
do uh first of all here's an algorithm
i'm writing just bear with me but just
bear with my handwriting so i'm just
writing an algorithm so here is my
algorithm with the let's write it with a
red color so uh let me write here is
your
algo a rhythm
algorithm okay so you do for k centroids
k
for centroids okay so you you have to
choose k okay you have to choose k which
is k where is a hyper parameter okay
then you repeat this two process then
you repeat this two process the first
process is cluster assignment
cluster assignment you assign all the
clusters you assign all the cluster you
assign all the cluster and then update
take take out the average and then uh
take out the clusters time you assign
the clusters and then you take out the
average and then you make that point so
you when then you do the updation of a
cluster okay then you up recompute the
centroid okay then you recompute the
centroid okay then you how you how you
recompute the centroid
the centroid it simply means you make
the and you take out the average and
then you assign that cluster okay that
cluster to to to the nearest data point
okay again you have takeout average
until and unless until
you do until you do until uh your uh
your centroid are not changing your
centroid
your centroids your centroids are not
changing are not changing okay where
it's it means that your algorithm is
converged now you don't need okay so you
repeat these two process like clusters
cluster assignment means assign the
cluster with blue or red and then you
update your centroid and take up by
taking out the average and then again
doing doing this taking on the average
again doing this like that okay so this
is the basic algorithm of k-means
clustering algorithm and i hope that you
understood about k-means so let's under
and let's understand a little bit more
we is
a little bit more further into just a
recalculation of k-means k-means
clustering is an algorithm also called
the lloyd's algorithm then we what what
we do so let's go back to our
visualizations
okay so here is our data and what what
we do with into ub randomly we randomly
initialize two centroids okay not every
case just have taken it is a hyper
parameter we have just taken two for
this case okay then what you do then you
do the second step which is uh which
first you do the cluster assignment you
do assign all the cluster with the
closest with the same points in the end
of the cluster then what you do then you
just recompute the centroid by taking
out the average and moving the centroid
okay then you do the cluster assignment
then you assign the cluster like this
then you again move the centroid okay
recompute the centroid then you assign
the like like that and then you take out
the average and again you uh
again you do the same you take out the
average and then move your centroid okay
now now in the next iterations is not
changing now your k-means flush string
is converged now you are done okay so
here's a good algorithm you will be able
to see on the internet the same thing
like first you do you choose key how
many number of key
clusters then you assign the clusters
recompute and then until and unless your
centroids are not are are are not
changing okay so this is whole about
k-means clustering algorithm and i
really really hope that you understood
cayman's clustering algorithm so now
let's see some of the evaluation
techniques of k means clustering
algorithm okay evaluation technique how
do we evaluate our k-means clustering
algorithm so for an example
so for an example here is my example so
for a for an example we are given we are
given
uh no not in foreign example is just a
justice time giving you the optimization
objective so you are given so you are
given
x
d dimensional space dear dimensional
space
as well as k and the clusters which are
this uh and set i think the dictionary
which is not which is in this c1 c2 all
the way down to the ck okay we have k
clusters okay then what you do you want
your uh to optimize c you want to
minimize this cost function you want to
minimize this cost func function now
what you do you take out i equals to 1
all the way around to the k we are k
where
x be the member of c i mean the cluster
now you take out the distance
of x
and c okay you want to minimize this
cluster okay so uh just it it will make
sense don't worry here we have ci which
is equals to the
centroid so let's see let's see what do
what do i mean with this uh distance
between x and c so what we are told that
what what we are told like uh we are we
are told that we have that that we are
given x they dimensional space and we
have clusters which is c1
c2 all the way down to the ck where we
have k clusters now what we have then we
have this equation i equals to 1 all the
way down to the k we are going to until
every clusters where each we are each
x where each x is the member of cluster
means we are this data point is the
member of this cluster okay now you take
out the distance between you take out
the distance between this data point and
this cluster this this cluster okay and
this should be this should be minimized
your distance should be minimal your
distance should be minimal as compared
to this your distance should be minimal
so that's what it is telling over here
okay so i hope that you understood with
the help of a visualization okay so ci
is the centroid okay cluster centroid
okay so how do we take out the distance
for taking out the distance we have
something called as a euclidean distance
euclidean
euclidean for taking out the distance we
have something called you there are a
lot more distances which are already
available you can take a look at it in
online but it's a very used eupledean
distance
so what is euclidean distance in
euclidean distance we have d
uh we have two points p and q okay since
we are doing for each and every point i
equals to 1 all the way down to the n
means number of training training
example qi minus pr
squared okay and it's taking out the
square root of the square root of that
okay so this is the this is the
euclidean distance that just measures
the distance between two points like
this and you can see some more about
this onto the internet how we derive
this equation what is this well who have
found it etcetera etcetera etcetera okay
and sometimes and this this cost
function of k-means clustering is called
is called s s e means sum squared error
sum squared error and you can also see
it is just like the dawn index following
the inter and intra cluster here we want
to minimize our in
our intra cluster over here we want to
minimize our intra cluster we want to
minimize our
intra cluster okay so that's the basic
definition that's the whole thing about
whole story about a k-means clustering
algorithm and i really hope that you
understood k-means and then we have
talked about evaluation techniques for
k-means and
that's it for uh k-means and now we will
talk about why it matters it's the basic
definition of why it matters which the
random initialization as we have seen
that we initialize our centroids these
centroids randomly you can see that we
have initialized randomly so why it
matters how it can cause the problem it
can cause the problem so here we had
just we are just choosing you can see
over here here here over here here that
we have in iteration number one we have
three centroids iteration number two we
take another average compute then we do
the we come we we simply what you're
doing we cluster we assign the cluster
with the same centroid and then we
recompute by taking out the average in
the second iteration then in the third
iteration then the fourth iteration in
the fifth iteration and the sixth
situation you can see over here that uh
we you can easily see that we have a
good cluster over here but you can see
in here that you have adjusted it can
cause how it can cause problem is
iteration number you want you have just
randomly initialized now you can see
whole story changed whole story changed
you can see over here okay so that's the
big problem so that's why we do which is
very not recommended to to choose it
randomly so researchers discussed about
it
these researchers had talked about it
how we can use it how we can make
something good so we researchers found
that uh k means plus plus something well
as k means plus plus algorithm works
best works best
which is very time which i'm going to
tell you okay so kms plus plus algorithm
what it does it simply select
multiple numbers it simply select
multiple numbers as in random we are we
are just taking any random but we select
multiple numbers and select the smallest
error okay so that's that's what the k
means plus plus does it selects
selects
multiple
multiple means is just a it's just a
multiple a sample from the numbers
multiple numbers
and checks and checks
which number which number minimizes
which number minimizes minimizes
the sse the sse which is the which
minimizes the into intra cluster
distance okay so that's the k
means plus plus and it is usually used
in everywhere okay rather rather than
randomly
okay so we have talked about uh why why
we choose importance why we choose um
over uh run why why we choose k means
plus plus over i ran randomly because
maybe it can happen sometimes okay a
very good a very cool god pro if the
luck is not with us it can cause a big
problem and further okay so how we have
to deal with this kind of situations for
dealing with these kind of situations we
have something called as uh k-means plus
plus which will help us today which we
just selects the multiple multipliers
and selects select the one
select the numbers which has a smallest
error okay
okay so
uh let's see uh you may you may think
you may think hey ayush hey ayush how do
we select how many number of a centroid
that we need okay so that's the that's
that's that's also the best uh that's
that's also the big problem so we have
something called as elbow method we have
something called as elbow method
and what it does we have elbow method
like this we have written the k clusters
one two three four five six okay now in
if you if you have taken k equals to one
your error is high
to uh if you've taken k equals to two
your error is going down
like this like an elbow
like an elbow okay so here you can see
the elbow turns around at three so you
select this elbow to select k equals to
three okay so this is your loss this is
the number of okay and this is your loss
which is decreasing sse sse okay so
that's why how we use elbow method
either you can use grits or cv or random
randomized research to student this
parameter i think that will not work
because
we don't have labels but album method
works best when you plot it you know
when you plot and then see what number
of
k you need okay so that's it that's
that's the following and let's revise so
that we are on the same base so what
what we do in k-means clustering
algorithm we choose number of okay using
the elbow method not now just uh just i
choose the randomly and then we plot it
and then then we choose the k and then
what i've done then we repeat a cluster
assignment like we assign all the
clusters with the same clusters then
then we compute the centroid by taking
out the average okay then you uh then
you keep repeating this antenna and
unless your centroids are not changing
and then uh the evaluation technique for
your k-means or loss function for your
k-means is the
you want to minimize your intra-cluster
by just taking out the distance between
two this distance between the
the points between points inside the
cluster okay and then that's called
sum square error and here and you take
out the distance using the equilibrium
distance that just that just take out
the difference between two points by
doing the summation over there okay
great so uh why how how how we choose
the in in how how we choose this cent
centroids okay the initializing of the
centroids for initializing we have seen
seen over here that randomly initialize
can cause a very big problem so that's
why we have something called as k means
plus plus which will help us to select
centroids using what it does it select
it does for multiple runs and checks
where uh and checks the numbers who
where uh the sse is a low okay and how
we select the number of a key we select
the number of okay by using elbow method
where it the elbow is where elbow is
turning around like in as a hand as a
hand if you draw it like this
if you draw it like this if i draw a
hand
over here if you draw it like this
okay so your elbow is there so your loss
is decreasing with k equals to one is
your losses that this this this okay so
you choose the elbow k equals to three
and it works best
okay so we had talked about these things
and now it's time for ending up k-means
clustering the chapter of k-means
clustering which is uh just uh just
ending the topic with our favorite what
are the some of the limitations of
k-means clustering algorithm and what is
the first time complexity so the time
complexity of k-means clustering
algorithm the time complexity the time
complexity of k-means clustering
algorithm if you don't know about from
the if you don't know dsa leave it okay
ignore this
at the time complexity is order is time
complexity the order of
n
times k and n is the input size k k is
the number of clusters i
number of iterations d the dimensions
okay uh this this is our and this is
this this is what the time complexity of
that okay so it's depend because the
time complexity depends upon your size
if you don't know about time complexity
i have one something called as dsa
mastery course uh soon we're putting
putting videos on to that so um first
four lectures are based on time
complexity you can watch that just go
one new where i will just show you where
you can go okay
uh some some of some of the limitations
of k-means clustering algorithm some of
the limitations
of k-means clustering algorithm is it's
it's it's very sensitive to outliers
okay so let's assume that you have this
that that you have this oops like why uh
powerpoint control z does not work i
don't know why
so uh here we draw an x and y plane and
here we have
x here we have
y and let's assume that we have made it
and here we have the outlier here we
have it is closest so it will
take that outlier in that cluster so we
don't want that so it is very prone to
outlier means we have we have to detect
the outlier and it can be solved using
density based uh
even i just don't know what is with what
what's there so it can be solved
outliers problems can be solved using a
db scan which you will have a pro
problem set to solve okay means you you
have to read the wikipedia page uh and
write uh go google docs onto the ddb
scan what you understood okay and then
it's it's it's like different sizes
different distances maybe they're
causing the problem okay but the main
main problem is outlier okay okay says
so we have i have given you the thing
that db scan hierarchical clustering
works on these types of issues okay so
that's it for this k-means clustering
algorithm and where you can uh record
where you can uh find the time
complexity videos and it's very very
recommend uh just it's a very very very
helpful if you subscribe this youtube
channel the newer youtube channel which
you can find um which way which you can
easily is easily find onto the
uh youtube just by writing new era where
i have 500 true subscribers as of now
okay so you can subscribe that and see
the dsm mastery course where we have
more than 23 videos already uploaded a
long lecture so you can learn about time
complexity from that also okay so that's
it for this sub section you will now
have a toolkit of various algorithms
various techniques various things okay
so now let's meet at the next section
where we'll be talking about
hierarchical hybridical clustering i
will give it a sort so that it should
make sense okay so let's meet at the
next sub section okay so now we have
talked about clustering we have talked
about unsupervised learning we have
talked about one of the partitional
based or center-based approach which is
k-means clustering with k means plus
plus algorithm for a random
initialization okay so i hope that you
understood everything in unsupervised
learning and if you have gone so much
further into untube voice learning now
we are capable of learning hierarchical
clustering which is one of the most
favorite uh means one of the most
favorite uh
and the best clustering techniques that
include including partitional based and
then we have a hierarchical clustering
okay so this is the this is this this is
what we are going to do we are going to
start with an introduction to a
hierarchical clustering to help you
better understand what a hierarchical
clustering is then i will go further
into different um just just a quick
recap onto partitional based okay then i
will show you the visual representation
of hierarchical clustering and what's
the dendogram okay and then we will move
further into understanding the two two
types of hierarchical clustering which
is called agglomerative and divisive
okay
so agglomerative clustering and
diversive clustering we will dig dive
into augmentative clustering and we will
just to take a look at the diversif okay
and then we will go further into
understanding the augmentative
clustering algorithm and then we will
see uh then we'll compute that algorithm
manually and then we will see the inter
cluster similarity between our two
points okay but if
if if all the words or technical terms
are going above your mind leave it means
uh
just ignore it the words as of now let's
start
with hierarchical clustering just
introduction to hierarchical clustering
okay so what is hierarchical clustering
hierarchical clustering is that you have
a hierarchy of clusters okay so for an
example what i'm going to do what i'm
going to do is i'm going to take four
points i'm going to take four points p1
uh let's let's not take it here let's
take p1 here p1
then i'm going to take p2
then i'm going to take p3
then i'm going to take p4 okay
for an example i've taken these four
points and now we want to cluster it out
okay now we want to cluster it out so
how do we cluster it so for clustering
so for clustering we have our favorite
means we can simply see okay this
distance is small these are more similar
we are going to do this we are going to
cluster it out like this
and we have this uh p3 and p4 how do we
cluster we cluster this p p one and p
two as real so we cluster we we put
another cluster okay because this
this cluster p1 and p2 is p1 union p2 it
is now a one cluster now
in
nearest the data point nearest point
between or the nearest
these these are their own clusters
initially these are their own clusters
so we are going to merge it okay
so here we have a p1 and p2 now the now
that this is
smallest distance is p4 now we attach
means now we make one more cluster okay
now in this big cluster in this cluster
where we have three points what is the
nearest data point now the nearest state
data point is p3 okay so we'll make
again one cluster again one big cluster
like this until and unless we have one
cluster at uh one one one cluster uh at
a point okay so here we we are ended up
with one cluster okay so it is not
making sense i know but we can um just
just as a diagram i have made this so
let's see how how we do it
using a dendogram that that will make
more sense okay so here we have a p1
here we have a p2 oh oops let me make a
little bit more in good
oops what happens
okay so here we have a p1 let's assume
that we have this is the point p1 this
is a point p2
this is the point p2 and this is the
point p3 and this is the point p4 okay
now these are the points now what we
will do with here you can see we just
assume that just assume that this is p1
p2 p3 and p4 and you can see this p p1
and p2 are smallest so we can make uh we
can attach this we can make a
we can make like this you can attach
this p2 and p3 okay now these are one
plus or p2 and p3 are one cluster which
usually cause p2 union p3 okay now
initially p1 is one cluster c1 p2 is one
cluster c2 p3 c3 and p4 c4 okay so these
are initial clusters now what now what
we'll do now this is the one cluster
which is c2 okay so we've we we
found and
attached it okay now what now what we
will do now the nearest state data point
is p4 over here
okay so what what we will do we'll again
attach p4 into this
we'll again attach p4 now we have now we
have p3 and p4 as one cluster over here
okay now we are now we can attach p1
now we can attach p1
now now we can attach p1 like this
now we can attach p1 and now we have our
dendrogram which is actually a hierarchy
of clusters okay so here we have a
traditional
dendrogram which uh
which which i think that you have all
i've seen in your journey so this is
your hub this is your dendrogram what
you have done you have just who are most
similar you are attached to it okay who
are more similar you attached it for an
example
these are two similar you attached it
and then these this is now what you
attach it like this okay do not merge it
do not merge it okay so you have to do
like this now here we have until unless
we have left with one cluster
okay so that's the basic uh hierarchical
clustering and i hope that you
understood hierarchical clustering the
basic intuition but if not let's let's
try to again understand a little bit
more further into a more sophisticated
way okay not supposed to just just uh
easy way okay so for the example i'm
gonna take a yellow color so here you
have a c1 here you have a c2 here you
have a c3 here you have a c4
okay so this uh this is your c4 now you
can this
c2 and c3 are your points c2 and c3 are
your points okay so these are two more
similar so you will attach this like
this now c4 here he is here so will you
make you so you will make one one more
now pc3 and c4 will be attached like
this and c1 will be attached onto the up
of c4 now this is a traditional
dendrogram this is transferred
traditional then dendrogram where you
convert this cluster of numbers where
you convert cluster of numbers
c1 these the clusters clusters to a
hierarchy of clusters okay so for an
intuition what what what i'm trying to
see you here so i have one example
so for intuition what i'm trying to say
you hear that we have a
c1 c2 c3 c4 now we're just uh making a
attaching as a cluster so c2 union c3
etc
okay so this is the basic intuition
behind hierarchical clustering so there
are two types of hierarchical clustering
uh some of the types are we have some
something called as agglomerative
agglomerative clustering and then we
have
and then we have divisive clustering and
then we have diversif clustering okay so
we will deep to have an agglomerative
clustering i'll just give you an
intuition behind
diversif clustering okay so what is
agglomerative clustering so the
agglomerative clustering
aglo
agglomerative clustering okay so before
that let's understand let's uh let's see
let's uh let's let's unders understand
the divisive clustering to help you
better understand that so it is down to
it is up to down approach sorry it's a
down to up approach it's an
agglomerative is a down to up approach
and diversif is just opposite it's just
a positive
diversif diversif
is just
up to down approach
up to down approach so what do i mean by
this so for an example
for an example let's assume that we have
a four points we have a five points
in the form of data a
b
c
d and e okay so here what to what you
are going to do we are going to divide
this cluster of numbers the cluster of
numbers into a different different
uh a b let's assume that you are divided
with a b now this is your c d e c d e
c d
e as a more similar okay you divided
this now what you will do you will
devise this a and b a
and b now you will divide this
c
c
and
d d e okay
now you will take the d
and e
okay so this is the basic uh this what
what you are doing you are making the
cluster of numbers into separate
separate numbers you are making the
hierarchy of numbers okay hierarchy of
numbers
and this is what you are doing okay so
you're just uh making a di um hierarchy
of numbers and like abcdes you're going
to up to down approach from up to down
approach but in the case but in the case
of but in the case of agglomerative you
are doing something different you are
here you are going up to down up to down
in agglomerative you will take you will
take because in agglomerative you have
cluster one c2 they are unique clusters
means only one cluster so you do merge
it okay you do merge it okay so it is
agglomerative is up to down approach
sorry down to approach down
to up
okay so that's the basic intuition
behind agglomerative and diversif
clustering okay so we'll see in detail
about agglomerative clustering and
diversified clustering to help you
better understand all of these algo ah
agglomerative and diversif but the basic
intuition behind
hierarchical of clustering hierarchy of
clustering is that you have at some
points and what you do you simply you
simply
you simply merge to cluster because
these p1 p2 p3 are before r4 cluster
initially you merge through cluster and
then you have some kind of similarity
matrix okay so you have some some kind
of similarity matrix that we will see
according to that you merge it and then
you make a dendogram or hierarchy of
clusters okay so that's the that's
that's what agglomerative and
acclimative is just down to approach
where you are converting the converting
the clusters into by merging different
different cluster antennas we have one
cluster left at the top like this c1
okay as an example and in diversif you
are actually going
up to down approachment dividing the
cluster into a single single group okay
like a b c d e okay so that's the basic
intuition behind this uh agglomerative
and diversif clustering
okay so let's start with agglomerative
clustering deep dive into agglomerative
clustering to help you better understand
what an algorithm
algo agglomerative
agglomerative clustering does and we
will see a lot more about this okay we
will not see the implementation as of
now we will see in another section where
we now we are now after this i think we
are we have we have completed this
theory part all those thoughts means we
have now have a good knowledge of
everything now what what we will do we
will make a lots of projects okay
so here's an algorithm so first here if
you're so first uh let me let me write
an algorithm
first i will write an algorithm and then
i'll then i will make you understand
with the help of good examples that i've
already listed over here okay okay so
here first what what we will do first
you we compute the proximity matrix we
compute
the proximity matrix proxy
midi matrix that just tells you the
similarity between two points
second we will we will see we will see
we will see just as now it looks like
and then you repeat these two process
then then you repeat this two process
then you repeat this two process merge
merge
two clusters
merge two clusters
and update the cluster update the matrix
update the proximity matrix
proxy
midi matrix okay so that's the basic
that's the that you repeat in a for loop
and then you until and unless until
you have one cluster you have one large
cluster left means until you have left
you have covered all the cluster okay
until you have covered all the cluster
okay
covered
all the cluster or we can say no
clusters are left as a single cluster
okay but this is this is a more formal
definition until you have a good cluster
like as as an example that i've showed
to you okay so this is a basic algorithm
to understand in agglomerative
clustering
now let's understand this in more detail
okay so initially what i've talked about
but i've note here what i'm going to
note here like i'm going to write note
which is each
each cluster or p1 p2 p3 each are its
own cluster now we'll be able to build a
hierarchy of clusters okay so let's uh
let's build uh let's build an
approximating matrix how it looks like
so the approximating matrix looks like
this let's iron let's assume that you
have
p1 p2
p3
p4 okay i'll just assume as an example
now what you do you
you do this
p1 p2
p3 p4 okay
now you do this means this is
approximately matrix this is the
approximate matrix like this
okay okay and these diagonals are zero
these diagonals are zero these diagonal
the diagonals are zero because the
distance between the distance between
the p1 and p2 will be obviously zero the
distance between p1 and p2 maybe some
group 2.4 there is p3 p4 like that so we
have we have written like that p the
distance between p1 p2 and p1 is maybe
something like that diagonal distance
between p2 and p2 is obviously zero okay
so this this is what the basic uh this
is what the basic proximity matrix looks
like so let's see let's see
that how we how we make a dendrogram
okay so here we have p1 p2 p3 p4 now
assume now we will just assume that uh
let's take an example that this uh this
is 4.6 to 4.2 6.9
point two eleven twelve thirteen
fourteen fifteen
sixteen seventeen eighteen okay it's a
zero okay so the distance between p p
four is p four is obviously zero okay so
the p2 we we will find the smallest one
we will find the smallest
similarity here you can see that this
this is the smallest similarity p2 and i
think uh
oops it's a it's a p2 and also i think
that i've not drawn a good mirror i i
will tell you so here let's let's assume
that you have this proximity matrix that
you have this proximally matrix just
just don't take a take a look at this
proximity matrix now what you will do
you will find the smallest similarity so
the smallest similarity so the smallest
similarity over here is
this three here we have three and six
okay so here we have three and six that
we have done first the smallest
similarity okay so that's the that's
that's what we i'm going to do so assume
that this is p1 and p2 has a smallest
now we have now what what now the next
is the next you can find over here is
four means six and four maybe let's see
six
and four which is here okay so we can go
over here also three and four we can see
this three and four also okay so we can
take this three and four like this it's
okay so just assume the next smallest is
p3 and the next volts is p4 okay so now
we have constructed now let's assume c2
p1
p p2 p1 then we have a again maybe some
p3 and p4 now first you do this then you
do this then you make this like this
okay so now we have now now you have the
hierarchy of clusters okay so that's the
basic definition that's the basic
algorithm for proximity matrix okay
and this is what you do and you update
the proximity matrix so how you update
now you merge the merged the cluster now
what you will do p1 union p2 okay p1
union p2 this one will be let's assume
p1 and p2 are attached then p1 union p2
this will be the cluster okay
now let's assume that the 2.7 and these
are
this are similar means this 2.2.7 and
maybe some maybe like that so we can
combine the cluster like that i think
this is not an actual example the bad
example okay but here uh you can you
will you will be seeing one of more one
more comprehensive example okay so how
do we
measure the similarity how do we measure
the similarity of the inter cluster
similarity we can measure the distance
between two plus two points or clusters
these p1 and p2
using maybe euclidean distance euclidean
distance
manhattan distance we have different
different distance similar distance uh
distance measures so how do we measure
the the similarity between two clusters
or enter cluster and inter cluster is
nothing much that that similar the this
is your one cluster and this is another
cluster so what's the distance what the
similarity between to merge it okay so
that's the that's the inter cluster that
we have already talked about in
terminology sessions so let's see so we
have so we have let's uh let's let's
assume that you have this let's assume
that you have this cluster where we have
x this this this this this let's see
another cluster
this this so how do we measure the
similarity how do we measure the
similarity so for measuring the
similarity we have i'm going to talk
about three methods i'm going to talk
about three methods min
and the next method and max the next
method is group average
the next method is grouped average so
let's start with min so what do i'm
doing in min so let's assume that you
have this uh so so you have this data
point like this we have this cluster
you have this cluster now the second
cluster is like this
second cluster is like this okay so what
you do in minimum what you do in minimum
you take out the minimum
first to first i'm just just right
let me write it mathematically to make
it more sense oops what i've done
okay so what you what you have to do
what you have to do
so let's let let me write it
mathematically for minimum so minimum
is is just the similarity between
c1 and c2 which is nothing but equals to
nothing but equals to
minimum minimum of p i
is
member member of c one p i to be the
member of c one let's assume this is c
one so p i may be this point and p j the
another cluster should be the member of
c two now what you will do you will take
out the similarity this the similarity
of pi and pg okay these two
okay these two distance okay now you
take out the distance that you do you
take out the distance i'm writing your
distance and you you take out the
minimum point minimum points who have
mental here you with this the distance
between these two points is minimum as
compared to this point this point this
point okay so we will uh just uh
what what we will do we will simply uh
merge it okay so this is what the basic
minimum minimum approach does it just
takes out the similarity between c1 and
c2 by the taking out a minimum of all
the
i and js by taking on the distance
between all the minimum taking out the
minimum distance of all i and js with
the member of c1 and c2 okay so that's
the that's the minimum so let's see the
basic uh basic thing over here
to understand it little bit further away
and this is this this example is taken
from cs6530
by cluster analysis class lecture notes
this this example okay
so here
here is your proximity matrix here is
your proximity matrix where you have one
as a p1 2 as a p2 like that okay now you
have the here you have approximately
matrix here you have a
proximity matrix now here the distance
between one and one is zero the distance
between one and two is the 0.24 the
distance between one and three and small
point two two two the distance between
one and four is point height 0.37 the
distance between 1 and 5 is like this
and this in the same way diagonal are 0
okay so you can see here the smallest
similarity between or smallest distance
between two points i and j here we are
let's assume this is i and this is j the
smallest distance is point eleven point
eleven and we have three
and six
okay so we merge three and six as a
first cluster okay
now the next now the next
smallest similarity
or the smallest distance is
is uh
this one uh let let me choose yeah this
this one point 14 okay so five and two
okay so this is your next smallest so
now what you will do you will merge it
at the second cluster now what you will
do you will find that this two cluster
this the cluster u and this this p
five five union two
and
uh and three union six finds to be uh
um
has a smallest distance so you merge
with a cluster three
next is you have one you have one and
four now what what you do you this first
you take out the just you just you can
see first you take a first here we have
full
in which this union union and this full
and this four has the smallest distance
so you merge it and then you make a big
cluster again and then you are done okay
so it might make sense it might not make
sense further but i will walk you
through go through this example make the
dendrogram by yourself or necessary
clusters by yourself okay that will make
more sense
the next type of this is max what do i
mean by with max
max is simply
max
it's taking out the similarity
between c1 and c2 which starts with the
maximum which we which we want the
maximum distance
maximum distance between pi and pj and
pi be the member of c one and p j p j be
the member of c
two so that's the that's the basic
definition uh that's the basic of uh
this ends here we are taking the max so
what do i mean by max so here we have an
uh intuitive or a comprehensive example
so here you can see that we have again
the same proximity matrix now you can
see
that the smallest distance is three six
okay you merge it now how you will merge
this four however why why don't don't we
merge with five okay so the distance
between the distance between this five
and two is at maximum it's very large so
obvious this this one obviously will be
minimum so your merger that that's
that's makes sense that's makes sense
obviously okay so this this is what why
you're you you take minimum distance but
for merging you take the maximum you
take out the maximum to merge and here
you have taken the maximum and that's
how and that's how
and that's how all it works and here we
have a maximum here we have a minimum so
you take out a maximum and then you uh
compare and then you take on the minimum
and this is obviously the minimum and
then you and you can see this is the
maximum here and this is the minimum
from here so you merge it okay so this
is the basic and you can see the
dendrogram over here how we made okay
the next type of um
inter cluster similarity measure the
next type of inter cluster similarity
measure is group average what do i mean
by group average
group average so i'm just going to give
you the intuitive uh just um
as a simple equation which is
p i with a member of c 1 and p j where
the member of c 2 p i be the member of c
1 and p j with a member of c 2 you take
out the distance between p i and p j
divided divided by the norm because the
freak frequency divided by the norm of c
one with whatever the number of points
times the i think times the norm of c2
okay
so this is what you have to do i think
it's
it may be plus yeah it may be plus yeah
okay so you take out the norm of what is
the number of points freak frequency
okay so that's what you are going to do
so you can see over here that we have
this dendrogram we have this following
and then what you do you take you group
you group it look for for example you
can see the same thing has been done but
i'm going to take another example to
help you understand this much better
to help you understand this much better
so you have this first
and then you have this
second cluster okay now you have some
points you have some points in here you
have some points in here and some points
in here okay
you take each pair you take each pair
each pair like this you take each pair
okay
okay then you average it out okay and
then you take out the distance you
average it and then here you go okay so
for example here you take out the
minimum distance is three and six and
then you have this four uh then again
you merge it using the and that's what
what we what we were doing but here we
are merging one also the reason being
the average between will it will be
making sense if you sense it
mathematically okay and five and two are
closest okay
so this is what you are doing in group
men and let's see some of the uh some
just this minimum this uh
disadvantage the minimum disadvantage is
it it simply
it is it is sensitive to outliers it is
sensitive to outliers and bad wrath
rather than max is uh will will be less
prone to outliers okay
so that's the basic uh
disadvantage that i've told you and you
can see more onto the cs645 530 cluster
analysis lecture notes to understand it
much better okay
so this is what we are doing and if you
have not understood it is little bit
advanced but it it should make sense
little bit what what we do what we do
and this we have make hierarchy of
clusters like this okay so now we have
talked a lot about hierarchical
clustering and i hope that you really
understood everything you need to know
about hierarchical clustering now what i
will do i will just name some uh now now
what i will do i will name our time
complexity i will and the space
complexity now i'll name one time
complexity and space complexity for
agglomerative clustering just to make
just to make sure everyone is on the
same pace so the space complexity the
space complexity
is order of n square okay because we
have approximate matrix too and time
complexity will be order or maybe
sometimes it's uh order of n q okay but
some sometimes it goes to order of n
square
log
of n
okay so this this is your this is your
space and time complexity to understand
it much better and you can see the
limitations pros cons of these onto the
wikipedia pages they are very well
explained there
okay so we have we are done with
hierarchical clustering and i really
really hope that you understood
everything now we are done with
unsupervised learning now uh we will we
will do a lot of projects and then we
will end up this course and i highly
highly recommend you to do lots of uh
projects also okay and then after
learning this machine learning you can
get go to new era again i'm going to uh
just to now navigate here the url https
uh you can slash
youtube.comera okay so you can find then
uh just just take take take a look at a
newly launched deep learning series okay
from there you can learn uh advanced
machine learning or uh
or deep learning okay
so that's it for this session i'll be uh
so that's it for all this subsection
i'll be catching up your next section
okay so now we will build or start our
last section of this course which is uh
project section and in this section we
will build two projects maybe some more
project but uh initially i plan for two
projects maybe i can add more but you
can surely go to
uh my youtube channel for more projects
buzz but these projects will tell you an
overview of how a machine learning
project would look like and the
motivation for starting you a new
project because it's better to make your
project by yourself just taking the
inspiration from other people okay so in
this project we will build a heart
failure prediction uh
model that will predict whether the
person whether the person will die based
on some of the features or not okay so
this is the problem statement and we
have certain features like age gender
blood pressure smoke whether a person is
smoked or not whether a person have
diabetes or not what is injection
fraction what is the
that's what this is long name which i
can't
pronounce but the this is the this is a
problem statement and you can take a
look at the data uh we're going to take
a look at the data which is available at
this link and i hope that you will uh
understand this project i i have made
i've run step by step to help you
understand everything and as i am made
just i have not worked on this project
so i just want to pick up this heart
failure detection system just to make
sure that i will be making my own
project also and it will be uh and
narrating over through this project okay
so here uh what i'm going to do is what
i'm going to do is i'm going to make a
heart failure detection based on these
features and the target variable of our
which is that that event whether the
particular person died or not so that's
it with the target variable we will see
more about the data but what is the
business objective over here every
machinery problem has some kind of
business objective it simply means
that it's some health care problem means
we'll be able to build a health care we
will be able to build a healthcare in
healthcare something ai and healthcare
which is simply able to make a machine
learning model that will help you in
early detection of the person based on
particular
features and help the person can be
saved so that's why we are going to
build that model to help you better
understand the ai in healthcare we'll be
building one more project which is spam
detection system that is uh whether the
email or messages are spam or not okay
so let's start with this uh notebook and
uh first of all i've divided first of
all i'm going to load the data and sorry
sorry import the libraries so i'm going
to import pandas numpy seaborn
matplotlib and this okay so i will run
it down i will run it out and then i
will load my data
so i don't know why the second time so
now i will load the data and my data
isn't located in the folder of heart
failure data set if you click on data
set click on archive and here is my data
set okay so there i'm going to do i'm
going to just print out head and i want
one more thing that i want to clarify
over here the reason why i'm not writing
or quoting by it here because i i
thought like uh it will be better if i
narrate the code if i if if i'm writing
the code maybe i i forget something or
maybe the code is not annotated too much
so that's a for a few further references
i just took to just write it down over
here and then i'm only going to just add
it over there okay most of them because
because maybe while writing the code i
may forget to narrate some of the code
but yeah let let me know what you like
whether i should write a code or not
okay so i'm going to print it out the
shape of the data i'm going to do the
shape of the data is
29913 which is 13 columns and here we
have
h anemia cretinite false fokiness
diabetes injection fraction hp then
battle it serum then what is the gender
smoking time and that even okay and that
event is our target variable that we
need to detect okay so that's our basic
intuition that's our basic uh data
exploration now what i'm going to do is
we will see how much the data we have
means we will see what's the shape of
the data we have so here we are we are
given the shape of the data which is 299
rows and 13 columns okay
now using a day data dot shape you can
do now i'm going to take a look at the
information about the data you can
calculate or you can take out the
information about the data from the data
the info method and you can if you see
or we hope that it will tell you whether
the particular column has no values what
is the data type and what is the memory
usage and it will also tell you what's
the shape of the data by just taking you
can also take a look at this and you can
see that it starts with zero indexing so
we have 13 columns you can also take a
look at the description it will simply
tell you whoever is the numerical column
uh it it will tell you the describing
means what is the count what is the mean
of the particular column what is the
standard deviation what is the minimum
what is a 25 of that column and 50
percent of that column and 75 percent of
that column and max and that column it
will surely help in the photo means when
if you're a data scientist it will
surely help uh maybe something kind of
uh you are exploring what's the maximum
you can take a look at this you can take
a look at what is the standard deviation
what does it mean maybe you're
formulating some
problem based on machine learning so
it's very helpful this this data frame
you can you can have it spend five
minutes understanding what was this and
it's very easy it will tell you the
count minimum standard deviation etc
okay so what we have seen so far we have
loaded we have imported the libraries we
have loaded the data from my local
directory i'm going to take a look at
the shape of the data and i'm going to
take and i'm going to take a look at
information about the data
okay so here i'm going to data dot info
and that will give me the information
about the data okay then i'm going to
take a look at the description that's
what is the uh well that it will
describe our numerical data and then i'm
going to take a look at what is the
number of unknown values so here uh this
will tell you this this will tell you in
all the columns how many number of null
values are and here we have zero zero
zero no values in each and every column
okay but if you let's say let's say
let's take a second example that you
want no i don't want this i just only
wanted that how many how many numbers so
you can add a sum and then you can run
it out to see how it works so you can
see that we have a total of zero uh no
values okay so this is the basic
exploration uh as i can do about the
data access let's little bit exploration
about the data okay
now the main part will come in
exploratory data analysis when when we
do the so much of eda and a lot more so
we will see over how we do the
exploratory data analysis and here what
do i mean by explorative data analysis
in eda it it does not mean it is a very
very hard but it does not also mean this
is very very easy it's a very very
crucial step in machine learning you
should know your data how it is working
what's the what's the distribution of
the data is your data is balanced you
have certain questions to ask we will
which we'll see over here okay so you
have certain questions to ask to your
data that should your that using maybe
some plots maybe some numbers will see
that and you have to find answers of
your coach of of your company because if
you're a data scientist or data analyst
at some company you should work mostly
on to understanding and finding your
business solutions as i'm a data
scientist at artifact i used to see i
used to work a lot more with the data
i used to work a lot more with the data
because i think that i should be able to
what actually my data is and what the
business objectives are and what's this
what's the answer they want from my data
okay so that's what i do a lot of ted
exploration data analysis there so
that's why i picked up this problem i
found it very interesting and not picked
so much of heart because it should be
conserved like advanced house price
predictor
diabetes prediction system which i
already made which is available in my
github but i want you to try out make
your unique project and showcase on your
resume okay so then what we will do then
we will simply see the distribution of
our classes what do i mean by classes
over here
for this example we have
we have a binary classification problem
and this binary classification problem
we are given one and zero okay so
whether it if if this one then the
person died if it is zero then the
person doesn't uh not die i think i have
to see okay so sometimes yeah so the the
person is leaving is zero and the person
is dead is one so we have two classes
which is a binary classification problem
okay so i'm going to take a look first
what i will do i will take a look at the
distribution of my data and you can see
i'm highlighting the code from where i'm
taking a look at the distribution of my
data and here it simply means that i'm
just going to take that's just just
going to data then bracket i want to
take a look at the event i'm going to
count the number of event where the
event is equal equals to zero and i'm
going to count the same where the event
is equal equals to one by taking out the
length of each alex or cds okay then and
also the pi pi takes an array so i'm
going to put in an arrow like this i'm
going to put in an arrow so let's let me
choose that red color and this uh medium
that works good i'm going to put in
array and then i'm going to just label
it just just to make sure everything is
right so i'm going to label it with
living and data i'm going to
print it out what is the total number of
living cases and what is the total
number of diet cases okay
and then i'm going to plot it out by
just p l t dot pi i'm going to plot it a
pie chart by giving our arr a r r will
contain the length of life and length of
depth like this okay and then labels
will be the same light living and dyed
exploit this is how much to explode
amber and shadow what do you do you want
your shadow yeah sure i want the shadow
so i'm going to run it now so i just
hope that i've run the previously so i'm
going to run it now and you can see over
here that you that's your data is
imbalanced
uh we are actually working out we are
our data is imbalanced data so i will
tell you why why this this data is
imbalanced but first of all what is
first of all if you can see opioid that
we have total of 203 living cases and 96
which is tight cases and makes sense
also because in real world living cases
is more than the death cases i don't
know actually i'm not but i think so
okay so now let's let let me show it to
you in particular to help you get a feel
that uh what is imbalanced data okay
oops what is not working
what is imbalanced data so imbalanced
data means let's take an example that
you have two classes for example here we
have two classes living
and that okay
so you have more examples of living
which is here two or three like 203
examples but you have a far lesser two
times lesser the lesser than examples of
96 okay so here you were actually
working on a balance data what what can
be the issue of this issue of this can
be that your model and most of the model
is most trained onto this living so
you're uh you can assume that you're
that the output of
the most of the output of your model
will be zero rather than one in some
cases that will print one but it will in
most of the cases it will be zero okay
so here uh we have some examples so
maybe it can but your model is more
prone to train under 203 and your model
may maybe get biased towards some
problem means your model and can be like
this print
zero your model is this this model and
it's only printing zero at every time so
this happens when you have for one cases
you have two on the let's take an
example that you have a 400 examples so
for one cases you have three nine nine
examples and only one example for
for death okay so that is causing that
will cause the problem okay a big
problem this is a big problem which
comes as a
something called as which was starting
in deep learning which is working with
imbalanced data okay so this this is
what i'm going to highlight that just i
just want to take a little take a take
take take my answer is my data is
imbalanced how much examples for each
case do i have so i answered my question
that we are actually working we are
actually working on imbalanced data
which is actually working here on
imbalanced data where we have a living
cases equals to 203 and diet cases
equals to 96. so imbalance simply means
that your classes that your classes are
not equally distributed are not equally
distributed so can i write it out um
yeah so let's write the definition so
i'm just going to comment it out just to
imbalance means imbalance means
that your data
is your data is
not equally
uh distributed between classes
distributed between classes between
classes okay so uh it may happen that
if in balanced data our data is equally
distributed so for an example for a
particular example so for example let's
say you have a training length maybe 400
so if you have a training length to be
the 400 so assume so assume 200 is for
death examples 200 is for live example
so we have we have equal number of
examples in both living
and
death cases
death
cases okay so this is this is an example
of balanced data and our model works
best here okay
this is more robust it is not biased
towards anything okay so this is the
basic uh this is this this is this is
our first sticks for which we didn't
also take take another reference so what
what we have done so far we have simply
taken we have simply uh drawn some eda
from here by taking out the length and
taking out the length of each event for
a zero and one and then then i put in an
array and then i'm gonna then i have
labels which is living in dots and
printed something and then i'm gonna
plot the pie chart with that this this
this this this explode comes with
explode and shadow we want the shadow so
you might be seeing the shadow over here
okay and you can see that what the
inference so i answered my question am i
working on imbalanced data
yes
how much here okay two times just an
approximate so our thigh face is two
times lesser than the living cases or we
can put in a percentage by just dividing
it out by just dividing it down to the
total length of our data okay so you can
you can take you can try it out more
mathematically but this is what i'm
going to show you to you about this
informants okay let's move on to the
next inference in the next since we
enter influence i wanted to take a look
at the distribution of our age
uh this this this will tell you whether
your data is when what range most of
your uh most of them the central
tendency i think that is that is here
the mean the most of the cases most of
the edges like from 40 to 95 okay most
of the cases 40 to 95 examples examples
are starting from
40 to 95 95 and then you can see most of
the cases are in around 16 okay and
around 60 with some standard deviation
okay so this is the distribution of your
data you can try out for different
different you can try out for definitely
for different different uh
numbers which i've already shown to you
there are a lot more numbers you can
definitely try it out okay make a pie
chart for class
for binary columns like high blood
pressure
it was or not or maybe gender make that
column and see if it works so i will
show you how to filter out the columns
from there okay so now we have seen the
distribution of our data so now what i
want i just want to check so maybe my
business objective is maybe my my my
lead told to me hey uh if your data your
data dashboard like this should be
answering lots of questions should be
answering lots of your questions about
the data okay so here the answer that
you're working on this data means the
total number of type cases is less than
the living cases okay which is two times
less than the typically living cases
okay so that's the that's the that's how
you do and here you can see you can say
to your stakeholder or whatever the lead
that most of the a most of the age rise
from 40 to 95 okay so you can see from
this and c and you can tell most of the
cases fly around from 50 to 70 like that
okay that is the distribution of a data
so now say that you wanted to check you
wanted to check
select you want to select the columns
that are above age 50 and see they're
dyed or not again a very good secret it
sql query forum but maybe you just just
think about what you want to do in
pandas or you want to do it like that
okay so it is possible and seek well but
not i i just as an example yeah i've
made in a python okay so what i'm going
to do my business objective is select
the columns select the columns
sorry number of examples i think that i
do you know
select rows that are above age 50 and
seeing that
they are died or not so here what i'm
going to do i i want the death event i
want the death even because i don't want
any any column with the death even whose
age is above or equals to 50 and
they are living okay and then again the
same thing and then again i'm going to
take out the length of the same as above
i'm
okay so if you've been if if i run this
you can again see you can see here that
here we have living cases here here we
have the living cases a lot and you have
a small but you can see the diet cases
diet cases so if
if i write it out i just want to write
it out like this so oops i'm going to
write a total number of
total uh total number of
it's a diet cases diet cases i'm going
to take out the length
length of diet
length of that i'm going to
do for
total number of
total
number of
non-diet cases not diet cases
just i'm not able to write because i
have two taps in front of me it's very
difficult for me to dabble
right over here okay so here length not
died okay so here if you can see that
you can you are able to see that we have
total number of right because 85 and
total number of not at 167. so just see
over here that in total in total we have
203 which is two times lesser than and
here this is fairly one times less than
that okay so here you can see that most
of the cases again died but most of the
cases over 50 died okay as comparatively
to
our plot
maybe not not making sense but
again i'm sorry going to say that assume
that just let's listen to what i'm
saying i'm saying like you can see that
um in our work plot we have total number
of our diet cases in two times our diet
cases our diet cases is two times lesser
is two times lesser than our living
cases and here our diet cases is one
times lesser than not diet cases so here
you can we can see obviously this is low
but here you can see most of the people
that are of always 50 died okay from
this inference comparatively from the
upper plot okay so here that's how we
answer the questions from the data and i
hope that you understood everything and
i think that you will be
taking out more influence okay great so
let's see one one more one more uh
column which is very fairly good column
which i think oops get out
i'm just going to yeah here it is oops
yeah here it is okay so now now just
assume that you want the columns that
are available 50 and you'll see whether
they are died or not i think that i have
already already okay so you want that
that there are above age 50 oops i think
this is uh this is for diabetes so yeah
so what you have to see
you have to see you have to answer the
question that the person is having
diabetes that a person is having
diabetes how many numbers
how many numbers of patients who are
diet are having diabetes and how many
numbers a patient this dog dies
their dead non-diets having diabetes
okay so diabetes isn't um
where the person is not having diabetes
and having diabetes okay
so maybe i've done a little bit wrong
over here the diabetes should be there
the diabetes should be there and we have
to see whether the person had died or
not okay so you can see diet with
diabetes is this and not that with that
diabetes is this so there are a lot more
but you can again compare with the other
plot over here
then it will start making more sense
okay so we have done extensive data
exploration data analysis a lot more can
be done to answer a particular business
problem like this you can see over here
you can answer some more questions from
the data but as to give you a taste of
this how i do how i like to do the
answer the problem using my favorite
visualizations okay so you can answer
this uh it's it's very good to answer
this all uh by just uh visualizing it
out and saying to the lead okay so now
now we have seen a lot more things we
have seen that more of the visualization
just don't worry about this the these
are again in the course website mlo one
dot native app it's a very very uh easy
easy to get all these notebooks
okay so now you will check the
correlation of our variable so what did
i mean by
take checking the correlation of our
variables it simply means that you'll do
that how your how your features how your
features are correlated so here you have
a very good reference i have taken from
the style they they have explained very
much extensively every some online so
here was telling
it shows the correlation between
variables on each axis and uh it's
means this just shows that
i will give you the uh plot over here
but what is char what it does it simply
shows you the correlation ranges from
minus one to plus one okay minus one to
plus one it simply means that if your
variable is closer to minus one then is
a very very similar okay if your is is
very very similar so you can see value
closer to zero means there is a no
linear transmission lean linear thing is
not there so you can you can't use
linear regression over there between two
variables means we can each this
correlation tell us whether your data is
a linear or not and the close to one the
correlation is more positively
correlated okay more positive means
correlation will empty correlation
between these two and you can read about
pearson correlation for your efficient
topic you're going to just use something
kind of that okay
that is one increase so that the other
and close to
close to one to the strongest this
relationship is means the
the one is closer to one the stronger
the relationship is the diagonals are
all
one that simply indicates that the
squares are correlating with each
variable to itself so it's a perfect
correlation so if you have all the data
all the all the all the diagonals of one
so the perfect sign of perfect
correlation and the plot is also
symmetrical and i know that you know
about symmetrical
so you can see over here but i'm going
to just uh
put it in a form of this
i just hope that i'm going to put it
like this
okay so i'm going to run it out and here
you can see that our data is perfect for
relation more the dark is minus 5.3 like
that
is the more correlated okay so you can
read that it's very io explain and also
you can do the same as your like if you
want to do it with the panas so here you
are going to do and your diagonals are
again one etc okay
so we have done talked about various
things you have under understand data
and etc etc everything okay so now i
hope that you got an idea about how you
process so now what i will do i will
start with data set development as i've
talked about that you should devalue
your data into training or testing set
because for testing you have to check
some you have to you you don't have real
examples so for validating your model
works best so what you will do you will
divide your data and do validation
segments training and validation set
where you are dividing 70 30 okay so 70
for training and 30 percent for testing
okay so you can run this out we are
using the escalant api uh from while
importing the trainer split
okay so now we have done this and i hope
that you understood this also so now we
will do now we will i will not do future
engineering over here but uh i will just
showcase to you what's the what's
what we do just a one example of feature
in january okay so in featured
engineering we add more features we
encode our variable we encode our
categorical variables we apply some
transformations on our data just to
insert our feature okay so here is an
example of adding the feature okay so
here what would here what what we are
doing we are adding the interaction term
okay so what is interaction term
interaction terms means
interaction terms means let's for a
foreign sake of example assume that you
have this data set this data set which
is
gender
and age okay for an example so it will
add again one new problem by taking out
the product of g z and uh not let's take
a bp okay and we think means in
numerical so it will take the product
and add okay so it is just doing the
product of two features and making that
call okay so maybe that that will not
make sense but this is what the
interaction term means means we are just
adding the product of two features okay
so
here is our function for that so first
of all we are taking the columns names
then we are taking the length because we
have to see we have to iterate through
um and then i'm going to copy it out so
that we can change anything to x and i'm
going to um
just iterate through all the columns and
i column represent the represent of
first column and this feature i name
that this uh there is this this column
i'm going to ask
access using the x and then i'm going to
range through j because i want to
multiply these two so here again the
same thing and again i'm going to take
out the data and we'll do is just to
make it this to just show the name of
the column like this that that we
multiplied and actually you're
multiplying this out and then we are
returning the x end okay so this is what
and then we are calling on x train and x
test and we are done okay
so here if you run it out now you can
see if if if i show you the code if i
show you the x-wing mod
x train mod
do i run it
yep
let me run it again
you can see that we have 78 columns we
have 78 columns from your 30 or 13
columns to 78 columns you can try the
result how it is working and let me know
in the comment box below on our on in
our desktop community okay so this is
what what we are doing and by adding the
interaction term we are feel free to
explore more okay now what we'll do we
will now we'll start building our model
so how do we build just just we will
start building our model so first i'm
going to make a model for evaluating our
model so first i will take a look at the
accuracy precision recall and confusion
matrix so again if i run it over here
now now it will give and we are giving
the ground through as well as our
predictive okay first of all i will
start with legislative question with max
iteration to be 1000 the reason why i
have given over here because if you it
is not converging it is not converging
with any solver so for converging if you
run it down you can see that lbgs fail
to converge what you can do you can
increase the number of iterations or or
what do what you can do you can simply
you can simply uh
scale your data maybe my data is not
scaled so increase to the iterations 2
000 and it worked okay but it is also
telling a process to standardize your
data or to scale your data so here for
standardizing as well as the building
the model so we have something called
this make pipeline so what what it will
do for any coming example is to
standalyze and then it will uh and then
we and then it will apply legislation
over there okay so we are we are just
doing in a small number of and you can
compare the result of the
standardization and that max iteration
so the accuracy is actually better
actually better precision is also better
recall is also better and this is also
better okay confusion matrix
okay so i hope that you watch my session
on pre-season a recall but let's uh let
me show you what those precision and
recall confusion matrix means so maybe i
have the
this stochastic gradient reset yeah so
we just just just want to make sure that
you are on the same base okay so
here i'm going to highlight one
algorithm which is
optimization algorithm which is same as
our favorite gradient decent but here in
gradient decent what we were doing it
just takes it is taking a lot of time
white is taking a lot of time so here
assume this this example assume this
example i'm going to narrow it over here
that
let's assume that you have a 10 000 data
points 10 000 data points 10 10 000 data
points and we have 10 features okay so
here you have 10 features and the
residuals consist of as many terms as
their data points so you have 10 000
residuals because we are taking the
difference between your predicted and
now model predictive model output value
so you have around ten thousand term in
our case residuals so we need to compute
the derivative of the ten thousand term
you need to compute the third period of
a ten ten thousand term with respect to
our features which is ten thousand times
ten which is one lakh computation per
iteration that is so so much high okay
so that's why we have some something
called as stochastic gradient adjacent
so what what we do so what could we do
in stochastic gradient descent this we
choose simply us the same thing happens
we repeat until analytics our
approximation is minimized and then we
randomly shuffle and then we do at each
step it means we at at one year step so
we don't update we do updation as well
as the derivation at each step and we
are doing for each training examples for
each
training examples okay so it um you it
is a little bit out of course it is
usually thoughts and
maybe an uh
deep learning but i would highly
recommend to learn this is just equal
equals to the
batch gradient decent okay so you will
be able to see what's the difference
okay so now as
i've talked to you that we have
something called as pre-season recall
accuracy so we have not talked about
that so let's talk about i'll just spend
a little bit of amount of time onto that
so here tp means true positive means
true positive means that your outcome
that your outcome
is
that you that your moral outcome
correctly predicts the positive class
okay so you have in in any model you
have two positive and negative classes
positive
negative classes positive like zero is a
positive m one is a negative it'll be
positive so your model predicts the same
output as your ground through okay in a
positive end for a positive class true
negative is where the where your model
predicted one and your output is also
one and true positive means zero and
zero these are positive plus and these
are negative plus okay
here you have false positive which is
your model incorrectly your model
predicted your model predicted your zero
and actually the output is one so it is
false positive means positive and false
because they are not matching
false negative is just the it's your
moral your your moral predicted you're
more predicted wrongly okay so you're
more predictive one and your output is
actually zero means negative and
positive class
okay so that's the that's that's the
true positive negative and confusion
matrix is simply like this first we have
a true positive
false negative
false positive and true negative that we
have just seen it will tell you how many
number of are correctly classified as up
in a positive class in a negative class
in a in a but in the modern model
field and a positive class with a
moderate fail and this is a true
negative where the model actually worked
okay so you can see that we will we have
seen okay so precedes and recall as we
have talked about precision and recall
a number of a true positive divided by
the number of a troop or was divided by
the number of a true positive plus the
number of a false positive so true
positives t p
plot by three t p divided by the number
of a true positive plus the number of a
false positive okay so this is your
output this is your output of the
precision and simply answer the question
what proportion of positive indications
was actually correct okay so it answered
what proportion so here we have 0.73
which is actually a good proportion but
we had it can be improved the equal
answer is the question what proportion
of actual positive was identified
correctly okay okay so it will tell you
that what is the proportion of actual
positives was identified
correctly okay so this is the
recall of our model okay so now we will
see
now we will see uh just just we will to
see the that that the every season we
call
confusion matrix etc okay so now we will
see now we have built our legislation
with some standardization now we'll
build a support vector classifier with a
grid search cv with extensive fine
tuning we have c which is lambda which
is which which controls the width of
that margin so we'll try different
differences zero point one one ten
hundred one thousand gamma one zero
point one zero point one zero zero point
one and kernel to be rbf kernel and then
i will call the grid source to
instantiate with the svc classifier ram
grid reference to verbals equal to three
it will i'm going to fit it it will try
for each and every and checks like score
and this is what here and this is what
the thing is they have done where they
have checked and you can find out the
best parameter that the model found
where c equals to 10 and gamma equals
0.01
you can see it's far performs a little
bit less with uh compared to logistic
progression but it worked okay
so we have done with earlier we are done
with the support bitter vector
classifier as well as logistic
regression classifier now what we will
do we will do uh this we will we will
make a decision a tree classifier okay
so what i mean by decision tree
classifier is i'm going to import the
true as that we've already talked in
detail i'm going to import a randomized
research we have talked about grid
search randomized research is same so
i'm going to define a function that
takes the parameters take some how many
runs to clf what the classifier to use
okay
then we will
then we'll call a randomized on clf
which will give the clf which is
classification number of iterations etc
then if fit it then then you'll find the
best parameter then we find the best
score and then we'll say this and this
this is just a custom-made model but you
can surely remove that and just use that
randomized search and then put all these
so i have already done in some of my
projects i've just taken out from there
and it's working great okay so i'm gonna
it will tell which is the best which
criterion is the best whether again drop
your guinea a splitter or main weight is
i have done a lot of uh fine tuning okay
i will run it it will take a little bit
amount of time trying all the values and
checking the score and you can see the
training score is it 0.84 and the test
score is
0.75 okay now we'll run this classifier
with the same uh with these uh features
okay so it it will give me the output
like this now i will oops now i will run
it out maybe you can you can see okay so
you can see how it how well it is
performing maybe i have not let's see
the best score randomized to search best
score okay
uh maybe uh yeah so that's that's the
basic and you can also try it out maybe
i'm a little bit uh you can see uh
let's see if it is it is not good or not
oops
i have to also show okay so it is
showing the best classifier so i have to
put it over here i don't know why i put
it over here but
what i have put it now in when what mine
but i will let me put it
okay let's run it it's actually 0.75 so
i've lit i have obviously done some fine
tuning and here what i got that's with a
good parameter okay so it's not always
oh this works best in some of the cases
it worked okay so now with the service
little bit of fine tuning i'm going to
call a random forest specifier then i'm
going to run it with this with a with a
parameter stack that we got with the
random forest okay it will evaluate my
model and then 0.86 0.1 actually good
okay now what we'll do we will use
xgboost okay xg boost is another we have
talked about we're learning with 0.1 max
step what is the number of parameters
then i'm going to put evaluation set
into one uh
array okay so just uh just just see the
log loss at the same time and then i'm
gonna run it so it will tell at the log
loss of the zero iteration and zero
point hard to do is the log loss
validation loss okay now we will
evaluate and here again 0.85 is more
robust model okay it is a robust model
if you if you can see the importance
it will show what features are more
important so time is very important
injection is very important so in this
way you can select you can discriminate
maybe smoking anemia sex creator dying
and then means these these three you can
remove as a future selection okay the
last in that test we are going to uh use
is a gradient boosting classifier
gradient boosting is mostly used in a
cases of
images but let's see it how well it
works with these hyper parameters you
can also fine tune it to get better
results than me and it actually worked
okay now what i will do i will i will
save my xg boost model because eddie
boost is more robust so i will save my
model by just calling for job lib job
lift up dump i'm going to load my job if
you can see if i run it now you can see
that zero zero one and you can see if i
go over here if i go over my heart
failure and model.pkl file and you can
load this model.pkl file to make a good
model okay so that's the that's our
that's a basic thing that we need to
understand about um that test we need to
understand about uh this
hurt failure detection system and i hope
that you have understood a lot from this
okay so thank you for uh seeing uh this
section and i really hope that you
enjoyed this and we have covered this
project in 42 minutes
in the next project we will be talking
about a small project spam detector
system which is again a very cool
project which is understanding problem
statement and building a good model okay
so let's meet at the next project then
have a good day so now we'll talk about
or we will make one project which is
spam and hand detector system so if you
have seen your
gmail uh or google gmail or microsoft
outlook there you are seeing that they
are maybe where you have a tab which is
spam tab they're your spam emails are
there so in the same way we are going to
build a spam and ham detector system so
spam means means that uh that a
particular message may be corrupt and
ham means not a spam just oppose it to
spam okay so just uh ham means not a
spam i don't know why does not work for
the first time not a spam
okay and here you can see that that text
we have a label means uh we are given a
message we are given a message and we
are given the target label which is our
why okay so this this is our this is our
message maybe go until journey point
crazy and then you and there is a label
which is given over there okay and this
data set is downloaded
this data set is down downloaded from
uci repository and here is our data data
set so it is in table so i'm not going
to use csv i'm going to use table to
read that i'm going to separate by a tab
header should be none and the names of
the columns should be labeled and
messages
okay so let's take a look at we will
take a look at the first few uh
data points so let me run this out first
of all this and then this
and then i'm going to show you one of
the messages there so it should start
making sense to you
so here
data oops what happened
data and this is the messages
it will take a little bit of time
then zero position so you can see that
go until journey point crazy available
etc etc and here it says that is a ham
that means not a spam so for a for
example let's assume this second number
because in second number we have it
labeled at the span so free entry it's
looking like a spam like it's free entry
or where now like that
okay
so that is the that's that's the basic
uh that's the basic exploration of our
data and this is downloaded from uci
repository okay so i think that you that
you understood we are given a corporate
for test so here we are not given any
numbers here we and we are given here we
are not given any number we are given
oops what happened what is happening we
are given a messages which is x as our
messages which is in text format so your
neural network argument sorry machine
learning model does not work with text
so you have to convert the text into
numbers so we will see some of our
favorite text
text a vectorizer to convert this corpus
of a test into a matrix or a vector or a
number of a vector we will see that we
will see that okay
so here you can see that uh what here we
are given a data which is text and
there's one and then we have a label
okay so now we will see now we'll start
exploring our data set so now we have
got our problem statement that we are
given a part with our text we are given
a text and we need to formative password
or pipeline and give it to your output
whether it is a ham
or a spam or hammond zero and spam means
one okay so that's that's that that's
the our favorite uh
given now we will move forward now now
we'll move forward into exploring our
data so i've already explored it so let
me rerun it again so here i hope that
you all are able to see this
so maybe even if you're not don't don't
worry i will just we're going to take a
look at a shape of the data which is 5
72 572
with two columns and then we have a no
values to be zero because we don't have
any no values we have two infos and here
which is a count unique values uh what
is the frequency and etcetera and
obviously they're in the text we do you
don't have numerical things so that's
why
it's it's empty okay
great so we explored the data very much
now it's time to again start with
explorer
exploratory data analysis okay so in
explorative data analysis we in the in
our previous project we have seen that
we have seen that we have to see the
distribution we have to see uh the
distribution
we have to see the distribution of the
classes okay so here we are seeing the
distribution of the classes by just
taking out the length and converting
that into a length now now here you can
see the labels which is hammer spam and
it will tell what is the number of total
labels with the plotting the pie chart
and you can see over here that the
number of
ham examples is 4
825
and spam examples at 747
so we are actually working on imbalanced
we are actually working on imbalanced
data so your model will learn a more
about tam rather than spam okay so be
sure to keep that in mind
next we will uh now it's it's very very
important like uh for an example so
let's uh let's understand the processing
of our text how how we clean our text
and why it is why it is there a lot more
need so
why do i mean like what do i mean by
cleaning is for an example let's assume
that you have a
go
okay so you have go oops
go okay small g i don't know why it is
not working again
i like okay so here you have go
here you have go okay it says best place
small oh okay so
these two will be considered different
these two will be considered different
but this is the same these two will can
will be considered different but this is
uh this is the same or maybe
this hashtag does not need any sense
over here so why do we need hashtag over
here maybe we don't need like this we
don't need emerges but here but in some
cases like in sentiment analysis emojis
plays an important role but here we are
go and go are the similar thing maybe
here we have a
here we have a
these these need if we if he gives to a
model these two will be considered
differently so that's that's not a good
thing so what we will do we will convert
all our text into lower text okay now
here we are doing some text
pre-processing that that you need to
know okay just uh just using re okay
rejects okay so i'm going to replace
here and i'll be given one simple
message i'll be given one simple message
first of all okay i'm going to first
lower it down by converting that into a
string then i'm going to replace this
this zero if there is any zeros in the
text will be replaced by m okay and this
this three will be replaced by k and k
is thousand k or hundred k or what
whatever
this uh
this comma will be replaced by this
sorry uh above i i'm not recalling
what's the name and except sorry uh
it's uh it's uh i'm not recalling but
yeah you can see okay so then you have
won't will be here it will be considered
different so will not okay can not
should be can not
can't should be cannot okay he
uh we have we are just doing n not
equals not what's what is is it's it is
that his he is she is she is
s own percentage then etc and then your
l will okay so this is the this is the
basic text preprocessing that i've done
over here but one thing that i can also
do over here one thing that i can also
do over here like for stemming stemming
okay
stemming
limitization
limitization limitization so i would
like you to explore this i would like to
you to explore both of them in
implementation okay and uh why what
first of all let let me tell you what is
stemming okay so stemming it simply
means and it's it's in stemming it
simply means that
for an example for an example so if i go
to some website let's take an example
that i
write play that i write play
i write
p-l-a-y-e-d
then i write player
okay so it will it will the stemming
will give play and these three quotes
can become will will be converted to
this single word because they make a
similar sense okay so that's the
stemming and limitization is just a
bigger version of that it it makes a
meaningful some sometimes stemming does
not make a meaningful word so for making
a meaningful word we have lemmetization
but again laminization what is just so
for example place plays plates played
and players
so it will convert in play and the the
stemming will convert in pla okay so it
does not make sense but this limitation
is making sense after we levitize our
work
word or we convert our corporates of a
word into a single word okay so that's
the seminal limitation but i want you to
explore stemming the word stemming
limitization using nltga library you can
refer to some of my github i've already
done that but i want you to do this okay
so otherwise you know no tasks will be
left for you in this task okay so here
what then what then what we'll do then
you apply to each messages by making a
new column you apply each messages these
text pre-processing by doing this all by
calling the lambda and
calling the laminate will go through
each step will it it will it will go to
each step and apply the function onto
each messages and put that into a
processed text so let's take an example
of that it
will start making more sense if you take
a little bit of example
okay so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to print out i'm going to print
out not first which will be our favorite
uh not processor text so i'm going to
print out first which is not processed
text so these are data and then i'm not
going to i'm going to post a video now i
want to zero element and now i'm going
to
make a simple line i'm going to make a
simple line oops what happened i'm going
to make a simple line so it's just mix
this
and i'm not and then i'm going to just
paste it over like this okay so it will
show you what is the pre-process text so
this pre-processed text is converted
like this okay so apply stemming okay by
using the porter stemmer you can go to
nlp and ltk stamic nltk
okay there is something called it's
limitization so you can see some of the
tutorials which are available in
geeks4geeks etc so
read it out means you can go to any of
them whatever you like it's just
converts the words into uh yeah here is
a good example so playing play play so
it will come common root from play okay
so this will convert it like this like
stemming is the process of reducing your
inflection into words okay so you can
read this read this sound this is a very
good documentation provided by their
camp
and you will get to know much better
about this but i will be bringing up one
full course onto national language
processing justice is a sample how do we
work with the text but
on new era on new era when full course
on deep learning where we'll be talking
on deep learning we'll cover text
working with the textual data okay
now we'll go further into now i'll go
further into feature engineering what is
feature engineering here we are not
going to add any features we're just
going to encode our hand to zero and
expand to one by calling our map method
then it's done now we'll divide up a
data into train this split now if i run
it here you have total number of this
and then and then we and then what and
then what what we will do now just
assume now just see now just see over
here that in training set in training
set
we have our text but
neural machine learning will not accept
the string or whatever the textual data
so what we have to do there is modern
means word embeddings then we convert
our word and then we convert our word
into maybe this word into some numbers
into some numbers into some numbers
there are a lot more techniques
count vectorizer tf idf vectorizer bag
of words which i'm not going to again
talk about again it's time for you to
explore as of now you can just think of
it as you can see there you go you can
see that what's the mathematical
equation for that is a single
mathematical equation but is what it
does is simply you can go to usq learn
feature extraction just extract the
features from the text which converts
your
text into the numbers okay by just we
instantiate over here now now with now
what it it will do it will fit the
training data means android return the
matrix and then
we don't want to fit the text test
testing so that's why we are just
transforming our uh text stress to the
numerical into the matrix okay that's it
okay so this is what we've used to
convert our
uh
text into on vector of numbers okay so
if i show you the training data how's
the training data is a sparse matrix
okay
it's a sparse matrix which is with five
thousand fifty five thousand two hundred
and nine stored elements into that okay
now we will use nine base i hope that
you understood and i hope that you had a
look we're on nine days uh on this as
you have told to do the assignment so
you hope that you had a look at night
base you can read more about knife base
this is just a very simple as we talked
about some other learning algorithm it's
very very simple okay so you may run
this and then you just
call color protect and here you have
accuracy so now let's uh let's give up
corpus vertex so let's take and let's
stick and take an example here you have
a text
here you have a text and i'm going to
write a y usage is a good boy i think
let's see if it is a spam or not spam
okay so i'm gonna just want to convert
that this it
in in production what we do we write a
function process we write the function
we'll take a text as an input then what
it will do we we instead we call our
account vectorizer which
which we call over here so i'm going to
call my count vectorizer like this count
vector
dot to transform i'm going to transform
my text giving uh giving
giving this
i'm going to do this num okay so it will
contain the basis of vectors now i'm
going to just call my model which is
maybe it will take a model so i'm going
to call my model which is here
nine days and then it will simply dot
predict now it will simply predict my
txt okay and then i'm going to oops it's
num na i'm just convert that into a noun
so it's the prediction i'm going to use
the prediction
and then what i'm going to do i'm going
to read her the prediction okay so here
if you call pre-process and then
pre-process and predict so it will be it
will take text as an input and it will
return maybe it's maybe uh some problem
maybe i have to do convector that fit
transform
what happened
pre-process iterable over raw documents
a string object received
okay no worries
so maybe
what's the problem was causing is
is i'm given this messages and instead
of this pre-process but we need to give
the process takes instead of messages so
here we are given the messages now we
are just going to providing the series
and then i'm going to do count vector
transform
uh giving this talk and then providing
naive bayes dot predict and this this
this this will predict whether that it
will it is a spam or a non-spam
okay so that's the basic uh
spam and ham detector system obviously
you can try more stacking various
various things so we hope just to give
you a taste how the natural
language processing uh project how we
work with the data just to give you the
taste of our data okay
so i think we are we are completed with
pro with this project i'll be i'll be
catching up you in the uh maybe uh the
next i think that we are done with this
uh this course maybe i will do i will
maybe we will talk about simple
perceptron and then we will wrap up this
course okay so thank you for seeing this
course i would highly
congratulate you for completing this
course
you